Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, warst du auf dem Oktoberfest?
Ich hätte die Gelegenheit gehabt.
Aber du wolltest nicht?
Ich wollte nicht. Ich war in München, hatte dort einen Vortrag bei den Jusos zu halten. Aber für mich ist ja das Bier trinken schon gar nichts. Und in ein Festzelt reinzugehen, ist eigentlich auch nicht so meine Sache. Insofern habe ich dann nur am Bahnhof ein bisschen Oktoberfeststimmung verspürt, wenn da die Leute aus nicht Bayern irgendwo mit Lederhosen ankommen und dann sich früh anstellen müssen, um da hinzukommen, also schon um 8 Uhr. Also es ist doch erstaunlich, diese eigenartige Biertrinkkultur. Aber ich bin natürlich froh, dass es stattfindet, dass gefeiert wird. Auch wenn es nicht meine Sache ist. Aber ich finde das gut. Ich finde nicht gut, dass wir Politiker haben, die erst noch eine Verschärfung der Corona-Regeln abstimmen, dafür stimmen. Und dann aber selbst aufs Oktoberfest fahren. Und das ist auch nicht mehr, ja, wir sind ja alle Menschen, sondern nein, da versucht man einfach mit zweierlei Maß zu messen. Beziehungsweise nimmt sich selbst immer völlig aus der Gleichung raus, als hätte das alles mit einem selbst nichts zu tun. Und das ist für mich so ein symptomatischer Fall von Politik, wie wir sie die ganze Zeit erleben, dass etwas verabschiedet wird. Aber das natürlich für einen selbst jetzt nicht gilt. Und dass da auch gar nicht der Widerspruch mehr erkannt, wird und naja, das hat mich wiederum sehr geärgert. Was mich gefreut hat, war, das passt ein bisschen zu deiner Alten Republik, ich hatte einen Vortrag in einem Seniorenheim. Ich muss viel mehr sagen, in einer Seniorenresidenz war es. Und ich habe es angenommen, weil es so eine kuriose Anfrage war, einen Vortrag über Filme in einer Seniorenresidenz zu halten. Weil ich sowas noch nie gemacht habe, dachte ich, vielleicht geht man dahin und lernt noch etwas. Und so war es dann auch tatsächlich. Zunächst habe ich gelernt, dass man auch da, und jetzt müssen sich alle ganz festhalten, Risikogruppe und so weiter, dass man dort dann im Saal bei einem Vortrag sitzt und die Maske abzieht. Ja, das gehört dazu.
Also waren noch viele Senioren da oder war es nur die Location?
Nein, nein, es waren nur Senioren da. Das hat man dann noch nicht öffnen können, sagte man mir mit Bedauern. Sonst lässt man nämlich auch Gäste von außerhalb bei solchen Vorträgen und Veranstaltungen rein. Aber das war immer noch halt ein bisschen schwierig alles. Aber es ist auch sehr schwierig, wieder Menschen dazu zu bewegen, ihre Zimmer zu verlassen und wieder an der Gesellschaft teilzunehmen. Und was ich aber eigentlich gelernt habe, und das fand ich ganz bemerkenswert, ich fragte dann so ganz vorsichtig, und da machen sie jeden Monat so eine Veranstaltung. Und dann sahen die beiden Damen, die das organisieren, mich an und sagten, nee, mehrmals die Woche machen wir hier was. Also wir machen Filmabende, hier sind Konzerte, hier sind Vorträge und, und, und.
Urlaub bis zum Lebensende.
Es ist wirklich Urlaub bis zum Lebensende. Und man darf sich das aber jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass da die große Nostalgie-Show aufgefahren wird. Also es gibt da nicht von morgens bis abends Heimatfilme oder so etwas. Ganz im Gegenteil, es wird auch die Feuerzangenbohle partout nicht gezeigt. Also sagte dann die eine Dame zu mir, da weigert sie sich beharrlich. Das wird gewünscht, aber es wird nicht gemacht.
Genau, es wird nämlich gewünscht.
Es wird gewünscht, aber es wird nicht gemacht. Und warum? Und das fand ich sehr gut. Wir müssen aufpassen, gerade wenn wir es mit alten Leuten zu tun haben, dass wir aus ihnen keine Zeitzeugen machen. Die sollen alle Gegenwart, die sollen mit der Gegenwart leben. Und wenn die nämlich Besuch bekommen von ihren Enkeln und von ihren Kindern, dann sollen die sich über einen aktuellen Film unterhalten können und sagen, ja den habe ich auch gesehen oder ein aktuelles Buch. Dann sollen die nicht sagen, das war damals schön mit dem Heinz Rühmann vor 100 Jahren. Nein, die sollen in der Gegenwart sein, die sollen keine Zeitzeugen werden. Das fand ich wirklich einen sehr, sehr guten Satz.
Ja, das ist wahnsinnig gut. Ich höre das zum ersten Mal so, denn sonst ist immer die Gefahr, gerade wenn man jemanden wie dich zum Thema Film unter alte Leute schickt, dass da eine große Einigkeit herrscht, dass natürlich der beste Film aller Zeiten, einer aus der schwarz-weiß Zeit ist.
Und ich vielleicht auch noch mal eine kleine Jopi-Histas-Demokratie hinlege.
Genau, dass du die dann auch noch mal zurückkatapultierst und das Standardprogramm wie Netflix machst und alle noch mal in den 60ern, wobei Netflix sich die 80er ausgesucht hat, verwickelst. Sehr gut, ja, das ist ein sehr starker Satz. Wir wollen sie hier auf der Höhe des Moments haben. Gerade im Kontakt mit den Jungen, denn nichts bringt die Generation weiter auseinander als das Medienverhalten. Man redet nicht nur über unterschiedliche Themen, sondern man konsumiert auch komplett unterschiedlich. Ich habe es jetzt an mir wiedergemerkt. Ich habe eine Zeit abonniert. Ich hatte ja davon gesprochen, dieses 9-Euro-Ticket, 9 Euro in 9 Wochen. Ich habe es natürlich vergessen zu kündigen. Und dann kam die Rechnung über 300 Euro für ein Jahr Zeit. Genau. Und ich habe mir gedacht, warum nicht? Beiß ich in den sauren Apfel. Das Problem ist allerdings, wie ich feststellte, ich bin ein Zeit-Print-Abonnent. Wenn ich also auf Zeit.de irgendwelche Texte hinter der Paywall finde, kann ich mich gar nicht als Abonnent irgendwo erkennen gehen. Irgend sowas. Ich bin jetzt wirklich nur ein Papier-Abonnent. Ich bin gefesselt ans Papier und die Webseite nützt mir sogar nichts. Ich bin auch mal so richtig zurückgeworfen auf heute ist Donnerstag, heute war sie wieder. Es hat nicht geregnet. Letzte Woche war sie komplett pitchnass, als ich sie dann Freitag rausholte. Heute habe ich sie nochmal geschützt vor Wettereinflüssen, was man so alles macht. Die Medien nochmal vor Wettereinflüssen schützen. Gut, wir sind heute hier versammelt um einen vollgepackten September zu besprechen. Viele Sachen reißen wir tatsächlich nur an. Wir haben uns am Anfang gedacht, wir greifen mal diesen Running Gag auf, dass wir nämlich hier immer wieder subtil oder explizit aufrufen. Das Buch über das Erbe Merkels muss mal geschrieben werden. Wir sorgen gerne für Materialsammlung, aber es muss dann jemand mit Format mal schreiben. Wir haben ja auch diesen Monat ein Buch mit Leuten von Formate, die uns ein Thema, das uns sehr am Herzen liegt, uns für den Salon hingelegt haben. Heute Morgen, just auf dem Weg aus dem Bett an diesen Schreibtisch, habe ich Deutschlandfunk gehört. Es tauchte schon in den entsprechenden Chatgruppen auf. Dann habe ich es selber noch mal im Original gehört und habe gedacht, jawohl, genau so muss man es machen. Wir hören Andreas Jung im Deutschlandfunk. Er ist der energiepolitische Sprecher der CDU-Fraktion. Was man so hat heute, um für Klamot zu sorgen. Genau, man hat noch eine kleine Rollenverteilung. Man hat nicht nur alles auf Jens Spahn usw. zugemünzt. Wir hören einfach in dieses Gespräch rein. Und zwar relativ früh. Der Deutschlandfunk-Journalist hat sich das gleich als erste Frage nach der Gesprächseröffnung rausgesucht. Er fand das Angebot, was ihm gemacht wurde von Andreas Jung durch die erste Pseudo-Antwort gut. Er hat deswegen gesagt, okay, dann gehe ich jetzt all in und reagiere auf eine vorbereitete Antwort. Das kennt man ja. Politiker wollen erst mal ihren Talking-Point unterbringen. Mit einer sehr vorbereiteten, sehr richtigen und durch Glück dann auch passenden Frage.
Jürgen, da müssen wir einen Schritt zurückgehen. CDU und CSU und auch die SPD haben die völlig verfehlte Energiepolitik der vergangenen Jahrzehnte zu verantworten. Sie haben auch dafür gesorgt, dass die Bundeswehr nur bedingt einsatzbereit ist. Wie viel Zeit räumen Sie der Ampel ein, um 16 Jahre Merkel zu reparieren?
Das ist zu schwarz-weiß dargestellt, wie Sie sehen.
Wie bitte?
Wie bitte? Gleich nochmal nachgedrückt.
Ja, genau so muss man es machen.
Genau, das ist auch nicht zu schwarz-weiß, sondern das ist einfach ganz schwarz dargestellt, so wie es sich gehört.
Wie soll es denn auch in Graubereiche gehen? Denn tatsächlich haben die ja regiert. Man kann ja nicht sagen, es war aber eigentlich ganz anders. Aber das ist genau die richtige Art, wie man mit ihnen umgehen soll und sofort auch nochmal nachfragen und sich nichts bieten lassen. Ich kann das sehr empfehlen. Ich meine, wir können uns warm machen mit dem Gegenteil, wenn du möchtest. Also das war jetzt vorbildlicher Journalismus. Ich habe es eigentlich für den Schluss aufgehoben, aber wir können uns schon ein bisschen Bluthochdruck produzieren. Es passt zum Thema, wie stellt man keine Fragen. Dann gehen wir jetzt glotz in diesen Exkurs. Es gibt eine Sendung bei Funk, die heißt Kreuzverhör. Kreuzverhör klingt ja so, dass man sich als Politiker ein bisschen fürchten muss. Was haben diese jungen Journalisten davor? Eine Moderatorin und ein Moderator sitzen gegenüber. Es ist nur ein Politiker da, in diesem Fall Christian Lindner. Ich erspare uns einfach die Antworten von Christian Lindner, denn die können wir uns selbst auch im Kopf zusammen denken. Jetzt heißt diese Sendung Kreuzverhör. Funk ist ja ein Quell ewiger Inspiration und Freude für mich, wie alle wissen. Nun schauen wir mal an, wie die Sendung beginnt.
Ich freue mich, vielen Dank für die Anleitung.
Würde man so jemanden, den man als Kreuzverhör nehmen möchte begrüßen?
Das klingt so ganz gar nicht nach Kreuzverhör, aber gut.
Gar nicht, ne? Ich habe jetzt einfach mal vier Fragen rausgenommen. Es gibt erst so zwei, drei Kurzfragen und dann noch mal eine etwas längere Frage. Was sind denn jetzt diese Fragen, mit denen man Lindner so richtig bekommen kann?
Wie viele Stunden schlafen Sie gerade im Schnitt?
Oder auch?
In welchem Jahr wird denn jetzt wirklich der erste legale Joint verkauft?
Oder Stefan, was uns alle umtreibt? Wer wird dieses Jahr deutscher Fußballmeister? Man muss der Fernes halber sagen, es ging dann auch noch um Inhaltliches, aber nie um Inhaltliches im Sinne von, was für eine Rolle spielt eigentlich gerade Christian Lindner. In der EU als Austeritätspolitiksvertreter und was bedeutet das für den europäischen Zusammenhalt? Nichts davon. Es wurde zwar mal vom neuen Euro-Tick, das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr und wie könnte das aussehen? Aber das sind alles Fragen, die so offen gestellt werden, dass natürlich ein Lindner darin nur baden kann und sagen kann, ich kann ihnen versprechen, es wird und wir sind dabei und so weiter. Also es gab nicht eine einzige Frage, die ihn nur annähernd in die Predoye brachte. Und selbstverständlich lernen hier die Jungen auch schon von den Älteren. Man will ja vielleicht auch irgendwann mal Anne Wilbe erben. Dann gibt es selbstverständlich auch diese Frage hier.
Sollten wir jetzt direkt Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine liefern, wie auch ihre Kollegin Marie-Agnieszka Zimmermann fordert?
Das ist eine Frage, die man einem Finanzminister natürlich sofort stellen müsste.
Vor allem sollten wir jetzt, nur mal kurz gefragt, direkt Kampfpanzer schicken oder indirekt drohen? Oder wie ist das gemeint, diese Frage?
Entsprechend fiel dann die Verabschiedung aus.
Herr Lindner, wir sind schon am Schluss angekommen.
Ich hoffe, bei Ihnen ist alles okay.
Da muss dann selbst Christian Lindner lachen. Alles okay. Also sag mal, wir haben dir wirklich nicht wehgetan. Ist übrigens meine Erfahrung, ich will da niemanden zu nahe treten, aber wenn man mit Fernsehredaktionen zu tun hat und vorher telefoniert, bekommt man immer so Sachen gesagt wie, ja wir wollen auch, dass du okay damit bist, dass du gefilmt wirst. Und ich denke mir, genau deswegen gehe ich ja wahrscheinlich ins Fernsehen, um nicht gefilmt zu werden.
Ja, ist auch ein sehr guter Monat, wo wir jetzt und wir reden später drüber, feststellt, dass in Italien jetzt doch anders gewählt wurde und so weiter und auch für die Italiener so ein bisschen überraschend. Das erste Mal so ein Ergebnis. Und wir wissen ja eigentlich, das ist auch deutsche Finanzpolitik gewesen, die diese Achse Draghi Macron zum Beispiel zerschlagen hat. Wir hören nachher Ursula von der Leyen, wie sie das versucht, noch mal ein bisschen zu retten, neue Verschuldungsregeln, auch wirklich auch Maastricht infrage stellt, alle EU-Verträge neu schreiben möchte. Und zwar immer als Generationenverträge. Also völlig überraschendes Zeug. Aber nichts davon schlägt sich hier nieder. Hauptsache, Christian Lindner geht es noch gut. Der hat ja auch eine anstrengende Hochzeit hinter sich.
Wenig Schlaf, Donnerkeil.
Genau. Sehr guter Exkurs. Kommen wir zurück zu da, wo keine Journalisten hingeschaut haben. Nämlich Fridays for Future hat ja einen kleinen Aufschlag gemacht vor zwei Wochen in der Bundespressekonferenz. Natürlich nicht im großen Saal, wo kämen wir da hin, wenn da noch eine Fernsehkamera anwesend wäre. Sie haben sich Hilfe geholt bei Marcel Fratscher, um, finde ich, im richtigen Moment mal die Frage zu stellen, 100 Milliarden für Krieg, warum nicht 100 Milliarden fürs Klima? Fratscher hat eine kleine Anmerkung gemacht, die wir auch noch mal unter diesem Tenor 16 Jahre Merkel erbe. Wer schreibt es auf? Abheften in die Materialsammlung. Denn er hat sich sehr bedankt für die Gelegenheit und auch die Freude, nicht nur als Wissenschaftler, sondern auch als Familien irgendwas und auch normaler Bürger und Mensch hier beisteuern zu können. Also im Sinne von Scientist for Future, das Engagement geht immer über die eigene Profession und Aufgabenstellung hinaus. Und dann kam er aber gleich zurück auf seine volkswirtschaftlichen Analysen, die hier gefragt wurden, und hat sie politisch zurückgebunden.
Aber zweitens, und das glaube ich, realisieren viele nicht, wir haben einen großen Fehler begangen, was den Klimaschutz betrifft. Denn wenn wir vor zehn Jahren in Deutschland den Ausbau erneuerbar Energien, Klimaschutz und andere Maßnahmen, energetische Gebäudesanierung, schneller vorangebracht hätten, so wie es auch anfänglich geplant wäre, dann hätten wir heute bei weitem nicht eine so große soziale und wirtschaftliche Krise, wie wir haben. Also sprich, wenn heute Menschen in Schieflage sind, Probleme haben, nicht wissen, wie sie ihre Rechnung zahlen sollen, weil Energiepreise durch die Decke schießen, weil 9% Inflation da ist, weil Nährungsmittel teurer werden, dann lässt sich das direkt auf die Fehler im Klimaschutz in den vergangenen 10 bis 20 Jahren zurückführen. Und das gilt es erst einmal einzugestehen, dass man nicht nur geopolitisch den Fehler gemacht hat, sondern eben auch beim Klimaschutz. Und es gilt jetzt diese Fehler zu korrigieren. Wir haben heute nicht nur für die Menschen, für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger eine dramatische Situation, sondern auch für die Wirtschaft. Viele Unternehmen können mit den hohen Energiepreisen über fossile Energieträger nicht umgehen, sind von Insolvenz und Überschuldung bedroht und wir in Deutschland riskieren, dass unser Wirtschaftsmodell wegbricht.
So, sehr harter Abschluss in diesem Ausschnitt. Es droht uns, das Wirtschaftssystem wegzubrechen, was ja heißt, ok, da muss man wirklich nochmal an die Grundzüge neu überdenken und so weiter. Und er hat diese Klammer aufgemacht. Wir stehen heute schlecht da, was das zivilgesellschaftliche und private Leben in Deutschland betrifft, was die Unternehmer und das Unternehmertun betrifft und was unsere Erwartungen an, kann uns die Natur eigentlich noch länger versorgen oder haben wir da auch künftig, laufen wir da in Wände hinein. Und alles drei hätte man mit einer guten Klimapolitik auffangen können, weil man dann gleichzeitig so eine ökonomische Resilienz eben nicht mehr diese Abhängigkeit und so weiter gehabt hätte. Geopolitisch, wie aber auch wirtschaftlich. Genau. Und es ist im Grunde eine Win-Win-Win-Situation, die wir damals ausgeschlagen haben auf Grundpartikulare Interessen, weil irgendwer meinte, ich habe einen Atomkraftwerk und es bringt mir 300 Millionen im Monat. Ich habe keine Lust, das auszuschalten. Und dann hat man da natürlich einen entsprechenden Einfluss und dann bleibt das eben auch an, obwohl schon die politischen Entscheidungen eigentlich alle anders laufen und wir sehen ja, das zieht sich bis jetzt. Also Habeck hat wieder entschieden. Wir haben im letzten Monat noch darüber gescherzt, dass er, also Habeck, die zwei Atombetreiber da in diese Lage rein zwingt, ihr Atomkraftwerk in Betrieb zu halten, aber keine Gewinne mehr abzuschöpfen. Und jetzt kriegen sie trotzdem ihre Gewinne weiter, zumindest die zwei in Süddeutschland. Auch weil die CSU da eine Energiepolitik gemacht hat, die halt einfach keinen Weg dran vorbeiführt. Aber, und er sagte ja, jetzt müssen wir es machen. Fratsch hat gesagt, jetzt sollten wir mal, also der Zeitpunkt ist jetzt. Und wir haben ja häufiger diskutiert, ja, es mangelt ja nicht an Geld. Wir könnten es ja einfach machen. Wir brauchen nur eine Neujustierung des Grundgesetzes in Sachen Schuldenbremse. Kommen wir also zurück zu diesem Gespräch von heute Morgen. Da war nämlich nicht nur der Knaller drin mit, dass der Deutschlandfunk Andreas Jung fragt, was ist jetzt mit 16 Jahre Merkel und wie viel Zeit räumen sie denn der Regierung ein, ihre Fehler wettzumachen, sondern es ist auch ein endloses Gestammel zur Schuldenbremse mittlerweile. Die Ideologie zerbröselt auf allen Ecken. Deswegen hören wir uns gar nicht in Länge an, sondern nur dieses kleine Finale, was da noch stattfand. Wir steigen also mit der Frage ein, wo der Journalist noch mal klugerweise darauf reagiert, zugehört hat, was gerade gesagt wurde und dann versucht noch mal so ein bisschen Restintelligenz herauszuschirfen aus Andreas Jungs Parteilinie.
Herr Jung, das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ganz kurz, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, die Union stellt jetzt vorsichtig die Schuldenbremse in Frage.
Nein, wir stellen nicht die Schuldenbremse in Frage. Nein, ich habe darauf hingewiesen, dass die Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz, ohne dass die Ausnahmeregelung der Schuldenbremse gezogen werden muss, so wie sie konzipiert ist, eine Konjunkturkomponente hat. Wenn die Konjunktur gut ist, erlaubt sie keine oder wenig Schuldenaufnahme. Und wenn sie schwächelt, dann erlaubt sie ohne Ausnahmemodus etwas mehr Schuldenaufnahme. Das könnten im nächsten Jahr 30 Milliarden Euro sein, ohne an die Schuldenbremse ranzugehen. Das ist gar nicht in Frage, dass da irgendwas im Grundgesetz geändert wird, ohne dass die Ausnahmeregelung gezogen wird. Die Einschätzung des Bundesfinanzministers, dass das nicht erforderlich ist und zeigt, sie ist klug konzipiert, so wie man sie gemeinsam ins Grundgesetz geschrieben hat.
Ist nur die Frage, ob das dann auch hinhaut.
So weit kommt es noch, dass wir da nochmal eingreifen ins Gesetz. Aber das wird ja noch. Man sieht hier wirklich, dass sie noch mit aller Gewalt daran festhalten. Ich bin gespannt. Ich würde sagen, das ist auch noch nicht ausgemacht. Nur weil eine Ideologie völlig hohl geworden ist, kann es ja trotzdem noch wirksam sein.
Wir haben jetzt die Situation, dass die Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau pro Jahr 60 Milliarden über Kredite locker macht, die zum Ziele hat, Subventionen abzustützen und abzusichern oder halt direkt zu bezahlen, die im Bundestag als Politik entschieden wurden, ohne dass das dann in die Schuldenbremse eingerechnet wird. Also die machen ganz klare politische Programmatik im Bundestag entschieden, ohne dass in die Schuldenbremsrechnung reingeht. Dann steht Scholz da und verkündet einfach 100 Milliarden, überrascht seine eigenen Regierungsparteien, wird alles in irgendwelche Schattenhaushalte versteckt. Schuldenbremse bleibt aber.
Und Fridays for Future kommt und sagt, ja, dann können wir auch ein Sondervermögen 100 Milliarden machen fürs Klima.
Die sagen dann auch den Weg, also wenn ihr euch darauf geeinigt habt, dass das strukturell möglich ist, dann fordern wir nicht einfach nur, haltet mal Paris ein, was ja gar nicht unsere Forderung ist. Es ist ja eurer völkerrechtliches Einverständnis, dass das nötig ist. Und wir einigen uns sogar darauf, dass wir euren Weg gehen über Sondervermögen und Schattenhaushalte und so weiter als zu organisieren. Also eigentlich ein ganz großes Zugeständnis an die Regierenden, wenigstens deren Quatsch, dann einfach im eigenen Anliegen mitzumachen. Und dann haben wir hier mit Christian Lindner, der eben sagt, ja, aber nächstes Jahr halten wir die Schuldenbremse wieder ein, dass selbst die CDU als Opposition, die für den ganzen Quatsch verantwortlich ist, dann nochmal dieses Zugeständnis macht. Ja, wir bleiben bei der Schuldenbremse, aber selbst wir gehen über Schattenhaushaltkonstruktion hinaus und argumentieren direkt mit der Schuldenbremsenformulierung im Grundgesetz und finden da noch Lücken, aber die Schuldenbremse bleibt. Und das ist ein Gestammel um den heißen Brei herum. Um statt einfach mal zu sagen, wir haben uns gehört, es war ein großer historischer Fehler. Eigentlich bräuchten wir so einen Fukushima im Moment, das wir einfach feststellen, es ist, wie es ist.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht von der, also es wird ja auch nicht von den Grünen gesagt. Also das ist ja schon interessant, man wird es irgendwo in der Basis finden. Aber eigentlich müsste Habeck sagen, die Schuldenbremse war der größte Fehler. Wir müssen die Schuldenbremse jetzt loswerden, sonst können wir das vergessen mit unserem Wohlstand, mit dem, was uns im Winter droht, mit allem, was uns in den kommenden, man muss es ja schon sagen, Jahrzehnten droht. Diese Akkumulierung von Krisen, es kommt ja noch Weiteres sicherlich hinzu in all den Jahren. Und eigentlich müsste er es so formulieren, er tut es aber auch nicht. Weshalb ich glaube, das ist auch bei den Grünen, und ich habe es ja auch schon auf Podien erlebt mit Grünen, so wie mit Rebecca Hams oder so. Es gibt tatsächlich auch da dieses Schwäbische Hausfrau-Denken.
Die Grünen sind sehr stark in Baden-Württemberg.
Das ist ja der Schlimmste von allen.
Es ist ja nicht nur die Schwäbische Hausfrau im Sinne von, sondern es ist ja tatsächlich diese Ideologie da, wo die Industrie so stark ist, und man sagt, man muss ja es mal leisten und schaffen und so, und dann organisiert man das schon irgendwie.
Der wollte doch, hieß es nicht, dass der dann irgendwann aus dem Amt ausscheidet, dass er nicht noch eine ganze Abendzeit macht.
Kretschmann? Ja, Cem Özdemir steht irgendwie bereit, aber der ist jetzt auch erst mal Bauernminister geworden.
Aber der will wahrscheinlich jetzt noch weitermachen, ne? Also es gibt ja auch keine Rebellion gegen den.
Also, sagen wir's mal so, es gibt sehr viele junge Menschen, die nach Baden-Württemberg eingewandert sind, weil sie da tolle ökonomische Möglichkeiten finden, die es unmöglich finden, wie sie dort regiert werden, gerade durch Corona hindurch und so. Es war ja alles ganz schlimm, und Winfried Kretschmann ist ja einer der allerersten, der immer gleich kommt mit. Also bei Corona kein Eingeständnis, wir arbeiten gegen das Virus und so weiter. Genau, dann diese ganze Waschlappensache, also wir individualisieren hier jedes Problem, setzt die Maske auf, nutzt den Waschlappen, geh nicht duschen und so. Also da wird ja alles auf die Spitze getrieben. Die Grünen, ich glaube Habeck und so weiter, die haben auch gerade zu viel Eisen im Feuer, und da sind zu viele Gespräche, die nach hinten losgehen, gerade vor Publikum. Die hoffen vielleicht so ein bisschen drauf, dass die Maurice Höfgens und so weiter dieser Welt das alles noch ein bisschen torpedieren, dass sie in so ein gemachtes Feld sozusagen einsteigen.
Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Sie müssen wütig sein und es eigentlich machen.
Das machen sie nicht. Und naja, Kretschmer ist ja wirklich...
Auf den darf man nicht hoffen.
Nein, dass der überhaupt noch da ist, ist eigentlich das große Wunder.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es gibt aber auch alte Leute, die natürlich noch voll da sind bis zum Schluss, nämlich Leute wie die Queen, die noch zwei Tage vor ihrem Tode das Truss empfängt. Dort stand mit Stock, aber es ist erstaunlich, dass sie noch stand, also wie das alles noch möglich ist. Es ist wohl diese eiserne Disziplin, dass man auch sagt, ich bin nun mal die Königin und muss noch mal raus.
Genau, und da schieben wir kurz ein, die eiserne Disziplin. Also es ist jetzt Wolfgangs Bewunderung und Begeisterung, die dieses Thema hier nochmal reinhebt.
Du kommst jetzt nicht raus, denn man muss den Leuten sagen, du hast im Fernsehpodcast über drei Stunden nur über die Queen geredet. Und ich dachte, was ist da los? Und deswegen, die erste Frage geht an dich. Du, Systemtheoretiker Stefan, bist du etwa ein Royalist?
Also es gibt natürlich funktionale Argumentationen. Ich habe auch gleich eine vorbereitet. Wir müssen uns allerdings erst warmreden bei dem Thema. Ich habe gesehen, du hast viele Clips dabei. Ich wollte nur kurz markieren, weil wir, als wir am Sonntag über die Queen sprachen, auch uns die Scherze erlaubt haben, als der Chat dann anfing zu fragen, wann hört denn das Queen-Thema auf? Wann redet ihr denn über die richtigen Sachen im Fernsehen? Und wir dann sagten, wir reden heute nur über die Queen. Und zwar aus vollem Herzen und völlig zu Recht. Und war für mich im Grunde abgehakt. Aber nachdem du mir angekündigt hast, wir reden auch über die Queen, habe ich mir noch mal einen Punkt für nachher bereitgelegt, eine Argumentation, die noch mal gemacht werden muss. Aber ich bin auch sehr gespannt, was du uns jetzt nochmal zum Thema mitbringst.
Wir steigen lustig ein mit einer Anekdote, die vor einer Weile schon der Leibwächter der Queen erzählte.
Normalerweise, auf diesen Picknick-Sites, du hast niemanden kennengelernt, aber es gab zwei Heiker, die uns kamen, und die Queen würde immer aufhören und sagen Hallo. Und es waren zwei Amerikaner, auf einer Wartesprache. Und der amerikanische Gentleman sagte der Queen, woher er kam, wo sie nachher gehen würden und wo sie in Briten waren. Und sie sagte, ich wohne in London, aber ich habe ein Weihnachtshaushalt auf der anderen Seite der Heide. Oh, ich bin hierher gekommen, seit ich als Kind war, also seit über 80 Jahren. Und man kann die Klagen sehen. Und als schnell als er klopfte, sagte er, ich nicht, die Schnauze hierher trifft sie regelmäßig. Und dann, die nächste Sache, die ich wusste, dieser Typ kam um, legte seine Arme um meine Schulter, und bevor ich gesehen hatte, was passiert war, hat er seine Kamera, gibt es der Queen, und sagt, kannst du eine Foto von uns zwei nehmen? Wir haben die Plätze gewechselt, und ich habe eine Foto mit der Queen gemacht, und wir haben sie nie aufgehört, und wir haben aufgehört, und dann hat der Queen gesagt, ich würde gerne ein Flieger auf der Wiese sein, wenn er uns Fotos von den Freunden in Amerika zeigt.
Das zeigt sehr schön, wie die Queen so tickte, also dann auf amerikanische Touristen zu treffen, die sie nicht erkennen, sie eine große Freude dabei hat und dann entspinnt sich dieses wunderbare Schauspiel.
Es sind unendlich viele Geschichten, die jetzt nicht mehr erzählt werden können von ihr. Sie hat Churchill verabschiedet, mit John F. Kennedy gefeiert und danach auch noch 50, 60, 70 Jahre weiter gemacht. Und sie hat nie in ihrem Leben ein Interview gegeben. Keine Bücher geschrieben, nichts. Das heißt, wir leben jetzt von solchen Geschichten und müssen da einfach sagen, das ist einfach eine ganz besondere Konstellation von Amt und Person und so weiter. Und es ist ein unendlicher Fundus, sich hier auch noch einfach zu amüsieren über solche Sachen.
Ja, es ist auch schön, welche Videos man dann so bei YouTube sehen kann. Ich habe mich ja dann auch dabei enttappt, dass ich dann noch mal schaue, wie war das, als Papst Benedikt zu Besuch bei der Queen war. Und sie dann sagt, oh, that was a tiny car. Weil sie dann doch etwas verwundert ist, mit welchem Auto er dann da ankommt. Also es ist einfach wunderbar, sich das anzusehen. Und ja, es ist aber auch das große Mysterium, dass man über sie nicht in dem Sinne etwas weiß, dass man sagt, ach ja, genau, jetzt haben wir jetzt was Privates mal wirklich erfahren. Und das hat mich natürlich immer so fasziniert an der Queen. Das ist ja ähnlich wie bei Lagerfeld. Also man kann, glaube ich, diese beiden Personen sehr gut parallel betrachten. Das ist übrigens das auch, was dieser wunderbare Film mit Helen Mirren in der Hauptrolle, der einfach nur die Queen heißt, so wunderbar eingefangen hat. Denn es ist ein Film, der von den schwierigen Jahren handelt, beziehungsweise von den schwierigen Wochen dann ganz speziell mit Diana's Tod, wo die Queen in irgendeiner Weise reagieren muss, sich menschlich zeigen muss, zugleich aber auch das Protokoll nicht verletzen darf. Und wie man da versucht, einen Weg zu finden. Und ich bin ja nun alles andere als ein Monarchist, sondern bin natürlich als Linker dafür, dass so etwas abgeschafft wird und dass auch Menschen sowas nicht brauchen sollten. Wir kommen aber dazu gleich noch, was man braucht und nicht und so. Aber man kann ja auch einfach es als Phänomen zunächst einmal wahrnehmen, schätzen und diese Form, Stränge, die sie in all das reingebracht hat, ist etwas, was mich zutiefst beeindruckt. Schon deshalb, weil man hier sehen kann, dass sich jemand ganz zurücknimmt. Und du hast da einen Clip gehabt im Podcast, den wir nochmal abspielen müssen, nämlich von Christopher Clarke, der sagte, dass das eigentlich das Besondere war, dass die Queen sich nicht in den Mittelpunkt gerückt hat.
Darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem Historiker Christopher Clarke, Professor an der Universität Cambridge und auch hier in Deutschland bestens bekannt, unter anderem durch sein Buch Die Schlafwandler über den Beginn des ersten Weltkriegs. Guten Abend, Herr Clarke. Elisabeth wurde ja 1926 in der Zwischenkriegszeit geboren und war insofern eine Königin, die von Kindheit an in einer erschütterten Welt lebte. Aber sie selbst wirkte immer vollkommen unerschütterlich. Ist es das, womit diese Monarchen der Nation immer Halt gab?
Absolut. Also die Königin hat mit einer unglaublichen Stätigkeit regiert. Überall um sie herum gab es Menschen, die, wie eben Menschen so sind, sich Verfehlungen zu leisten meinten. Es gab Ehe-Trennungen, es gab Skandale und was weiß ich, das normale Halt, was Menschen, was auf die Menschen zukommt. Aber sie immer stets, also ganz, ganz fest in ihrer Rolle und spielte sie noch mit einer so unglaublichen Teuer. Es ist interessant, also wenn man sich, wenn man, man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass Großbritannien keine geschriebene Verfassung hat. Das ist eine konstitutionelle Monarchie ohne Konstitution. Und in dieser Situation war sie sozusagen die Perkörperung, diese an sich nicht existenten Konstitutionen. Diese Rolle hat sie mit einer, mit einem exquisiten Gefühl für die Grenzen der Rolle gespielt. Sie hat sich nie persönlich geäußert zu politischen Themen. Sie hat, könnte man sagen, gänzlich im öffentlichen Leben auf ein Ich verzichtet. Also sie war nicht da, um sich selbst zu realisieren oder zu erfüllen, sondern um das Amt vorzuspielen.
Und das ist für mich überhaupt der wichtigste Clip zum Thema Queen. Also ich habe auch viel geguckt, aber das ist wirklich das Allerwichtigste, was er sagt. Zwei Dinge will ich hier herausgreifen. Sie hat diese Rolle mit einer unheimlichen Treue gespielt. Man muss also hier das Spiel auch mit sehen. Wir werden gleich noch einen Aspekt über Rituale bekommen, wo das Theater spielen wieder eine Rolle spielt. Sie hat die Rolle gespielt und als ein solches Spiel muss man das Ganze auch verstehen. Das macht es auch für uns so faszinierend, uns das anzusehen. Man kann sagen, heute gehe ich nicht ins Theater, heute gucke ich die Beerdigung der Queen. In dieser Weise hast du das ja rezipiert, denke ich. Dann gibt es noch diesen zweiten Aspekt, dass sie ihr Ich in der Öffentlichkeit nicht gezeigt hat. Sie hat das zum Verschwinden bringen lassen und hat diese Rolle nur in den Vordergrund gestellt. Was wir heute unglaublich lieben, ist ja diesen Ich-Kult. Den haben wir nicht nur bei den Influencer, sondern auch bei den Politikern, die die Home-Stories machen. Jetzt war doch auch schon wieder im Spiegel die drei jungen grünen Abgeordnete. Wir haben sie in ihrer WG besucht und dann erzählen sie privat irgendetwas. Es gibt eine wunderbare Mediensatire, vielleicht kennst du die aus den 80ern, Stonk über die Fälschung der Hitler-Tagebücher, Gottsgeorge und Hermann Juncke. Dann steht da ja ganz viel banales Zeug drin. Eva Braun sagt, ich habe Mundgeruch und so weiter.
Das ist authentisch gemacht.
Genau. Und dann sind diese Journalisten dort alle so begeistert.
Wie authentisch! Ja, also, da schlägt ja auch, selbst beim Führerschluck ein richtiges Herz.
Also in dieser Weise wird das dann rezipiert. Und das ist genau das Falsche. Und die Queen mahnte uns eigentlich mit ihrer Präsenz, mit der reinen Repräsentanz, könnte man auch sagen, immer daran, dass wir hier das Amt betrachten sollen. Und das imponiert mir so sehr.
Genau, wir haben diese ganze interessante Klammer. Das war ja auch interessant, sich sowohl die BBC als auch die deutschen Nachrichten dazu anzuschauen, dass wir die ganze Zeit nur eine Berichterstattung darüber hatten, wie haben sich die Leute gefühlt, wie haben sie gemeinsam getrauert, wie viele Blumen wurden mitgebracht. Also dieses ganz persönliche, jeder Korrespondent sollte sich dazu verhalten, dass es dieses Ereignis jetzt gibt, das so vorhersehbar war, die war 96 Jahre alt und so. Und gleichzeitig als Subjekt der Berichterstattung oder eigentlich dann wirklich Objekt der Berichterstattung war es aber eben diese Nicht-Person, sondern nur dieses Amt und dieses Schauspiel und diese dieser Schmuck die ganze Zeit, der sich ja auch durch diese zehn Tage Ritual einfach zog. Also das Protokoll wurde ja eingehalten bis aufs Letzte und selbst David Beckham stand natürlich 20 Stunden in der Schlange, um die Queen zu sehen und alle haben die Formalitäten da eingehalten und haben das Programm damit gefüllt, genau das Gegenteil zu machen, sich die ganze Zeit nach vorne zu stellen und über ihre Gefühle zu reden. Und ach, es war ja so bewegend hier zu sein. Und dann hat man sich noch so gefreut, weil am Beerdigungstag dann auch noch dieser Regenbogen über London und so. Und das war eine interessante Klammer.
Nun habe ich ein Feature gefunden, das ein paar Jahre alt ist, nämlich das wurde vom Deutschlandfunk veröffentlicht zur Hochzeit von Harry und Meghan und wir hören da erst mal einen Ausschnitt.
Meghan Markle ist der Star dieser Hochzeit. Schon bei ihren ersten Auftritten an der Seite von Harry fliegen ihr die Herzen in allen Teilen des Landes zu. Die Menschen stehen zu Hunderten an den Absperrungen und rufen, Harry, geh mal zur Seite, wir wollen Meghan sehen. Die Briten, von denen man sagt, sie zeigten Gefühle nur bei Hunden und Pferden, sie haben ihr Herz für Meghan entdeckt.
Das hat sich inzwischen gedreht, also auch interessant, wie schnell man in der Gunst des Publikums, kann man vielleicht am besten sagen, sofort sinken kann, wenn es irgendwelche Skandale gibt. Beziehungsweise spaltet sich ja die Haltung zu Meghan, nicht nur in England, sondern generell. Die einen finden sie ganz furchtbar, sie reiße das Königshaus ins Verderben, die anderen sagen großartig, sie spricht über ihre Gefühle und dann auch noch bei Oprah Winfrey. Für mich sind ja Leute, die mit Oprah Winfrey sprechen, generell nicht ernst zu nehmen. Aber sie macht natürlich mit Harry zusammen und diesen Dokus und was sie da alles vermarkten und ausschlachten, exakt das Gegenteil der Queen. Und deswegen bin ich natürlich auch, wie schon zu Zeiten von Diana, auf Seiten der Queen.
Ja, könnte aber dadurch, dass man sich vielleicht nicht erwehren kann, dass wir jetzt in dieses Instagram-Zeitalter kommen, diese dann doch notwendige Modernisierung sein für das Zeitalter nach der Queen.
Ich glaube aber, dass es dann nicht mehr funktioniert. Also ich glaube, wenn die Aura nicht mehr da ist, dann kann das Ganze nicht laufen. Ich will jetzt hier gleich als Klammer einfügen, ja, ich weiß um den britischen Kolonialismus und ich weiß auch, dass die Queen keine besonders rühmliche Rolle gespielt hat bei den Entschuldigungen, die man hätte leisten können. Das waren alles Dinge, die jetzt auch wieder diskutiert wurden. Und ich finde auch, dass sie zurecht diskutiert werden können, wenn da manche von Piertätlosigkeit sprechen, dann denke ich mir, naja, gut, das ist ja jetzt nicht gerade, dass man über die eigene Oma spricht. Das ist ja eine Figur des öffentlichen Lebens. Also so muss man es machen, sonst braucht man das ja alles gar nicht.
Das ist ja auch trotz allem eine politische Figur.
Genau. Und das ist... Worüber reden wir also hier? Das sehe ich natürlich alles, will ich aber jetzt nicht hier nochmal eigens thematisieren. Vielmehr geht es jetzt mal um das Ökonomische. Das ist auch aus diesem Deutschlandfunkbeitrag von ein paar Jahren. Was bringen eigentlich die Royals so ein?
50 Millionen Pfund Einnahmen erwarten allein die Souvenirhändler des Vereinigten Königreiches aus der Royalen Hochzeit. Insgesamt, so haben es die Experten des Marketingunternehmens Brand Finance ausgerechnet, ist das ganze Ereignis rund eine Milliarde Pfund wert. Die königliche Familie sei ein prächtiges Treibmittel für die britische Wirtschaft.
Nach unseren Berechnungen bringt die Monarchie dem britischen Tourismus rund 500 Millionen Pfund pro Jahr.
Also allein 500 Millionen Pfund, weil die da eine Queen haben. Klar, man braucht Sehenswürdigkeiten, nicht alle haben einen Eiffelturm. Also ist dann vielleicht die Queen auch was, was man sich ansieht oder die Paraden und was dort alles geboten wird. Dann gibt es natürlich die Kritiker der Royals.
80 Millionen Pfund gehen in diesem Jahr direkt an die Mitglieder der Königsfamilie. Darin enthalten ist ein dicker Zusatzbatzen für die Renovierung des Buckingham Palastes. Erwirtschaftet wird dieses Geld mit dem Besitz der Krone, erreicht von ertragreichen Landgütern bis hin zu teuren Einkaufsstraßen. Dass das Königshaus angeblich jeden Staatsbürger nur 4, 70 Pfund pro Jahr koste, wie dies die Freunde der Monarchie so gern vorrechneten, stimmen nicht, sagt Graeme Smith. Nicht nur, dass das sowieso alles Steuerzahlergeld sei, vielmehr seien in den offiziellen 80 Millionen teure Posten wie die Sicherheit oder die Nutzung von Gebäuden gar nicht berücksichtigt.
Die wirkliche Zahl liegt weit über 300 Millionen Pfund.
Gut, 80 Millionen bekommen die direkt und dann natürlich diese Renovierungsmaßnahmen, da kann man aber auch sagen, die würden ja die Schlösser nicht verfallen lassen, wenn die royale Familie jetzt nicht mehr da wäre, wie bei Harper Kerkeling, da müssen die ja fliehen. Es gibt doch diesen Harper Kerkeling Film, kennste den? Wo die Reuelts dann in den Ruhrpott kommen, weil sie im England nicht mehr geduldet werden. Ganz amüsant. Nee, die würden ja auch gepflegt werden. Und ich würde mal sagen, ich will die Reuelts nicht in dem Sinne verteidigen für das, was sie stehen und repräsentieren und so weiter. Aber jetzt mal rein ökonomisch betrachtet, wenn die 500 Millionen allein der Tourismusindustrie zu spielen, plus die ganzen anderen Dinge, plus Übertragungsrechte und was es da alles gibt und Merchandise weltweit, dann würde ich doch sagen, mit 80 Millionen Pfund sind die ein bisschen unterbezahlt, oder?
Also ökonomisch gesehen muss man sagen, in dieser Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, in der wir leben, sind das wirklich die Proto-Influencer. Die einen volkswirtschaftlichen Zugzwang haben, der es lächerlich macht, überhaupt darüber zu diskutieren, dass sie angeblich Geld kosten, weil das nicht der Fall ist.
Also da würde eine Kim Kardashian sagen, dafür stehe ich morgens nicht auf.
Ja, also es ist einfach, es ist absurd, diese Diskussion überhaupt so zu führen. Das ist, hier ist wirklich was in Bewegung und so.
Ja, wir bleiben aber beim Ökonomischen und hören rein in den Podcast von Adam Toos, Once and Toos. Auch da war die Queen Thema. Die Schwäne gehören der Queen oder jetzt dann dem König. Und das ist für mich ganz interessant, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Also was heißt das eigentlich, die gehören dem? Adam Toos führt das jetzt aus.
Die Antwort ist natürlich, dass Schweden einmal im Jahr die Piesteresistance in irgendeinem wirklich seriösen Bankett waren.
Und so, der König sei der König, hat gesagt, alle Schweden in dem Land belongen uns. Aber im Gegensatz zu den Monarchen, haben sie sie in dem Sinne, dass niemand anderes sie hat. Das ist, denke ich, die wichtige Idee hier.
Ich finde es interessant, weil es ja, es ist eine Ownerschaft, aber es ist nicht in dem Sinne, dass es eine Komplizierung ist.
Ich meine, niemand ist unter der Impression, dass der König Charles jetzt alle Schweden verkaufen.
Es ist Ownership, aber es ist nicht Commodity, also es ist keine Ware.
An wen sollte man die alle verkaufen?
Man könnte natürlich da auch noch ein Geschäft ausmachen, aber es ist keine Ware und man darf keinen Schwan töten, dann gibt es ordentlich Ärger und das hat mich natürlich auf eine Idee gebracht. Wir haben ja einen Bundespräsidenten, der unser Queen-Ersatz ist und da würden wir ja beide sagen, das haut uns jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig um, da würdest du nicht Stunden vor dem Fernseher hängen, wenn da irgendwas wäre. Eher nicht. Und das liegt ja auch daran, dass man nicht so recht weiß, was soll man eigentlich mit diesem Amt, vielleicht könnten wir dieses Amt doch mal aufwerten dadurch, dass wir auch so eine Ownership, aber nicht Commodity-Sache daraus machen. Also könnten wir nicht Sachen sagen bei Dingen, die wir auf keinen Fall privatisieren wollen, die nicht Commodity werden sollen, wie zum Beispiel Autobahnen, wie zum Beispiel Trinkwasser, wie zum Beispiel Stadtparks und was weiß ich, dass man sagt, die gehören dem Bundespräsidenten, aber der kann kein Commodity, keine Ware daraus machen. Also damit könnte man das Amt nochmal gut aufwerten und würde eine sehr interessante Enteignungsdebatte von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge führen.
Also man würde den Bundespräsidenten zu so einem teilhabenden Geschäftsführer der Deutschland AG machen, dann einfach für die Zeit im Amt die Verantwortung hat.
Dass das keine Ware wird.
Dass das bleibt, ja. Dass das bleibt. Ins Grundgesetz damit.
Ins Grundgesetz, genau. Und dann können wir immer wieder sagen, ne, also ein Grundgesetz steht, also da kommen wir jetzt ja nicht hin, dass wir das nochmal ändern. Bei Hard Aber Fair, was ich sonst nie sehe, aber ich hab's mir hier mal angesehen, in, ich glaube, zehnfacher Geschwindigkeit, um es auszuhalten. Da war also auch alles um die Queen zu Gast. Unter anderem war James Hors, der Autor ist und sich mit der Monarchie auskennt und so weiter. Und der kommt jetzt auf diese Rituale zu sprechen, die du ja auch schon mit Begeisterung rezipiert hast. Und ihm gegenüber steht Sascha Lobo, der gar nicht einverstanden ist. Aber wir hören jetzt erst mal James Hors reden.
Mich interessiert, ob es die angebliche Tradition ist, die heute so wunderbar dargestellt wurde. Meine Mutter ist 1930 geboren. Diese ganzen Traditionen, die hier dargestellt wurden, sind erst beim Tod von Queen Victoria aus dem Nichts ausgegriffen. Warum ausgerechnet da? Man hatte keine Tradition mehr, sie hatte ja so lange regiert. Man wusste gar nicht, was machen, wenn ein König ist. Und es war ein Theaterregisseur, mehr oder weniger, der das alles erfunden hat. 30 Jahre vor dem Geburt meiner Mutter. Das ist keine uralte Tradition. Das ist nicht mal so alt wie die Gedächtniskirche zu Berlin. Das waren Traditionen.
Sie enttäuschen mich. Ich hatte gedacht, es wäre tatsächlich mindestens vier Jahre.
Ich finde, Rituale müssen nicht immer historisch begründet werden, um ihren Wert und ihren Gehalt zu haben. Es reichen auch funktionale Gründe. Das kennt jeder aus therapeutischen Zusammenhängen, wenn man versucht, bei manchen Menschen oder auch in der Erziehung so ein paar Routinen mal zu etablieren. Wenn man dann immer kommt mit, das sollten wir eigentlich schon immer so gemacht haben, ansonsten können wir das nicht erklären, ist das ein falscher Ansatz.
Und wann ist denn schon für immer, wenn man sagt, ich dachte, die waren 400 Jahre alt. Aber wo ist jetzt der Unterschied, ob die 80 Jahre alt sind oder 400 Jahre alt sind? Es ist ganz erstaunlich, dass man immer, wenn es so lang zurückklickt, dass man nicht mehr direkt jemanden befragen kann. Das ist jetzt so schockierend für ihn, weil er sagt, ja meine Mutter, wie hat das noch so und so erlebt, da war das noch nicht, da haben die sich das ausgedacht, das hat er von einem Theaterregisseur entwickelt. Also hier nochmal dieses Rollenspiel, auf das Klark auch angespielt hat, das nochmal in den Vordergrund zu stellen, aber zu sagen, die sind damals erfunden worden. Ja, und das ist ja gerade das Tolle an der menschlichen Zivilisation, sich so etwas auszudenken, weil man sich überlegt, wie geben wir einer Sache eine Form? Und das ist ja eine Frage, die sich grundsätzlich stellt, zum Beispiel, wenn jemand stirbt. Also es gibt wohl kaum Fälle, wo man einfach nur sagt, verscharrt ihn. Sondern man hat auch, wenn man längst aus der Kirche ausgetreten ist, noch den Freien Redner oder da kommt jemand und spielt das Lieblingslied und all das. Paare, die sich ja auch irgendwann treffen, kennenlernen, entwickeln meist gemeinsam Rituale, haben ein Lied, das sie verbindet, ein Restaurant, das sie immer wieder aufsuchen. Also solche Ritualisierungen sind eine sehr menschliche Eigenschaft, aber sie müssen nicht zurückreichen auf die Antike oder sowas.
Genau, vor allem der Anspruch, es muss aber historisch begründet sein, wir haben ja auch extreme Bedeutungsschwankungen, selbst bei Monarchien und Königshäusern. Also Saudi-Arabien gilt heute als Monarchie, die haben das auch einfach nur erfunden vor so ein paar Jahrzehnten und erklären sich einfach dazu. Und wenn er jetzt hier sagt, naja, das wurde dann für Königin Victoria, ja, Königin Victoria hat halt eben aus, ich will es nicht übertreiben, aber fast nichts, so ein Weltreich noch mal geschaffen. Und klar wird man dann anders beerdigt als die, vor allem Könige, die jetzt nicht so eine Mega-Geschichte sind, vor allem Königinnen, dass man das dann noch mal anders macht. Und es war ja auch für mich eine große Frage jetzt, wenn wir jetzt feststellen, okay, Königin Victoria verdient so ein großes Begräbnis, weil sie halt wirklich da in so einem Aufbau der weltweiten Bedeutung der englischen Krone und so weiter. Jetzt haben wir Königin Elisabeth, die feststellte, in meiner Amtszeit wurde so ganz schön viel zurückgebaut, aber gleich diese mediale Bedeutung so aufgebaut. Also klar kriegt sie so eine Beerdigung, wie sie jetzt gekriegt hat. Klar wird das dann zehn Tage lang gemacht und alles fernsehtauglich. Und es schwingen da viele Fragen noch mit im Raum, die man sich mal anschauen muss, wie zum Beispiel auch King Charles. Er hat sich jetzt voll ins Erbe seiner Mutter gestellt. Also er hat gar keinen neuen sozusagen Amtseid, sondern er hat in seiner ersten Rede, wo er hätte alles sagen können, betont. Ich erinnere noch mal, wie meine Mutter ins Amt gekommen ist oder sogar vorher sich auf die Krone verpflichtet hat, bevor sie dann ein paar Jahre später erfahren hat, dass sie selber jetzt ihrer Pflicht, die sie der Krone auferlegt, dann selber gewahr werden muss und entsprechen muss. Und er hat dann gar nicht innertlich das erneuert, sondern nur gesagt, ich erneuere ihren Eid, den sie damals der Bevölkerung gegeben hat. Ja, warum nutzt er jetzt nicht die Gelegenheit, noch mal was Neues zu begründen? Aber man versteht natürlich sofort zwar auch Thomas Einwand, dass es natürlich jetzt erst mal darum geht, dass Erbe der Queen schon allein wegen diesem ganzen Merchandise. Also ein Charles-Ding wird man jetzt nicht 500 Millionen Pfundfach verkaufen oder so, sondern es wird immer noch die Queen und auch ihr Antlitz und ihre Würde, die in diesen ganzen Fotografien drinsteckt und so. Muss man halt jetzt auch noch mal aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht aufrechterhalten und all solche Fragen spielen da rein. Und dieses, weil wir sagen, es ist König, muss es alt sein. Und deswegen muss aus der Tradition heraus ein Ritual begründet werden. Nee, da gibt es funktionale Erwägungen. Wir kommen ja gleich noch mal kurz drauf zu sprechen.
Auch hier die Parallele vielleicht zu Lagerfeld noch mal. Die Marke Chanel hat ja jetzt auch eine neue Chefdesignerin und wahrscheinlich können die meisten sie gar nicht beim Namen nennen. Sie wurde von Lagerfeld dort eingeführt und sie ist dann auch übernommen worden. Aber natürlich versucht man jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen diesen Lagerfeldgeist, auch wenn man keine Kollektionen mehr von ihm hat, wach zu halten. Also man kann nicht gleich tabula rasa machen und sagen, hier ist ein 25-jähriger Hipper-Designer und der macht das jetzt ganz anders. Sondern man muss jetzt mal versuchen noch diese Chanel-Marke, die so aufgeladen wurde von Lagerfeld, in dieser Weise eine Weile zu halten. Und dann muss man sich sicherlich umorientieren. Bei der britischen Monarchie wird das wahrscheinlich dann die Aufgabe von William werden, der dann da eigene Akzente reinlegen muss. Wir bleiben noch mal kurz bei den Ritualen, denn es gibt ja auch das Ritual, dass die Bienen über den Tod der Queen informiert werden müssen.
Und es gibt ja auch wirklich lustige Elemente. Ich hab mir das angeschaut. Eine völlig absurde Tradition ist ja, dass zum Beispiel der königliche Imker, die Pflicht hat, die Bienen der Königin über den Tod ihrer Majestät zu informieren. Ganz richtig. Und dann wurde eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass er das in gesetztem Ton getan habe.
Schauen Sie mal nach rechts auf den Bildschirm.
Da wird heftig im Kopf geschüttelt.
Ich bin selber Imker. Ich kenne viele Imker. Und ich weiß noch aus meiner Kindheit im Allgäu, wenn da ein Bauer gestorben ist, der Bienen hatte, dann ist sein Sohn an den Bienenstock gegangen und hat den Bienen gesagt, pass auf, der Bauer ist tot, jetzt bin ich der Bauer.
Das macht jetzt aber diese königliche Tradition nicht weniger lächerlich. Da werden sie mir Recht geben, oder?
Nein, ich finde das macht... Warum ist eine Tradition lächerlich? Nur weil sie die königliche...
Weil Bienen nicht reden können, würde ich sagen.
Wenn sich andere Leute auch machen. Imker haben eine besondere Beziehung zu ihren Bienen.
Also das Rituale für diejenigen sind, die die Rituale durchspielen und nicht für die, die zuschauen, ist ja nun keine neue Erkenntnis für alle Beteiligten.
Ich finde das wirklich erstaunlich, dass der Charlovo überhaupt das nicht versteht. Also dann müssen wir mal fragen, was... Also wir können dann sofort sagen, reißt alle Synagogen, Kirchen und Moscheen ab? Denn das ist wirklich lächerlich. Das können wir sofort machen. Wir können auch sagen, warum verhalten sich Leute bei Hip-Hop-Konzerten so? Also warum springen die da? Setzt euch doch hin und hört der Musik zu. Wir können ganz, ganz viele Beispiele nehmen, wo man sagt, ja, ein Ritual ist ja gerade das, was das... Also wir spielen hier mit Symbolen, wir spielen mit Repräsentanz, wir laden dies auf mit einer Bedeutung. Genau dies macht uns eigentlich zu Menschen, dass wir dazu in der Lage sind. Tiere haben keine Rituale, Tiere haben keine Statuen, vor denen sie salutieren oder irgendetwas. Tiere haben nur Instinkte. Tiere machen Dinge irgendwie immer gleich vielleicht, weil sie den Instinkt dazu haben. Aber man hat noch nie irgendwo gesehen, dass Hunde anderen Hunden ein Schrein aufbauen oder irgendetwas machen. Und gerade weil wir Menschen sind, machen wir dies. Und das ist eigentlich eine sehr, sehr intelligente Form, auch zum Beispiel mit der eigenen Sterblichkeit umzugehen. Mit all diesen großen Fragen, die wir dann doch auch nicht beantworten können, ist das eine Weise, damit umzugehen. Und das zeigt sich dann jetzt sehr prunkvoll beim Beispiel der Queen. Aber eigentlich können wir das als eine Einladung betrachten, um über unsere eigenen Rituale nachzudenken und auch zu fragen, wo fehlen vielleicht gewisse Rituale inzwischen? Denn vielleicht haben die Kirchen auch so wenig Zulauf, weil sie natürlich sehr stark auf das Ritual verzichtet haben. Sie wollten den Konventionsbruch auch aus guten Gründen zum Teil, ja, also gerade bei der katholischen Kirche mit dem zweiten vatikanischen Konzil. Und inzwischen ist aber alles so happy-clappy, dass man gar nicht mehr weiß, wo bin ich hier eigentlich gerade? Ach so, es ist eigentlich eine Kirche, dass man schon irgendwann dann denkt, ja, braucht man sie dann überhaupt noch? Das kann ich ja auch im Freundeskreis mal gerade so herstellen. Und da, glaube ich, ist es sehr sinnvoll, wieder auch über Ritualisierungen nachzudenken. Die kann man jetzt nicht immer so, wie das hier bei der Queen dann Victoria geschehen ist, mit Theaterregisseur einfach mal so schnell ins Leben setzen. Aber eine Welt ohne Rituale gibt es nicht. Denn das ist genauso, wie man glaubt, man könnte permanent dem Konformismus entgehen durch einen Non-Konformismus. Aber dann wird halt der Non-Konformismus zum Konformismus. Beziehungsweise es gibt von Söffner auch immer diese Betrachtungen, dass er sagt, es gibt eigentlich so Rituale des Anti-Ritualismus. Das kannst du ja zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt mal bei Sascha Lobe bleibt, auf der Republika sehen, wie man da Leute begrüßt, wie man sich dort verhält, was man trägt. Das ist halt dann nicht die Papstrobe und die Queen mit ihrem Blazer, aber eigentlich unterscheidet sich das nicht viel. Ach nee, Blazer trägt sie nicht, sie trägt diese mittellangen Kleider.
Es ist nirgendwo belassender für alle als zum Beispiel bei diesem Casual Friday oder so an der Arbeitsstelle, wenn es heißt, heute kommen alle mal ganz locker. Und dann kommen alle ganz locker und wissen gar nicht, wie sie sich verhalten sollen. Oder wenn der Professor sagt, ja, und dann ist heute der Vortrag, dann gehen wir mit den Vortragen noch essen und dann machen wir uns einen gemütlichen Abend. Und alle Ständen so, ich weiß zwar, wie ich mich in Seminarsituation verhalte, aber wenn es plötzlich so gemütlich und der Professor ist da und er gibt mir dann später trotzdem eine Note, auch wenn es jetzt hier gemütlich zugeht. Und Sascha Lobo meint ja gerade, das ist totaler Quatsch, dem Bienen das Ritual vorzuspielen, weil die können ja nicht reden, die antworten ja nicht. Und der eine Punkt, der ein Ritual zum Ritual macht, ist, dass man da nicht miteinander redet oder sich überrascht, sondern das wird natürlich vorher und deswegen Protokoll aufgeschrieben, was dann passiert und dann hält man sich genau an dieses Protokoll. Genau. Es geht genau darum, nicht zu kommunizieren. Also deswegen dazu sagen, die Bienen kommunizieren nicht. Nee, genau. Die sind einfach nur Objekt des Rituals. So wie jedes Subjekt in dem Ritual wird sich zum Objekt des Rituals wird. Und gerade diejenigen, die bewusst daran teilnehmen und dann auch Schritt für Schritt und genau sehen, wo wird hier eigentlich mal abgewichen, das kann man dann wieder zum Thema machen und so weiter. Und da wird ja auch viel, also da beginnt ja dann das Spiel, wo man das so macht. Und ja, Rituale, was wäre, wenn man es jetzt mal wirklich auf die Spitze treibt und Sascha Lobos Idee hier folgt, wir schaffen diese Rituale ab. Dann hätten wir ja eine Situation, dass wir einfach sagen, die Queen ist tot im nicht geschriebenen Verfassungsrang steht dann einfach drin, ja dann ist automatisch der nächste König. Also Charles war ja ab dem Moment des Wissens darüber, dass die Queen tot ist, König. Alle anderen Situationen sind völlig egal, wo er wäre, in welchem Zustand, er ist ganz automatisch der König. Und damit wäre das geregelt, man hätte einen Haken dran machen können, man schreibt das dann kurz informationsmäßig irgendwo auf und damit ist gut. Und in dieser BBC-Berichterstattung hat man mit einer Seelsorgerin gesprochen, die dann auch meinte, diese Art der Gemeinsamtrauer eröffnet für alle die Gelegenheit zu sagen, ja ich kannte die Queen nicht persönlich, aber ich habe Bezüge zu anderen und gerade nach diesen Corona-Jahren hat man ja auch unverarbeitete Trauererlebnisse und so weiter. Und jetzt treffen wir uns auf der Straße zu einer Trauerfeier und jeder bringt seinen eigenen Fall mit, bis hin zum Haustier. Hat sie ausdrücklich gesagt, irgendwer hat seine Eltern verloren, irgendwer hat seine Kinder verloren, irgendwer hat ein Haustier verloren. Und dann gehen alle auf die Straße und jeder bringt seine eigene Trauergeschichte mit und dann wird das mal zum Thema. Und eigentlich kommen wir jetzt so langsam in diese Schrumpfungs- und Altwertengesellschaft, wo wir sagen können, du kennst wahrscheinlich diesen Film Coco heißt er glaube ich, wo für Kinder mal dieses mexikanische Todesfest gefeiert wird. Das ist ja für uns Europäer völlig wie die feiern die Toten. Also einmal im Jahr gedenken die den Toten. Wir machen das doch nur am Tag der Beerdigung und danach ist es so durch. Und schon nach fünf Jahren, ach ja, heute war ja der Tag, wo jemand gestorben ist und so weiter. Man vergisst es völlig. Und eigentlich brauchen wir mehr dieser Rituale. Also die Queen hat mir eigentlich auch nochmal gezeigt, so ein bisschen, ne, wir kommen jetzt in diese Gesellschaft, wo auch mein Buch Kategorie 1 Sterben ist. Also ich bin Bestseller in der Kategorie Sterben bei Amazon. Ja, wir brauchen eigentlich diese Kategorie mehr. Wir müssen jetzt sterben lernen, weil demnächst werden sehr viele Leute sterben lernen. Es gibt die ersten Unternehmen, die sich jetzt, nachdem sie jahrelang sich warm werden mussten mit der Elternzeit und so weiter, dass Menschen sich da frei nehmen für die Pflege ihrer jungen Kinder, dass man sich jetzt auch fragt, wie geht man mit Pflegefällen, Angehörige, Ältere und auch Todestage um? Also kriegt man Sonntagurlauber und so weiter. Das muss jetzt diskutiert werden, weil demnächst eben sehr viele Leute einfach sterben und das findet in Deutschland noch nicht so richtig statt. Wir haben jetzt von der Queen so ein Angebot bekommen, das kollektiv zu machen, was ich sehr gut finde, so als Idee, dass man sagt, egal wann man die eigene Verlusterfahrung macht, man weiß, keine Ahnung, 19. September oder so was, gibt es einen kollektiven Volkstrauertag oder so was.
Aber in anderer Weise.
Genau, und man institutionalisiert das mal wieder neu. Man stellt das Fernsehprogramm so ein bisschen um, hört abends so ein paar Seelsorger, die auch so ein bisschen darüber reden, wie es ist, Verlusterfahrung zu verarbeiten und so weiter. Aber man kann das jetzt mal reinholen. Man kann das jetzt mal institutionalisieren und ritualisieren. Und ich glaube, damit wäre sehr vielen Menschen geholfen, dass die Imker so ein bisschen in die Pionierrolle fallen. Okay, aber ich finde, man kann das jetzt mal so zeigen.
Es ist aber bekannt, dass es ja bei Imkern tatsächlich diese ganz, ganz nahe Bindung zu den Bienen gibt. Wir bleiben mal noch bei den Ritualen. Dazu gehört natürlich auch, dass man lange in der Schlange steht. Zum Beispiel auch, wenn man David Beckham ist. Und der wird hier mal ganz kurz interviewt, während er zwölf Stunden in der Schlange steht. Es war natürlich wieder perfekt aus, sehr gut gekleidet. Nimmt jetzt auch noch mal die Großeltern, die nicht mehr leben, noch mal dazu. Die würden das jetzt auch so machen.
Es ist eine nahezu idealtypisch perfekte Antwort für diese Frage, die eben gestellt wurde. Ich bin hier nicht nur für mich, sondern auch für diejenigen, die mir nahe stehen, aber hier nicht mehr dabei sein können. Die Queen ist jetzt für uns alle gestorben, auch für die, die schon längst gestorben sind. Es ist so ein bisschen wie, dass auch schon wieder Nachrufe aufgetaucht sind über die Queen von Menschen, die selber schon gestorben sind. Also die, wo es zeitlich total auseinanderfällt, wer hier wem gedenkt und der Tod so eine große Rolle spielt.
Nun müssen wir aber noch mal als Kritik einfließen lassen, dass wir ja hier von folgender Konstellation ausgehen. Wir haben da jemand, der aufgrund von Geburt diese besondere Position bekommt, wie wir alle in der westlichen Welt. Wir alle in der westlichen Welt im Sinne von eines Ortsbonus.
Richtig.
Ja, aber wir sind natürlich jetzt nicht als Oberhäupter irgendwo und haben die Aufgabe, ein Land zu repräsentieren.
Fahr mal als Tourist nach Nigeria, wie du dich da fühlst. Du wirst aufgenommen wie ein König.
Das mag sein. Okay, aber dennoch, wenn wir es jetzt mal auf unsere Gesellschaft beziehen, dann haben wir ja eine Hierarchie darin. Also du weißt ja auch, die Hanseaten, wenn sie das Bundesverdienstkreuz bekommen, dann lehnen sie das ab, weil sie nicht einen Orden tragen wollen, weil nicht einer über dem anderen stehen soll. Und das ist ja ein demokratisches Grundprinzip. Und natürlich auch der Schritt zur Aufklärung und auch zum demokratischen Bürger, dass man nicht mehr jemanden braucht, den man bewundern kann, sondern wir wollen Amtsträger, die eine Kompetenz haben in den verschiedenen Dingen, die nicht so wie Christian Lindner unterwegs sind. Und dann sind wir froh. Aber wir müssen jetzt goutieren, Habeck macht Dinge gut. Aber wir würden jetzt nicht in blinder Bewunderung hier sitzen und sagen, mein Gott, also dem einmal die Hand zu geben, das wäre das höchste. Ja, so Leute gibt es natürlich. Das finde ich immer hochverdächtig. Hier haben wir das aber bei einer Person. Und man kann doch auch sagen, solange eine Gesellschaft dies noch braucht oder solange man nicht da wirklich eine fundamentale Kritik dran übt, sind wir eigentlich in einer unaufgeklärten Lage, die ja niemals dazu führen wird, dass man tatsächlich mal die großen wichtigen Schritte angeht. Und ich will jetzt einen Clip spielen, auch aus diesem älteren Deutschlandfunkbeitrag, ganz kurz, wo jemand sich äußert, ein Brite, der diese Hochzeit jetzt sich ansieht. Und man kann das jetzt direkt übertragen nehmen, der hätte das zur Beerdigung gesagt.
Wenn du dir überlegst, dass die nur ein paar Meter entfernt sein werden, das passiert uns nur einmal im Leben. Meinen Leuten sage ich, das hier ist etwas, woran wir uns unser ganzes Leben lang erinnern werden. Wir werden unseren Enkelkindern noch erzählen können, wir waren dabei.
Ist das nicht eine ungeheuer traurige Aussage? Du willst dich ja noch rechtfertigen mit deinem Queen-Tick.
Also wir kennen natürlich alle dieses Phänomen. In China wird es ja zum Beispiel komplett übertrieben. Es gab kürzlich in den Abendnachrichten einen Bericht darüber, dass irgend so ein Dorf sich komplett selbst in ein Museum verwandelt hat, nachdem Qi da vor acht Jahren mal zu Besuch war für drei Tage. Man hat jeden Station dieser kurzen Stipfvisite, weil er hatte das so als Beispieldorf ausgesucht für hier, kultivieren wir jetzt den ländlichen Raum und sorgen auch hier für Wachstum und so weiter. Und dann sind die halt auf die Idee gekommen, dass einfach also diesen Moment festzuhalten, jeden Stuhl, den Qi berührt hat, als den hat zuletzt Qi berührt und so. Also man kann es komplett übertreiben, aber das ist halt Popkultur. Wir gehen alle deswegen in diese Konzerte, weil wir über die Musik hinaus diese Anwesenheit, dieses Raum gebundene und auf, da braucht man dann auch mal sein Körper, da reicht nicht nur der Tonträger und man hört diese Art Nähe. Ich kann das irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Und ist diese Nähe schlimm? Also wir haben jetzt ganz häufig auch diesen Begriff der parasozialen Beziehung, den man aufbaut. Also das haben wir bei den Followern zu den Influencern, aber das haben wir auch bei Wählern zu Politikern vielleicht oder wir haben das bei Leuten, die die Podcast hören. Und da steckt natürlich in diesem Wort eine Kritik gleich drin. Das ist etwas perioreativ gebraucht, weil man dann sagt, ja, das ist keine richtige Beziehung, weil man sich ja nicht face to face gegenüber sitzt und man sich wirklich kennt, sondern jemand hört nur zu oder sieht nur und ist dann Empfänger, aber kann nicht wirklich zurück kommunizieren, vielleicht mal was kommentieren, aber es ist nicht diese Kommunikation, die wir zwei jetzt gerade hier miteinander führen. Und dann würde ich aber sagen, das ist ja auch etwas, was es immer schon gab. Also ich sehe das Problem der parasozialen Beziehung da, wo das Abhängigkeiten produziert, also wo junge Leute dazu angetrieben werden, sich in den Bankrott zu shoppen, durch irgendwelche Hypes die Influencer auslösen oder durch Abhängigkeiten sexueller Natur, dass Leute immer mehr bereit sind, bei OnlyFans zu zahlen, weil sie glauben, das ist eigentlich ihre wahre Freundin, die sie da haben. Da hat das sicherlich eine sehr ungesunde Komponente. Aber zugleich würde ich sagen, zu Martin Walzer habe ich auch eine parasoziale Beziehung. Ich habe alle wichtigen Romane von ihm gelesen. Und natürlich war das für mich ganz wichtig, schon in der Jugendzeit. Und ich habe den Mann mal bei einer Lesung gesehen, aber nie mit dem irgendwas zu tun gehabt. Aber trotzdem, würde ich sagen, ist da ein Band da. Ich würde jetzt nicht gleich an den Bodensee fahren, wenn er stirbt und würde da zur Beerdigung gehen. Aber natürlich ist das eine parasoziale Beziehung. Eine parasoziale Beziehung, die ich aber auch habe zu gewissen Sängern, weil diese Stimmen immer für mich so wichtig waren.
Genau.
Und die habe ich auch nicht im Realen. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ich hätte aber eigentlich gern Maria Callas würde ich jetzt gern treffen, es gibt halt niemand von meinem Kantenkreis, der so singen kann.
Diese Parasozialität steht immer in der Kritik, weil sie eben nicht ganz sozial ist, sondern nur parasozial. Und wir müssen das aber in beide Richtungen denken, denn sie ist parasozial und damit auch nicht asozial. Also es gibt so ein, sag mal so, Queen Elizabeth II ist nicht Queen Elizabeth I oder Queen Victoria. Die beiden haben wirklich materiell weltreich aufgebaut. 25 mal, äh fünfmal so groß wie Alexander der Große in seiner Peakzeit. So, war natürlich viel Technik getrieben, Schifffahrt, unglaubliche Materialschlacht, Kolonialismus, alles was da rein gehört so richtig. Hier wurde regiert und zwar über Land, Boden mit Blut und Schwert und so weiter. Und jetzt haben wir festgestellt, jetzt bei Queen Elizabeth, das Reich ist zerbröckelt. Es blieb noch so ein Commonwealth. Es war so die Idee von, na dann machen wir wenigstens gemeinsame Jugendspiele und man hat so Parallel-Solo-Olympia irgendwie organisiert und wir stellen fest, sie hat nicht über Land und Leute regiert, sondern einfach über die Gemüter und zwar global. Also auch wir in Deutschland konnten dann irgendwann diesen Spruch übernehmen. Zuerst war sie die britische Queen, dann war sie die globale Queen, dann war sie nur noch die Queen. Also sie gehörte auch irgendwie zu uns. Wir konnten unsere Zeit damit füllen, die Zeitungen waren voll und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist doch eigentlich interessant, dass wir dann Leute haben, die dann irgendwie sagen, ja so einmal nutze ich die Gelegenheit, wenn sie sich bietet, auch in ihrer Anwesenheit zu sein. Aber sie ist halt grundsätzlich bei mir auch abwesend nicht asozial. Und das ist ja was ganz Besonderes. Also dass man so eine Art von, ich will es nicht übertreiben, aber es fehlen einem auch ein bisschen die Worte, Weltgeist und so was halt. Ja, dass da einfach immer jemand, irgendwo ist sie schon, irgendwer sieht sie schon gerade, irgendwer kann schon gerade bezeugen, dass sie gerade lebt und arbeitet und so weiter. Es muss nicht ich sein, ich kann mich darauf verlassen. Sie ist da, andernfalls würde ich es mitbekommen und dann kriegt sie aber die ganze Welt mit. Her Majesty just died. Dann ist es einfach der Satz, der alle anderen Sätze aufhebt. Solange diese Art von Weltgewissheit da ist, dass es weitergeht, dass die Rituale laufen, auch wenn ich selbst gerade nicht involviert bin.
Das ist das Beruhigende.
Genau, das war der eigentliche Wert, der so mitgeliefert wurde.
Und wäre das denn auch möglich, ohne das zu leben? Also ich meine, es gibt ja viele Leute, denen ist das jetzt sonst wo vorbei gegangen mit der Queen. Oder wir haben ja auch Konstellationen, wo wir das nicht so erleben. Beispielsweise war ich vor einer Weile in Berlin und dann fuhr der Bundeskanzler im Auto an mir vorbei und der Taxifahrer sagte zu mir, da ist der Bundeskanzler. Und dann sagte ich, aha, aber da hab ich ja nicht gedacht, toll diesen Moment erlebt zu haben. Der Bundeskanzler ist dann mir vorbeigefahren. Also kommen wir zu einer Gesellschaft und deswegen noch mal meine Frage, bist du Royalist? Das war ja ernsthaft gestellt, gerade weil ich das nochmal adressierte an den Systemtheoretiker. Inwieweit hat das jetzt diese funktionale Komponente, dass du sagst, so möchtest du, dass die Gesellschaft funktioniert? Oder sagst du, das dient dem Funktionieren einer Gesellschaft? Weil ja die Kritik jetzt wäre, und das ist ja nicht eine besonders linke Kritik einfach nur, sondern generell eine Kritik aus der Aufklärung herausgesprochen. Wozu brauchen wir die?
Sehr gute, ich nehme die Herausforderung jetzt an und liefe jetzt meine vorbereitete Antwort. Denn ja, sehr viele kamen jetzt mit dieser Kritik. Sie hat ja gar keine formale oder politische Macht. Und ich sage, nö, sie war aber trotzdem da. Hat gewirkt, es greift dieses Thomas-Theorien. Gibt es einen Gott, ja oder nein? Wenn alle in die Kirche gehen, gibt es eine Ursache dafür. Die ist Gott, also muss es Gott irgendwo geben. Dann ist die Frage nur, in welchem Zustand. Und ich will mal eine sozusagen formale, historische, wie soll man es fassen? Ich beschreib's mal und dann kann jeder selber überlegen. Über die Antwort auf die Frage, welche Funktionen und welche Folgen hatte die Anwesenheit und das Leben der Queen. Wir wollen ja hier spontan historisieren, die letzten 70 Jahre mal aufgreifen und sagen, 1952 gab es eine Nachkriegszeit, die schon im Abkling war. Wir wussten so ein bisschen, okay, wirtschaftlich geht's bergauf, die Leute profitieren davon, aber Europa hat immer noch Diktatoren gekannt. Spanien, Portugal und so weiter. Das war noch die Blütezeit der Diktatoren. Während wir schon Kohle und Stahl, und wir wissen heute wohin es führt, der Europäische Union, das Aufblühen dieser Demokratie. Wir sprachen ja zuletzt über den neuen Autokratismus. Also wir kennen so eine Blütezeit von Demokratie. Und es war eben nicht schon vorher reingeschrieben, dass Europa jetzt eine ganz tolle Demokratie wird bis zum Jahr 2000 und danach kommt so ein Orban oder so und Polen und dann wird es wieder zertrümmert. Und jetzt gerade, während wir hier sprechen, finden im Iran Volksaufstände statt. Es begann bei den Frauen, hat sich jetzt durch die ganze Gesellschaft gezogen. Es gibt diese große große Unzufriedenheit, große Wut und jetzt rätseln wirklich gerade alle, was passiert denn da eigentlich. Und wir haben und deswegen biete ich jetzt einen funktionalen Vergleich. Also den darf man jetzt nicht sachlich übertreiben, das ist rein funktional. Wir haben in Iran diese Konstellation Bevölkerung und Regierung und dahinter aber noch als drittes im Bunde ein Ayatollah. Wir wissen, es ist ein schiitisch dominiertes Land. Die Schiiten haben ein Ayatollah und der übernimmt vor allem die religiose Führerschaft, aber eben auch viele weltliche. Also er sagt einfach, was hier politisch gemacht wird. Alles hängt von ihm ab. Und das mal funktional verglichen mit der Queen, die 1952 viele Gelegenheit bekommen hat, zu sagen, ich nutze meine mediale Macht, um mich trotzdem politisch einzumischen. Es steht nirgendwo so richtig geschrieben, dass mir das verboten ist. Ich hätte die Macht. Ich habe diese wöchentliche Konsultation mit dem jeweiligen Premierminister. Ich überlebe viele Premierminister. Also ich kann auch langfristige Linien hier einfach aufziehen und immer mal wieder hier und da. Und sie hat ja dann auch mit ihren Kostümen gespielt, dem Brexit entsprechend kommentiert mit blauem Hut und gelben Blümchen drin und so weiter und so fort. Und die große Leistung der Queen, die wir heute als absolut selbstverständlich ansehen, die aber nicht selbstverständlich ist, ist, sich 1952 dafür entschieden zu haben, zu sagen, egal was passiert die nächsten 70 Jahre, die ich regiere, meine Botschaft lautet, ihr habt euch für Demokratie entschieden und jetzt müsst ihr auch Demokratie machen. Er erwartet nicht von mir, dass ich nochmal, und ich selbst hatte diese Wünsche, in mir, als wir den Brexit kommentiert haben, dass die Queen hier doch nochmal interveniert, dass wir nochmal so eine göttliche Fügung oder sowas, so eine divine Intervention und divine meint eben wirklich die Queen, die hätte diese religiösen Kraft um die Alpen. Genau, aber es passiert da alles nicht, sondern sie hat ihr Land, das ihr Unterstand, England, auf die Demokratie verpflichtet, egal was passiert. Boris Johnson wollte die BBC zertrümmern, jetzt kommt Liz Truss, und wir wissen alle nicht, was das bedeutet. Ganz großes Durcheinander, aber ihre Botschaft war, ihr habt euch für Demokratie entschieden, also macht jetzt Demokratie. Hofft nicht darauf, dass ich jetzt mit Autokratie zurückkomme, obwohl ich in der Pole-Position wäre, jetzt noch mal das eine oder andere zu versuchen, da wirklich inhaltlich einzugreifen.
Das wurde ja jetzt auch noch mal laut. Also es gab ja jetzt noch mal Artikel, die noch mal aufgeschrieben haben, da hat sie damals versagt beim Brexit, und sie verstehen gar nicht, was das bedeutet hätte. Wäre sie in der Weise nach vorne geschritten, hätte gesagt, ich will den Brexit nicht, und überlegt euch das mal. Wenn sie das gemacht hätte, hätte sie alles riskiert, beziehungsweise dann wäre wahrscheinlich die Monarchie abgeschafft, oder irgendwas anderes wäre Kraut und Rüben. Das wäre ein gigantischer Schritt gewesen. Das wäre undenkbar geradezu.
Und ich sehe die Bandbreite und damit auch, wie man diese Lebensleistung einschätzen soll. Irgendwo in dieser Dimension, wo auf der einen Seite der Ayatollah ist, der immer noch versucht, das Land einfach zu unterdrücken und die Biografien der jungen Frauen und Männer zu brechen. Und auf der anderen Seite der Queen, die einfach dieses unendlich stabile, weitreichende Versprechen gegeben hat, wir machen jetzt Demokratie. Trotz aller Traditionen, die wir hatten mit unserer, und das ist eben nicht nur weltliche Herrschaft, es ist auch oberhaupt der Kirche, einfach das andere Angebot zu fahren. Und dass wir es heute als so selbstverständlich ansehen, dass die Queen dazu gar nicht, und überhaupt, das ist ja nur noch so eine informale Rolle und so weiter. Ja, das ist ihre Leistung, dass wir das heute so sehen und sagen, genau, das ist einfach die Herausforderung der Demokratie. Jetzt macht mal ihr Demokraten und wir werden jetzt sehen, welchen Pfad England da einschlägt. Es wird ja gruselig. Also die ökonomischen Daten sehen ja nicht so aus, als ob man da ohne autokratische Züge irgendwie das Land befrieden halten kann, wie das die letzten 70 Jahre gelang und in der Hinsicht...
Und was hat ja vor, jetzt erstmal Steuererleichterung zu bringen, weil sie ganz fest an den Trickle-down-Effekt laupt.
Es ist traurig, ne?
Es ist richtig traurig. Es gab auch einen Skandal bei dieser ganzen Zeremonie, nämlich ist es ja so, man steht ganz lange in der Schlange, auch ein David Beckham, aber dann gibt es die Gerüchte, beziehungsweise auch entsprechende Bilder, dass Bill und Holly, das sind die berühmtesten Frühstücksfernsehmoderatoren Englands, sich vorgedrängelt haben, beziehungsweise als Journalisten akkreditiert, sich irgendwie vorbeigeschlichen haben. Es gab da Aufnahmen davon, es gab einen immensen Twitter-Shitstorm. Man muss sagen, die sind wirklich ganz populär. Also wir haben zwar auch Frühstücksmoderatoren, aber das ist nicht vergleichbar. Also das sind Institutionen und das waren dann überall auch auf den Blättern dann als der große Skandal der Stunde und ich habe mit einem Bekannten telefoniert, der Engländer ist und er sagte Wolfgang, wenn du mal wissen willst, wenn du mal wirklich einen britischen Satz haben willst, was ist wirklich britisch, dann soll ich mir das Statement durchlesen, das daraufhin Holli und Bill verfasst haben, nachdem es diesen Shitstorm gab und der letzte Satz ist entscheidend.
None of the broadcasters and journalists there took anyone's place in the queue and no one filed past the Queen. We of course respected those rules, however we realized that it may have looked like something else and therefore totally understand the reaction.
Fritischer ginge es nicht mehr, sagt man mir. Niemals würden sie eine Warteschlange überspringen. Es war dann überall großes Thema. Ich habe es mir ein bisschen bei YouTube angesehen. Hier noch ein Ausschnitt aus Piers Morgan, weil du jetzt auch gerade von der Einigkeit, die die Queen nochmal hergestellt hat und so weiter. Ist sie jetzt vielleicht schon zerbrochen? Kaum hat die Queen die Augen zugemacht, geht schon alles drunter und drüber, wenn man sich das hier anhört.
Es gibt eine Petition von 35.000 Leuten, auf der Frontpage von jedem Papier, als wäre es das größte Schandal aller Zeiten. Das war der Fehler des Judges.
Wir haben alle gesprochen.
Das ist der Nachteil.
Das ist vielleicht geblieben von all dem, man weiß es nicht. Wird König Charles das noch mal einigen? Wir werden jetzt vielleicht Ende des Jahrzehnts noch mal aufgreifen, sonst werden wir nicht weiterhin so realistisch unterwegs sein.
Es ist ja auch jetzt wirklich ansehend, des realen Königshauses für Ruhe zu sorgen. King Charles III wird alles auf sich ziehen, hat sich ja von allen anderen Engagement getrennt, nur noch die repräsentative Rolle übernehmen. Wir wissen, dass alle Medienhäuser, die akkreditiert waren, jetzt den Auftrag gekriegt haben, die eine Stunde Material aus den zehn Tagen im Königshaus vorzulegen. Die darf dann später weiter verwendet werden, alles andere nicht mehr. Also die Erinnerungskultur wird auf einen ganz engen Fokus gelegt, also nur noch auf die Highlights und so weiter, damit solche Diskussionen dann gar nicht mehr groß, weil man einfach gar kein Material mehr zeigen darf davon, wie jemand in der Schlange stand oder so, weil das ist ja alles Poolproduktion gewesen. Und die große Herausforderung wird Prinz Harry sein, der ja nun schon, Thomas hat mir das gestern gezeigt, in so einem Interview über die Suizidgedanken von Meghan sprach, wie er sich im Stich gelassen fühlte. Und er holt ja auch gerade aus, mit einem 40 Millionen Vorschuss ein Buch vorzulegen, in dem all seine Sorgen noch mal dargelegt werden und Prinz Williams Aufgabe wird sein, da irgendwie wieder seine Augenhöhe herzustellen.
Ich finde, die sollten den einfach jetzt da verstoßen.
Sie haben ihn ja im Grunde verstoßen. Ja, das ist ja auch richtig.
Also ich finde, ab einem gewissen Millionenbetrag auf dem Konto hat man auch nicht mehr das Recht, unglücklich zu sein.
Ja, also es gibt jetzt viele einfache Streisen in dieser Diskussion.
Es ist dann wirklich jetzt auch mal gut. Und ich verstehe auch nicht, das haben die auch gewusst. Und auch Meghan, die hätte sich ja auch einen anderen Mann ohne Haare suchen können. Also es gibt ja keine Veranlassung dazu, dass man sagt, ich würde mal gerne ins Königshaus einheiraten und glaubt dann, das sei so wie immer, wie überall mit irgendeiner Beziehung. Nein, man geht nicht in eine Beziehung nur ein, sondern man wechselt den Job und zwar vollkommen. Und wenn man das nicht machen will, dann muss man das nicht machen. Das ist ja keine Zwangs-Ehe gewesen, sondern die haben sich selbst dafür entschieden. Und dann muss man das entweder mitmachen oder man kann sich auch in aller Stille zurückziehen und wird ja dann immer noch prächtig alimentiert. Es ist ja keineswegs so, dass man sich um die finanzielle Sorgen machen muss. Und das finde ich wirklich so was von degutant. Und dass das aber trotzdem in einer Gesellschaft, wo keiner mehr irgendwas Vernünftiges erbt, wo das also gut, genau, Leute die erben, aber die meisten Leute erben nichts. Und wo wir so eine unglaubliche Ungleichheit haben, dass dann Leute noch glauben, sie müssen jetzt Prinz Harry und Meghan empowern. Da muss man wirklich sagen, sind ja jetzt alle verrückt geworden. Also da ist mir ja jeder Royalist der zwei Stunden in der Schlange, zwei Stunden in der Schlange steht lieber, weil der wenigstens ja noch eine Form war. Also dass man jetzt noch glaubt, man müsste diese Leute da unterstützen. Nein, sie haben diesen Weg gewählt, dann haben sie plötzlich gemerkt, ach so, das bedeutet ja auch Arbeit und bedeutet Repräsentanz. Und in jedem Sinne des Wortes, ja, Pech gehabt. Aber da muss man nicht gleich zur Oprah Winfried raufen.
Ja, ich bin auch begeistert von der Professionalität von William & Kate, um das nochmal zu sagen. Das ist toll zu sehen. Und mal sehen, was die Zukunft bringt.
Wir wollen noch ganz kurz, weil wir das noch gar nicht angesprochen haben, über den Salon sprechen. Es ist soweit, das Buch von Richard David Precht und Harald Wälzer ist erschienen. Es liegt jetzt schon auf meinem Schreibtisch. Ich habe es schon mal ganz kurz reingeblättert. Aber ich fange mit der Lektüre jetzt nach der Aufnahme dieses Podcasts an. 260 Seiten, einige Fußnoten auf Lager. Ich habe schon mal reingeguckt, was wird da so alles zitiert. Sie machen also wohl einen großen Rundumstark. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf das Buch und habe auch mir Folgendes geschworen. Ich werde bis zu der Aufnahme des Salons kein Interview mit den beiden lesen und auch keinen Podcast mit den anderen. Ich will wirklich nur das Werk, will die Argumente haben und will diese anderen Dinge auspländen. Das ist das, was mich interessiert an diesem Buch. Ich würde aber gerne eine Argumentation schon mal vorwegnehmen, die jetzt gemacht wird von vehementen Gegnern dieses Buchs, die sagen, wie können die ein Buch über die Medien schreiben, dass die Medien über Dinge nicht berichten oder so. Die kommen doch die ganze Zeit in den Medien vor. Sollen wir uns jetzt wirklich auf dieses Niveau begeben und sagen, ab wann darf man dann das Buch schreiben, weil man gar nicht mehr in den Medien ist? Oder kann es vielleicht sein, dass diese Leute ganz prominent sind und deswegen noch in den Medien natürlich vorkommen, egal was sie machen? Also auch wenn die beiden zusammen ein Kochbuch geschrieben hätten, würden die natürlich vorkommen, aber das ist dann wieder ein Prominenzsystem. Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man jetzt immer sagt, naja, aber die kommen vor und wir machen es ja hier auch immer wieder thematisch fest, dass so viel, das nicht vorkommt, also wie unterrepräsentiert zum Beispiel europäische Themen in den Medien sind. Natürlich ist da nicht jemand, der sagt, das darf jetzt nicht gebracht werden, sondern es geht ja hier um Strukturelles. Ob das in dem Buch dann analysiert wird, wird sich zeigen. Ich finde nur, dass diese Argumentationen, die sind dann in den Medien, also sollen sich doch nicht beschweren, dass sie in den Medien nicht vorkommen. Das finde ich ein bisschen albern, weil man jetzt auch trotzdem, auch wenn man davon nicht in dem Sinne betroffen ist, kann man ja trotzdem Argument machen. Also ich könnte jetzt ein Buch über die Geschichte des Sports schreiben, auch wenn ich selbst keinen Sport mache.
Also es gibt, und das kenne ich aus eigener Erfahrung in den Redaktionen, diesen Moment, wenn man feststellt, dass derjenige, über den man berichtet oder mit dem man berichtet als Journalist oder Redakteur, selber sehr viel mehr Reichweite hat. Das ist vor allem im Sportjournalismus so, wo dann irgendwann doch sich eingestellt hat, dass ein Sportschau-Moderator Millionengehalt hat, weil das wäre ja irgendwie sonst nicht auf Augenhöhe, wenn er mit Millionären die ganze Zeit redet, die nämlich den Sport ausüben und die sehr viel mehr Follower haben und so weiter, wenn er da selbst so unter Fernerliefen läuft. Und das, was du jetzt angemerkt hast, ist, finde ich gerade der Grund, warum wir dieses Buch so ernst nehmen sollten, weil nämlich die Journalisten es ernst nehmen, weil sie nämlich von den beiden in Sachen Reichweite Schachmatt gesetzt werden. Und das ist genau der Grund, weshalb wir alle auf dieses Buch gucken und ihnen damit noch mehr Reichweite verschaffen. Also da ist halt so ein kleiner Zirkel drin, den kann man auch paradoxinieren und so weiter. Aber das ist der Anlass, warum wir uns mit diesem Buch beschäftigen. Darüber hinaus, wir haben ja die beiden Autoren hier schon häufiger irgendwie thematisiert.
Und oft kritisch.
Oft kritisch, genau, das ist eben der Punkt. Und diesmal, ich werde es auch machen, so wie du, ich habe dadurch, dass ich jetzt Zeitabonnent bin, natürlich mal quer gelesen, dieses Gespräch, was sie da führen. Aber das ist ja auch nichts, was jetzt irgendwie mich vorher schon aus einer Bahn wirft oder so.
Ich brauche auch nicht nochmal ein Interview zu einem Buch. Also wenn die 260 Seiten aufgeschlagen haben, dann reicht mir das ja auch vorerst mal.
Ja, genau. Und ich finde fast, sie quatschen jetzt zu viel in irgendwelchen Podcasts, dass sie irgendwie zu Gast sind und dann eine Stunde lang mit irgendwelchen Leuten reden. Nee, lasst doch das Ding für euch stehen. Wir nehmen also das Buch ernst, finde ich auch sehr gut. Ich werde auch nichts weiter darüber hinaus lesen, sondern einfach dann werden wir das Buch besprechen.
In aller Sachlichkeit und Nüchternheit und ohne Aufregung. Und wir haben jedenfalls keine besonderen Sympathien mit denen, sondern schauen da leidenschaftslos, sagen wir drauf.
Gewisse Vorfreude habe ich schon.
Ich habe natürlich eine Vorfreude auf die Debatte und all das. Klar, ich freue mich auch sehr auf die Aufnahme schon, aber wir haben nicht in irgendeiner Weise, dass wir sagen, den fand ich schon immer toll oder schon immer schlimm, sondern ich fand manches immer toll und manches immer schlimm. Bei beiden und das wird sich dann zeigen, welche Seite das Buch mehr einlösen wird. Jedenfalls sprechen wir darüber dann nächste Woche im Salon. Noch kurz der Hinweis, der Salon ist, wir müssen das immer mal wieder erwähnen, weil es sonst Irritationen gibt. Der Salon ist komplett buchbar über Steady. Das ist über unsere Seite neuzwanziger.de zu machen. Das kann man aber, wenn man den Podcast über Spotify hört, auch da über einen Button machen, dann kommt man direkt dorthin. Und wenn man das Ganze über Steady abschließt, dann, das ist wichtig, dass wir darauf hinweisen, hat man auch das gesamte Salonarchiv von Januar angefangen 2020 bis heute. Wenn man den Salon jetzt über Apple bucht, dann ist es so, dass man dort auch ältere Folgen buchen kann. Aber nicht alle. Aber nicht alle. Und bei Patreon sind wir ja auch, weil wir wissen, dass manche Leute, Gamer zum Beispiel, bei Patreon Leute unterstützen. Und dann kann man das natürlich verstehen, dass man sagt, ich will nicht nochmal einen neuen Account haben, jetzt warum muss ich noch Steady? Da kann man also den Salon auch abonnieren und hören. Und da sind auch ein paar Folgen jetzt da, die ja schon bei Patreon sind. Ich glaube zwei sind es. Zwei oder drei. Zwei oder drei. Aber da wird jetzt nicht nochmal das gesamte Archiv hochgeladen. Das wäre eine Herkules-Aufgabe. Wer also wirklich alles haben möchte, der kann das dort über den Salon, der kann das über Steady tun. Und Die Neue Zwanziger-Seite empfiehlt sich sowieso, die mal zu besuchen, weil dort auch für die, die den Salon nicht abonniert haben, immer das aufgelistet ist, was gemacht ist. Worüber wir sprechen. Und vielleicht ist dann auch bei manchen nochmal das Interesse da, das abzuschließen, um auch nochmal eine eine oder andere alte Folge nachzuhören. Denn wir besprechen ja doch auch viele Bücher und Texte, die eine gewisse Zeitlosigkeit haben. Wir wollen ja nicht so sehr dem Tagesgeschäft hinterher hecheln.
Genau, der Salon steht ja so ein bisschen für sich. Wir spontan historisieren aber dann wirklich im Jahrzehntemaß. Da sind jetzt 70, 80 Bücher oder so haben wir mittlerweile besprochen. Und ja, wie Wolfgang sagte, steady, weil da kriegt man für den kleinsten Betrag das ganze Archiv und noch den einen oder anderen Vorzug, wie zum Beispiel, da sind die Kapitelmarken mit drin. Da kann man also selber von Text zu Text springen. Wir haben einen Cover, machen damit den Salon nochmal erkenntlich, welcher Monat ist es überhaupt. Und man kann ihn im Podcastplayer seiner eigenen Wahl hören, denn man kriegt einen ganz normalen RSS-Feed, seinen eigenen, aber trotzdem einen ganz normalen RSS-Feed. Man kann also mit dem Podcastplayer, den man sowieso nutzt, dann auch da einfach ganz normal abonnieren und kriegt einen Hinweis. Neue Folge ist da, da muss man nur noch Play drücken.
Wir gehen zur Helmut-Kohl-Stiftung.
Nein, ich kläre dich auf. Es gibt eine Helmut-Kohl-Stiftung und es gibt eine Bundeskanzler-Helmut-Kohl-Stiftung. Und wir gehen zur Bundeskanzler-Helmut-Kohl-Stiftung, weil das nämlich die der Partei ist.
Und nicht die von Meike. Das hat mich gewundert die ganze Zeit. Schön, dass du das aufklärst. Ich habe es mir angeguckt. Also nicht die gesamte Veranstaltung, aber die Merkel-Rede ganz insbesondere. Und die wollen wir nun auch hier vorstellen. Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, wo ist Meike Kohl? Und das erklärt natürlich, dass es also die Gegenveranstaltung, möchte man fast sagen. Denn ich war natürlich auch überrascht, wenn da Meike Kohl noch dabei wäre, dann hätte sie ja niemals Merkel eingeladen. Denn Merkel ist ja auch so ein bisschen unsere Queen insofern, als sie Akzente zu setzen weiß bei der Kohl-Beerdigung. Nämlich dankte sie ja als erstes einmal Hannelore Kohl. Und damit auch ganz deutlich gesagt, was hier los ist.
Man könnte eine eigene Netflix-Kortserie daraus machen, wie Angela Merkel in der Einstiftung so gar nichts zu suchen hat, weil die Gründer das nicht wollen. Und in der anderen trifft sie dann auch Friedrich Merz.
Ja, und es ist aber auch noch so mit ihm so ein bisschen, ja, Friedrich Merz hat ja auch eben schon drauf hingewiesen, aber das habe ich uns jetzt mal alles nicht mitgebracht. Ja, warum habe ich überhaupt uns jetzt noch mal Merkel mitgebracht? Nun, ich habe ein bisschen in die Clips rein geschaut, was wird jetzt gerade in den Talkshows, die alle zurückgekehrt sind aus dem Sommerurlaub leider, und was wird da jetzt zu Ukraine gesagt? Und ich will es kurz zusammenfassen, das passiert da gerade.
Genau, es ist eine sehr schöne Darstellung deines Satzes, für die es immer Tag eins ist. Man redet über ein Thema, als ob man noch nie darüber geredet hätte, erst recht nicht gestern.
Als wenn ich Programmleiter wäre, oder derjenige, der das am Ende ins System einspeist, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert. Ich würde einfach mal eine Sendung vom, sagen wir, 12. März nehmen und die statt der aktuellen spielen und mal gucken, ob es irgendjemand merken würde. Ich würde es mal probieren. Jedenfalls war Merkel da und sie soll natürlich über Helmut Kohl sprechen und hat eine Anekdote mitgebracht. Sie trifft zum ersten Mal Kohl zu einem richtigen Gespräch, denn es soll wohl für sie nach oben gehen in der Partei. Sie soll ein wichtiges Amt erhalten. Und diese Anekdote habe ich mitgebracht, zum einen, weil sie amüsant ist, zum anderen auch, weil sie uns jetzt so ein bisschen dahin führt, wie man Politik auch verstehen kann.
Als wir dann zusammensaßen, hatte Helmut Kohl im Kern jedoch nur eine Frage an mich und die lautete, wie verstehst du dich mit anderen Frauen? Er duzte ja andere gerne einfach so. Und nun war ich verdutzt, erzählte er etwas von Freundinnen, der Tatsache, dass ich es in der Akademie der Wissenschaften, in meiner Arbeitsgruppe außer der Sekretärin nur mit Männern zu tun gehabt hätte. Und dass ich mit anderen Frauen genauso wenige und genauso viele Probleme und Gemeinsamkeiten hätte wie mit Männern. Helmut Kohl genügte diese Auskunft augenscheinlich. Er fragte noch irgendetwas nach meinem zukünftigen Wahlkreis. Dann war das Gespräch schnell beendet. Offensichtlich hatte es ihn bestärkt, mich beim Bundespräsidenten als zukünftige Bundesministerin für Frauen und Jugend zur Ernennung vorzuschlagen.
Sie hatte sich auf alles vorbereitet. Man kann sich so erstellen, welche Fragen werden wohl kommen. Er fragt nur, wie ich mich mit Frauen verstehe. Was ich aber mit dieser Anekdote sagen will, ist natürlich, dass Helmut Kohl so ein Gespür hatte für etwas. Natürlich hätte er sie löchern können mit irgendwelchen Kompetenzfragen. Aber wahrscheinlich hat er ohnehin gewusst, dass sie sie beantworten kann. Und dass sie besser Bescheid weiß über diese Fragen, familienpolitische Fragen, als er selbst. Was soll da jetzt gespielt werden? Also fragt er so etwas, um dann eine Antwort zu bekommen, die seinem politischen Gespür hilft zu entscheiden, wer ist die Richtige auf dem Posten?
Am Ende weiß man ja immer nicht, ob da sowieso schon alles Mögliche greift, Proports usw. Man kommt gar nicht drumherum, sie dann. Und dann klopfen wir noch mal kurz ab, ob sie sich mit Frauenthemen überhaupt befassen möchte und wie sie sich mit Frauen versteht. Und dann liegt sie es kurz ab.
Kanzler der Wiedervereinigung, das bedeutet Merkel geht auf 89 ein. Und sie macht hier etwas sehr deutlich, denn wir könnten den Satz anders sagen, also wir haben gerade Pech. Und damals hatte man Glück.
Angesichts des heutigen Krieges Russlands gegen die Ukraine können wir uns gar nicht glücklich genug schätzen, welche unglaubliche Konstellation der Weltgeschichte uns 1989 diese Entwicklung ermöglichte.
Es sind so verschiedene Dinge, die dann zusammenkommen, damit das gerade diese Tür sich öffnet, denn Falmut Kohl war ja einige Jahre vorher auch noch da. Das wäre schön, wenn das so käme. Aber wir haben diese Gegebenheit nicht, also müssen wir mit was anderem arbeiten. Merkel versucht jetzt mal festzumachen, wo wir gerade stehen.
Der Angriffskrieg Russlands und Präsident Putins gegen die Ukraine zerstört das Fundament all dessen, worauf sich die Staatengemeinschaft einschließlich der damaligen Sowjetunion und später Russlands im KSZE-Prozess und in der Charta von Paris geeinigt hatte. Das ist der Befund der jetzigen Lage. Aus diesem Befund gilt es nun, die im Wortsinnen notwendigen Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen. Eine ungeheuer schwierige Aufgabe, das weiß ich sehr wohl.
Und sie versucht jetzt eine Frage zu stellen, die eigentlich, wie sie selbst sagt, unstadthaft ist oder die man nicht seriös beantworten kann. Nämlich, was würde Helmut Kohl heute tun? Da sagt sie, naja, ist ja jemand, der aus seiner Zeit heraus gehandelt hat, deswegen lässt sich das eigentlich nicht so übertragen. Aber wenn man so sieht, politischer Instinkt, gespürpolitische Klugheit, dann natürlich auch den Moment erkennen, wo etwas geht. Wenn das die Politik von Helmut Kohl ausmachte, dann lässt sich vielleicht doch etwas zu dieser Frage sagen.
Ich denke, Helmut Kohl würde heute auf der Grundlage der ihn kennzeichneten drei Prinzipien nach der Zäsur, die der Beginn des Angriffskriegs Russlands gegen die Ukraine am 24. Februar 2022 markiert, zum einen alles daran setzen, die Souveränität und die Integrität der Ukraine zu schützen und wiederherzustellen. Daran kann es, so denke ich, keinen Zweifel geben. Ruft man sich allein den Geist der eingangs erwähnten Tischräte mit ihren zitierten zwei Kernaussagen anlässlich des Honecker-Besuchs in Bonn in Erinnerung. Zugleich war Helmut Kohl ein Politiker, der in Fragen derartiger Tragweite, also in Fragen von Krieg und Frieden, von Unfreiheit und Freiheit, niemals den Tag danach aus dem Blick verlor. Mehr noch, der diesen Tag immer mitdachte, auf unsere heutige Zeit übertragen, so denke ich, würde er neben der entschlossenen Unterstützung der Ukraine parallel immer auch das Moment, das im Moment so undenkbare, schier unvorstellbare mitdenken, nämlich wie so etwas wie Beziehungen zu und mit Russland wieder entwickelt werden können. Beides würde er natürlich niemals in einem deutschen Alleingang angehen, sondern nur im gemeinsamen Handeln mit unseren Partnern in der Europäischen Union und in der NATO.
Melnik ist ja bei Twitter direkt ein bisschen nervös geworden aufgrund dieser Aussagen oder ist, wir sagen mal, er ist wieder ausgeflippt. Aber das ist ja so seine Masche inzwischen. Und er findet ja auch immer noch großen Zuspruch bei deutschen Medienhäusern. Aber diese Vermessung des Kohlerbes und die Übertragung ist ja zunächst einmal sehr sinnvoll, die Merkel hier macht, indem sie sagt, wir haben zum einen natürlich die Unterstützung, die würde Helmut Kohl auch leisten, zu anderen aber muss der Tag danach mitgedacht werden. Und da bekommt man zumindest in der medialen Berichterstattung den Eindruck, dass es gar keinen Tag danach geben kann.
Genau, Tag danach ist ja immer die Frage mit oder ohne Putin. So und ich weiß nicht, ob sie hier selbst zu viel aktuelle Politik, wie sie gerade gemacht wird, einfach nochmal Helmut Kohl überstümpelt. So im Sinne von, der hätte das auch so gemacht. Also nochmal so eine eigentlich ein bisschen illegitime Legitimation sich da einfach abholen aus so einem, ja, einfach herausgelesen im Erbe, das so genau gar nicht drinsteckt. Denn wir wissen ja von Helmut Kohl, er hätte es ja vielleicht doch abwenden können im Sinne von seine Tages- also seine Agenda pro Tag begann ja immer damit, erst mal fünf, sechs Parteimitglieder anzurufen, die Geburtstag haben. Also erst mal eine halbe Stunde so fünf Minuten Gespräche zu führen, zu gratulieren, zu fragen, wie geht es und so. Und diese Entfremdung auf persönlicher Ebene zu Russland zum Beispiel, wäre ihm vielleicht gar nicht passiert. Also wirklich im Sinne von...
Das ist jetzt natürlich schwierig. Also sie würde jetzt immer sagen, das war halt diese unglaubliche historische, weltgeschichtliche Konstellation, die es ergeben hat. Und da war er dann auch noch der richtige Mann für.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja von selbst Angela Merkels Amtszeit, dass sich Putin da sowas nicht getraut hat oder hätte. Und dass auch Christoph Heusgen aus allen Wolken fiel. Dass das plötzlich... Klar, man hätte jetzt im Nachhinein sagen können, der Putin lag so auf Lauer und er wollte diesen Merkel ist nicht mehr da Moment abwarten, weil er gewusst hätte, also Merkel muss nur mit dem Finger schnippen und die Allianz gegen ihn hätte gestanden weltweit, weil sie einfach diese Rolle hat. Und er setzte auf eine gewisse Schwäche von Olaf Scholz. Also er hat sozusagen so einen historischen Moment.
Und beiden noch dazu aufgespräche.
Genau, so ein Schwachpunkt der Demokratien, dass sie nämlich einfach mal wirklich starke, durchsetzungsfähige und auch medial überzeugende Amtsführer, da einfach, wenn die aussortiert werden, dass man dann da in so eine Lücke springt. Aber es wäre bestimmt so ein großes, was man heute nicht sieht, auch so ein großes Bedauern bei Helmut Kohl gewesen, dass man es auf persönlicher Ebene nicht verhindert hat. Dass man dazu selten angerufen hat, dass jemand zu weit enteilt ist und man eigentlich nochmal hätte das Gespräch suchen sollen.
Auch weil der andere nicht wollte. Du hattest ja diesen Clip damals von Marscha Gessen, die nochmal so schön sagte, das ist auch ein Resultat des Lockdowns. Also Putin hat sich völlig isoliert und hat dadurch auch niemand an sich rangelassen und hat diese einsamen Entscheidungen gefällt. Ich glaube, man hat fast den Eindruck, wenn wir darüber sprechen, wir sind noch in so einem royalen Modus. Was hat die Queen gedacht und was denkt sie über Meghan? Aber wir haben das schon mehrmals deutlich gemacht in diesem Podcast. Ich würde es hier auch nochmal sagen. Deswegen ist dann auch so eine Anekdote, gar nicht so blöde, von Merkel, wie sie da auf Helmut Kohl trifft und befördert wird. Nun, wir haben natürlich große wirtschaftliche Interessen, geopolitische Konstellationen. Wir haben Gremien, die Tagenexperten, die beratschlagen und so weiter. Aber es gibt auch diese direkte persönliche Komponente, die du jetzt auch gerade meintest, wie oft hat man eigentlich telefoniert und Dinge ausgemacht. Und diese Art des persönlichen Vertrauens, das ist ja das, was bei Helmut Kohl immer so gesagt wird, was er dann selbst zu Maggie Thatcher aufbauen konnte, weil er ihr erzählte, ich war heute Nachmittag am Grab von Churchill, da wollte ich nur mal hin. Solche Dinge sind es dann, die plötzlich Weltpolitik entscheiden. Das ist so verrückt, weil es auch diese unglaubliche Kontingenz in der Weltpolitik zeigt, weil das dann sich nicht einfach logisch oder teleologisch entfaltet, hin auf ein Ziel gerichtet. Aber dass das eine wichtige Komponente ist, ist zweifellos gegeben.
Das sieht man ja an Gerhard Schröder und Putin. Das wäre da undenkbar gewesen, dass Putin Schröder vor so einem Problem stellt, das jetzt als Bundeskanzler organisieren zu müssen. Sondern die hätten da natürlich alle möglichen Wege gesucht.
In welcher Weise hat jetzt Schröder uns in das Problem weiter reingeführt.
Richtig, genau.
Das ist dann auch das, wo die persönliche Bindung einen vergessen lässt, dass man auch eigentlich sein Land da vertritt und dessen Interessen. Und nicht nur schaut, was kann ich danach noch Schönes machen, wenn ich nicht mehr Bundeskanzler bin. Das ist natürlich dann genau dieser Kipppunkt, wo man glaubt, wir verstehen uns ja nur auf persönlicher Ebene. Ach so, mit den Ländern da ist mir egal. Und das ist genau diese Vergessenheit. Und eigentlich hat das ja bei Schröder mindestens eine doppelte, wenn nicht dreifache Konstellation. Einmal so, ich lasse die Sozialdemokratie hinter mir mit der Agenda 2010. Ich drehte auf und sage hurra, wir haben den Niedriglohnsektor, wo man eigentlich sagt, mir sind jetzt die Menschen nicht wichtig. Ich habe hier als Bundeskanzler andere Aufgaben zu vertreten. Und dann nochmal so einen dritten Verrat, wenn man so möchte, zu sagen, ja klar ist das sinnvoll, in einem guten Verhältnis zu Russland zu stehen, aber ich mache da jetzt so ein persönliches Verhältnis draus, dass ich davon ein großer Profiteur bin und denke gar nicht mehr darüber nach, was das eigentlich für das Land bedeuten könnte, wenn diese Abhängigkeit zu groß wird.
Ja, ich finde es sehr gut, dass Merkel diesen Punkt gemacht hat, dieser Tag danach, denn es ist eine gute Erinnerung an Helmut Kohl im Sinne von, wenn man sie heute, also sie wird ja heute vorgetragen, also wenn man sie heute sozusagen so interpretiert, weil das ja der aktuellen Bundesregierung fehlt. Diese Sanktionen, auch wie Ursula von der Leyen, die Sanktionen bleiben und da führt auch kein Weg ran vorbei, egal wie die Bevölkerung leidet und die leidet da eben krass. Also dass man da wirklich krass rücksichtslos vorgeht und diesen Tag danach gar nicht mitbedenkt. Schon allein weil man schon diesen Tag, nicht nur den Tag danach, sondern schon diesen Tag, wo sich das mal ändern sollte. Also Sieg, Niederlage von wem auch immer, selbst das wird ja gar nicht themativiert, sondern man versucht nur den Zustand jetzt, dieser, muss man auch sagen, so einen gewissen Demütigung so lange wie möglich zu strecken, in der Hoffnung, dass sich dann schon irgendwas ergibt. Aber so richtig Zielsetzung hat man ja nicht.
Wir hören mal weiter, wenn es um die politische Klugheit geht.
Im Juni wurde ich in einem Zeitungsinterview gefragt, Sie kennen Putin schon lange, was ist er für ein Mensch? Ich habe geantwortet, man sollte seine Worte ernst nehmen. Und heute möchte ich angesichts der Entwicklungen der letzten Tage ergänzen, Worte ernst zu nehmen, sie nicht von vornherein damit abzutun, sie sei nur ein Bluff, sondern sich ernsthaft mit ihnen auseinanderzusetzen, das ist bei Leibe kein Zeichn von Schwäche oder Beschwichtigung, sondern ein Ausweis politischer Klugheit. Einer Klugheit, die dazu beiträgt, Handlungsspielräume zu erhalten oder, mindestens so wichtig, sogar neue zu erarbeiten.
Auch das ist noch mal ganz klar an die gerichtet. Ich finde, das ist eigentlich die wichtigste Aussage in der ganzen Rede, dass alle von der, wir brauchen die Namen nicht nennen, sie sind ja weit hin bekannt, dass wann immer jemand kommt und sagt, naja, wir müssen aber schon aufpassen, dass wir nicht einen Atomkrieg bekommen, und dann so gesagt wird, naja, der plappt. Und man denkt immer, ja, aber woher wollt ihr das wissen, dass der plappt? Und wenn sie jetzt noch mal sagt, ich kenne den, und die sollte man ernst nehmen, und das ernst zu nehmen ist auch kein Zeichen von Schwäche, dann ist hier jemand, der das wirklich aus der direkten Erfahrung politisch ganz anders betrachten kann als irgendwelche Kolumnistenschreiber. Und ich finde das noch mal ganz entscheidend, dass sie das hier sagt. Und das ist auch meine große Hoffnung, ja, dass diese politische Klugheit, die Merkel hier beschreibt, bei Olaf Scholz, auch wenn es uns nicht immer so gleich erscheinen will, doch vorhanden ist. Und mir scheint es, dass es da jedenfalls, also in der SPD am stärksten momentan vorhanden ist, die politische Klugheit angesichts dieser Bedrohung, die da ist.
Ja, das ist eigentlich super interessant, weil wir ja schon sagen müssen, Olaf Scholz hat das vor dem Kriegsbeginn wahnsinnig ernst genommen. Er ist zu beiden gefahren, er hat, wann nimmt er Nord Stream in den Mund, dieses ganze Theater da ein bisschen ausgeblendet, hat dann gewartet, bis er bei Putin war, um dann dort die Drohung auszusprechen, dann ist Nord Stream Geschichte und so weiter. Heute denken wir nachher, nein, ja klar, es ist dann Geschichte, das muss man gar nicht nochmal sagen, aber die Journalisten haben uns das ja so als Theater, Schauspiel und Drehbuch da hingestellt, dass wir irgendwie da auch ganz verpeilt waren. Also die haben es alles ernst genommen und ich finde, genau wie du sagst, genauso ernst muss man heute auch nehmen, dass eben der Olaf Scholz, der das damals schon so ernst nahm, dass der Krieg wirklich droht und dann nochmal diese ganzen Reisen macht, auch damit rechnet, dass es wirklich zu Atomwaffeneinsatz kommt. Und das sollte man eben auch ernst nehmen. Und jetzt schon wieder diese Häme, wenn man prächt hört in diesen kleinen Snippets. Ich habe sie jetzt im Markus Lanz Podcast gehört. Ja, würdest du heute nochmal anders über den Krieg reden als damals, weil es ergibt sich ja jetzt eine andere Situation. Ja klar, jetzt würde ich auch sagen, kann man mit Waffen anders umgehen, weil man ja sieht, okay so stark sind die Russen da gar nicht und so weiter. Ja, aber das führt eben auch zu der Situation, dass man diese Häme darüber, dass Prächt ja immer vor Atomwaffen gewarnt hat, dass man dem eigentlich näher gekommen ist. Also dass man das eigentlich droht, dass man jetzt sagen muss, naja der Prächt hat einfach, das ist ja völlig irre, der hat ja irgendwie mit Atomwaffen und so gelabert, dabei schaffen die es dann nicht mal, einen normalen Krieg zu führen. Und dann ja genau, deswegen wird es ja so gefährlich mit den Atomwaffen.
Und das war ja genau das, was Merkel gesagt hat, also aufgrund der Entwicklung der letzten Tage. Also die Rede wurde ja vor zwei Tagen gehalten und das war jetzt mit aufgrund generaler Mobilmachung, aufgrund der Niederlagen, dass sie sagt, ich habe da mal so ein Interview gegeben vor zwei Monaten und habe da gesagt, ja wir müssen das sehr ernst nehmen, wenn Putin droht und ich will das sogar noch mal ergänzen mit Folgendem. Das scheint so verrückt zu sein, dass das so eine randständige Position ist. Also ich meine, wir beziehen uns hier auf den Bundeskanzler und auf die Bundeskanzlerin, die ehemalige. Das ist jetzt nun wirklich nicht besonders zu versiefen. Aber es ist so absurd. Und ein letzter Gedanke, der auch mich etwas überrascht hat, ist folgender von Merkel.
Wenige wussten die Bedeutung politischer Klugheit so zu achten wie Helmut Kohl, der seinen Amt 1982 in den dunklen Zeiten des Kalten Krieges antrat. Übrigens, der damals von vielen abgelehnte NATO-Doppelbeschluss, für den er wie auch sein Vorgänger Helmut Schmitz sich sehr einsetzte, hieß Doppelbeschluss.
Nun werde ich jetzt hier nicht zum Verteidiger eines NATO-Doppelbeschlusses. Das ist auch gar nicht notwendig. Aber die Überlegung noch mal hier der NATO-Doppelbeschluss, der sagt, wir rüsten zwar auf, aber das eigentliche Ziel ist, dass es dann eine Abrüstung, eine nicht weitere Aufrüstung von der anderen Seite gibt, sondern dass wir dann gemeinsam abrüsten und dass sich auch da eine geschichtliche Konstellation für genau das ergeben hat. Das ist wirklich etwas, was man noch mal in anderer Weise betrachten muss. Also wenn sie das noch mal so betont, Doppelbeschluss. Also das ist momentan haben wir so diese, wir gehen in diese eine Richtung und wir fragen nicht nach dem Tag danach und all das. Aber wenn man den Doppelbeschluss sieht, als immer schon den Tag danach mitgedacht und eigentlich soll es dann generell eine Abrüstung geben. Wir gehen dann noch mal den Weg, inwieweit das jetzt wirklich so wahnsinnig intelligent und alles, aber das brauchen wir nicht noch mal aufdröseln. Aber dass man zumindest auf so eine Konstellation kommt, also wo man so eine Kippfigur dann baut, das ist etwas, was wir momentan im Diskurs auch von diesen ganzen Militärexperten oder den meisten Militärexperten, die wir hören, überhaupt nicht erleben. Und das ist schon dann erstaunlich, wie man da in den 80er Jahren war. Und klar, da gab es die Friedensbewegung, die sich aufgrund dessen ja erst mal erstarkt hat und die gegen diesen Doppelbeschluss war. Aber vielleicht hat man doch immerhin sehen können, dass es grundsätzlich eine Idee auch der Abrüstung wiederum war. Und da geht ja momentan gar nichts hin, sondern wir haben ja von allen Ländern und man sieht es ja an den Budgets, an den Entwicklungen nur Aufrüstung und da ist überhaupt nicht mehr irgendwo diese Idee. Und dann könnten wir, wenn wir so ein Gleichgewicht haben, wieder abrüsten gemeinsam. Das ist ja ein weiter weiter Ferne.
Ja, finde ich auch auf Ebene der Sanktion, die dann wirklich ein zivilgesellschaftlicher Eingriff, also da ist ja wirklich das Ziel, die Volkswirtschaft zu zerstören. Ich verstehe nicht, warum man nicht von Anfang an, wir haben es ja auch schon ein paar mal thematisiert, sagt, okay, wir frieren Geld der Zentralbank ein, es bleibt aber russisches Geld. Und alle Oligarchenvermögen, die wir hier einfrieren, werden minutiös bilanziert und stehen dann auch dem Tag danach Russland zur Verfügung. Also hier wird nicht enteignet, sondern sozusagen, dass man dieses Einfrieren einfach noch mal richtig ernst nimmt und ausformuliert, was es bedeutet, um damit auch ein Angebot zu machen, den zivilen Kräften, den es da in Russland gibt. Und es werden ja Petitionen geschrieben und auch in die regionalen Parlamente eingebracht, dass man denen so ein bisschen Rückhalt gibt, eine Argumentationsbasis. Wenn wir erst mal uns ja durchgesetzt haben und die Duma wird ja auch nicht drum rumkommen auf ihre Tagesordnung, so Abberufung von Putin und sowas, dann zumindest ablehnen zu müssen. Aber damit ist es Tagesordnungspunkt, dass man da so eine Argumentation dranhängen kann.
Also wir haben ja immer gesagt, das ist eigentlich eine kluge Strategie oder eine, das ist eine Kriegsführung, die es seit über 100 Jahren gibt und die sicherlich die sinnvollere ist, also einen Wirtschaftskrieg zu führen oder auch ein Financial Warfare. Und da muss aber eigentlich auch so NATO-Doppelbeschluss mäßig das so mit drin sein, dass wenn, dann muss da sein. Und ich hab momentan wirklich den Eindruck, es gibt so eine Phobie, das zu denken. Also wir haben jetzt Männer, die aus Russland rauswollen, die vor Krieg flüchten und wir haben eine Debatte darüber, ja, sollen wir die jetzt wirklich aufnehmen? Also Mick, der ja häufiger bei dir im Podcast zu Gast ist, hatte das so schön getwittert, er schrieb, wir sind nicht Herren über Leben und Tod, die Menschenrechte und Bedürfnisse, wie zum Beispiel nicht sterben, jetzt an irgendwelche fraglichen Umfragen oder individuelle Moralvorstellungen zu koppeln, geht es noch. Manche deutsche Helden sollten mal Kriegspause machen, wenn es so entmenschlicht. Und das finde ich so was von entsetzlich, dass man jetzt glaubt, also Leute, die vor Krieg fliehen, die nicht sterben wollen in einem Krieg und nicht kämpfen wollen und damit auch nicht andere töten wollen, dass man die jetzt noch mal extra befragen wird und sagt, ja, und warst du denn vor zehn Jahren auch schon gegen Putin? Oder was sollen die denn da sagen? Na ja, offenbar sind die bereit, das Land zu verlassen. Das muss man ja erst mal machen, nur um dann nicht zu kämpfen. Und dass das jetzt dann noch so getan wird. Also es gibt ja auch jetzt diese, also wir haben die ganze Zeit über Verschwörungstheorien gesprochen. Ja, und haben ja viel gelacht, auch hier. Aber jetzt wird plötzlich aus allem so eine russische Verschwörung gemacht. So, nee, das sind eigentlich dann Putins Trolle, die sind da nur hier und nisten sich dann ein. Also ja, da mag sein, dass da auch irgendjemand dann auf diesem Wege, aber jetzt haltet doch mal bitte die Füße still. Genauso, wo jetzt immer gesagt wird bei jeder Meldung, ja, da ist jemand auf Putin-Propaganda reingefallen. Und so würde ich sagen, naja, wir können auch noch von mündigen Subjekten bisweilen ausgehen.
Das finde ich eh, dass wir das in Deutschland wirklich nicht reflektieren, wundert mich. Entweder wir unterstellen Putin, er ist der Böse. Er zwingt seinem Land über Propaganda und was auch immer, diesen Bereicherungsautokratismus, den wir ja in dem Buch da auch nachgelesen haben, auf. Oder wir erklären das ganze Volk zum Tätervolk. Ja, so und wir haben uns eigentlich darauf geeinigt, Putin, das ist Putin, der ist das Problem. Man kann auch Russland anders regieren und wir kennen auch Wege da von außen unterstützen, tätig zu sein, in welchem begrenzten Rahmen auch immer.
Ja, aber hat ja Unterstützer, der ist nicht umsonst da, aber ist es nicht, das Volk identisch mit Putin. Und ich will noch eine Sache machen. Zum einen sagt man, Putin hat mit seiner Propaganda das ganze Land im Griff. Also es wird gesagt, seit Jahren gibt es eigentlich keine freie Presse mehr, seit Jahren führt Putin seinen Infokrieg und steuert das Volk mit Fehlinformationen. Und dann muss man ja sagen, ja, dann sind ja offenbar die Bürger ideologisch verblendet dadurch. Und das wird sich auch so wiederfinden. Und da werden auch viele sagen, ja, das ist kein Krieg, das ist eine Militäroperation. Aber wie will man dann zugleich wiederum von den Bürgern dann erwarten, die dann jetzt sagen, oh Gott, ich hab Angst zu sterben, ich fliehe, dass die natürlich jetzt den westlichen Liberalismus, ohne dass sie je mit ihm richtig in Berührung kamen im Fernsehen oder so, inhaliert haben und jetzt sofort hier hinkommen und sagen, ich würde gern Mitglied bei den Grünen werden oder was? Also was soll denn da sein? Also es reicht doch, wenn Männer sich entscheiden, für ein Land nicht sterben zu wollen. Was will man dann noch? Und ich bin da wirklich ganz entsetzt darüber, dass das überhaupt als Thema ist. Ich würde ja eher sagen, ja je mehr aus einem Land fliehen, das kennen wir ja noch aus anderen Ländern, wie zum Beispiel DDR oder so. Also wo Leute fliehen aus einem Land, dann ist das für das Land immer scheiße aus verschiedenen Gründen. Und das ist unser, also damit können wir ja richtig wuchern mit diesem Fund, wenn wir sagen, ja also wir haben jetzt ja schon 100.000 Russen, sind schon hier bei uns und die fühlen sich auch gut und wohl.
Genau.
Überlegt euch das auch mal, ob ihr noch kommen wollt.
Sehr gute Punkte. Wir werden es im Salon aufgreifen. Es gibt Textgrundlagen zur demografischen Problemlage Putins. Nicht nur, dass viele flüchten, sondern wenn man die ganzen Leute in so ein Pflichtjahr Krieg schickt, dann zieht man sie auch dem Erwerbsvertrag ein Potenzial. Wenn es dann gerade die 18- bis 27-Jährigen sind, ist natürlich Katastrophe vorprogrammiert, was das angeht. Was du eben noch meintest, wir haben uns eigentlich darauf geeinigt, die Bevölkerung ist ein Propaganda-Opfer von Putin. Und wenn die meinen, sie müssen jetzt vor Krieg flüchten, sollten wir ihnen genau den Kulturschock bieten, nämlich aus dieser Propaganda-Szenerie raus bei uns mal rein. Heißt natürlich auch, wir müssen denen dann ein Angebot machen. Wir stellen ja gerade fest, dass sich selbst die Ukrainer nicht besonders wohl in Deutschland fühlen und sagen, ich weiß, es ist noch Krieg zu Hause, aber ich gehe lieber schon mal zurück. Denn da ist dann doch mehr Lebensaufgabe für mich als hier in Deutschland. Obwohl man hier mittlerweile arbeiten darf und so. Es ist ja noch eine etwas privilegierteren Stellung, als wenn jetzt aus Syrien oder Afghanistan geflüchtet wird. Aber das wirft uns doch auch noch mal auf uns zurück mit der Frage, welches Angebot können wir denn den Russen eigentlich machen hier vor Ort, wenn sie ganz konkret kommen. Und darüber hinaus, welches Angebot können wir den Russen eigentlich machen gegen Putin? Und diese Frage steht unbeantwortet im Raum. Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel. Wir haben letztes Jahr auch über Ursula von der Leyen State of the Union gesprochen. Damals hat sie nämlich das Jahr der Jugend ausgerufen für 2022 und die EU Gelder verteilt, diese 750 Milliarden Pandemie Hilfe, von denen wir heute wissen. Ja, die werden jetzt gerade ausgezahlt an Italien zum Beispiel. Und die sind auch extrem abhängig davon, dass diese Gelder fließen. Wir kommen nachher darauf zurück. Ursula von der Leyen war also wieder im Parlament und hat dort gesprochen und man muss sagen, ja, es war nicht sehr voll und zwar nicht Corona bedingt, sondern irgendwie so richtig zieht es nicht. Was schade ist, denn ich will jetzt nicht überschwänglich in diese Rede reingehen, aber es sind doch so ein paar Sätze gefallen und wir werden das nachher koppeln mit Olaf Scholz vor der UN. Man muss ja nicht dort das sagen, was sie jetzt ankündigt und sagt, sondern sie hätte ja alles sagen können, aber sie hat sich halt dafür entschieden. Und Olaf Scholz wollte seine Rede verstecken, sie fand keinen Anklang. Seine 17 Minuten vor der UN. Hier ist es ein bisschen schade, dass wir Ursula von der Leyen ihn nicht gehört haben, aber wir hören uns langsam warm. Zuerst einmal geht es um ihre Bewunderung darüber, wie schnell Europa zur Solidarität gefunden hat, als Putin die Ukraine angriff, während das ja bei anderen Krisen anders war. Und da würde ich sagen, na mal den Winter noch abwarten.
Von diesem Moment her haben die Europäer weder geflogen, noch verletzt, sie haben die Kraft gefunden, das Richtige zu tun. Ein Jahr später, als die globalen Pandemie abwarten, hat sie uns nur Wochen lang gehalten.
Ja, Only Weeks zu, wir machen jetzt mal dies und jenes Sanktionspaket. Und jetzt sehen wir grad, wir uns auch selber mit den Fuss schießen. Und so würde ich sagen, mal die Energiepreisentwicklung abwarten, den Winter, ob dann die große Einigkeit, wie sie hier von In Europa geht, da ist oder vielleicht nicht. Sie wird so ein bisschen pathetisch. Mut kennt einen oder hat einen neuen Namen. Es ist die Ukraine und darin steckt aber dieses etwas verlogene Argument. Wir haben es schon ein paar mal gebracht. Wir müssen es ja auch noch mal anbringen, weil das auf so prominenter Bühne so pathosüberladen dargeboten wurde. Wir haben es schon ein paar Mal thematisiert. Wir schicken Material in die Ukraine, damit die dort auch unsere Freiheit mit verteidigen. Und wir haben sehr gute Argumente, keine Soldaten hinzuschicken, also nicht unsere eigene Biomasse zu gefährden, weil dann wären wir Kriegspartei und das wollen wir nicht.
Deswegen sagt Habermas, wir sitzen immer nur auf den Zuschauerringen.
Genau. Und das ist aber ein echtes Problem, weil wir die Ukrainer damit auch ein bisschen im Stich lassen. Muss man einfach sagen. Denn da gibt es unendlich viele Todesfälle und Leid und an dem beteiligen wir uns nicht, sondern wir senden schöne Sätze. Und kippen Material hinterher, damit dieser Krieg auch lange hart geforten wird. Als ich jetzt Richard David Precht hörte, wie er da auf Lands reagierte und meinte, ja heute würde ich anders über den Krieg reden als damals direkt danach, weil ich nämlich auch überrascht bin davon, wie schwach die zweitgrößte Armee der Welt Russlands aufgestellt ist, da würde ich sagen, wir haben bisher noch nicht ganz verstanden und es ist auch noch uns nicht gezeigt worden, wie groß die Bemühungen zum Beispiel im Pentagon waren, diese historische Gelegenheit, Russland zu besiegen und auch in einem echten Krieg zu bekämpfen, genutzt wurde. Man darf sich darüber natürlich öffentlich nicht freuen und da gibt es auch keine Lorbeeren einzusammeln, das würde ja alles zu diesem Gesichtsverlust-Problem zufügen, aber ich glaube, da ist noch so eine ungeschriebene Geschichte, dass man sich das nochmal genau anschauen muss.
Die Unterstützung ist immens und es wird so ein bisschen verdeckt, hat Deutschland schon das und das geliefert. Aber da wir ja gemeinsam mit den Verbündeten alles machen, ist es ja abgestimmt und dann gibt es natürlich immer solche Nickeligkeiten, wer hat jetzt mehr und was und so, aber natürlich ist da schon eine Extremmacht, das ist ja nicht so, als hätte jetzt das kleine Land das nur für sich geregelt, sondern es gab diese große Unterstützung und ich finde auch diese Sätze, sowohl weil die zu sagen, ja Mut hat einen Namen und so weiter und wir sehen in die Gesichter, ja in die Gesichter kann man bald nicht mehr sehen, weil die dann auch getötet sind und das sind dann einfach, da zeigt sich dann auch wieder herum so klar, dass wir es damit schon mit einer Politik zu tun haben, die sagt, wir halten unsere Leute daraus, aber wenn ihr das da macht, dann finden wir das wunderbar, aber wir sind damit natürlich in der Konstellation, wenn wir diesen Satz da ernst nehmen, die sterben auch für unsere Freiheit, dann kann man das auch aktiver formulieren, die lassen wir für unsere Freiheit dann sterben. So, also man kann nicht, dass wir, also ich weiß, dass der Krieg ja nicht aufzulösen ist ganz leicht, sondern und der Aggressor ist der andere, also da können wir nicht einfach sagen, wir schrauben das runter, sondern der andere ist der Aggressor, nur wir kommen da in eine ganz, ganz heikle Sache an, die überdeckt wird mit so blumigen Formulierungen, wo man sagen muss, nee, das ist nicht einfach dieser Heroismus, der da heraufbeschworen wird. Und da sind sehr, sehr kalte Machtinteressen dahinter, die auf Kosten von Menschen gehen, die da und das sind in dem Sinne, in dem Fall der Ukrainer, die dann da sterben. Wie gesagt.
Genau, wir überbetonen den Heroismus der Ukrainer und wir unterbelichten unsere Kriegsbeteiligung. Es gehört aber auch dieser Spruch, die Wahrheit stimmt immer zu ersten Krieg dazu. Es ist ganz wichtig für die Art der Kriegsführung, dass der Tenor grad ist, wir unterstützen zu wenig. Weil ansonsten wäre die russische Reaktion wahrscheinlich auch eine andere.
Aber auch wenn wir mehr unterstützen würden, das muss man auch ganz klar sagen, wenn wir doppelt so viel liefern würden, oder zehnmal so viel, wir kommen aus der Konstellation nicht raus, dass das andere da machen. Also wir haben das outgesourct, wenn man so möchte. Also wir sind nicht aus Gründen, sonst könnte ein Dritter Weltkrieg drohen oder so, zum Beispiel nicht daran beteiligt. Aber natürlich auch, weil das sehr schlecht zu verkaufen ist in Ländern wie Deutschland, dass wir aktiv da reingehen. Wir sehen, dass Afghanistan demakel, und da würden wir jetzt hier es auch mit viel mehr deutschen Opfern zu tun haben. Also tausende deutsche Soldaten sterben in einem solchen Krieg. Nehmen wir mal an, man würde den über so einen ganz klassischen Weg führen können. Und wir klammern mal diese Atomwaffengeschichte aus. Das wäre ganz schwer verkaufbar und wirklich auch nicht wünschenswert. Und insofern sourcen wir die Soldatentode, um das ganz drastisch zu sagen, out.
Es ist eine ganz normale europäische Wirtschafterei, die da stattfindet. Irgendwo arbeiten 50 Sklaven für uns, in deren sich das alte Modell noch mal durchgepeitscht. Ursula von der Leyen übertreibt es so ein bisschen. Sie hat die First Lady Zelensky da und betont noch mal die großen Leistungen und ich würde sagen dann fast des Häuserkampfes.
Wir sahen die erste Frau, die eine silenke Stimmung von gebrochenen Müttern und Vatern und kleine Kugeln in den Bäumen hängen. Und für immer werden die unbekannten Schützer dieser Waffe in unseren Erinnerungen leben. Meine liebe Olena Zelenska, es hat viel Kraft genommen, Putin zu retten. Und wir sehen in den letzten Tagen, dass die Ukrainier die Bravour des Volkes aufgeben.
Da hat aber auch jemand sehr viele Marvel-Filme geguckt, oder?
Ja, also sie referiert auch viel da noch mal, wie Selenski ihr berichtet, wie das so im Schulalltag ist, wenn man den Kindern morgens nicht nur die Brotbüchse für den Tag füllt, sondern auch noch schon einmal denkt, was wäre, wenn sie es heute nicht nach Hause schaffen und man sorgt noch so ein paar Tage vor und so. Alles rührselig, wahrscheinlich zu Recht da angebracht, aber eben auch auf so einer etwas komischen Ebene, sie da so im Parlament darüber reden zu hören. Dann geht es hier allerdings ins Eingemachte. Wir wissen ja, die EU hat über alle Staatsführer und so weiter, der Ukraine die Solidarität und auch die EU-Mitgliedschaft angeboten. Das ist ja vor allem dann auch Olaf Scholzes Kuh gewesen. Und dann kam gleich die Reaktion, ja, das wird aber noch Jahrzehnte dauern und so. Und das EU-Mitgliedschaft eigentlich bedeutet, ist ja Teilnahme am EU-Binmarkt. Und da wollte sie einen kurzen Prozess machen.
Wir wissen die Macht, die in diesem Single Market liegt. Und das ist warum ich heute in Kiew gehen, um das mit Präsident Zelensky zu diskutieren und ihm zu zeigen, was der Single Market ist als Potenzial für die Zukunft der Ukraine.
Denn wir wissen ja, im EU-Binnenmarkt geht es allen Ländern prächtig, die mitmachen, vor allem Deutschland oder vor allem Deutschland.
Also EU-Binnenmarkt ist deswegen immer wieder interessant, weil das eben diese immensen IGRA-Reichtümer sind, die da plötzlich eine Rolle spielen. Und wir wissen, dass die EU nur aus Agarsubventionen besteht und sonst fast nichts. Alles Weitere, ich weiß auch nicht, das sollte mal echt ein Journalist aufgreifen und mal beschreiben, was das bedeutet, wie viel Umverteilung der Subventionen das dann so mit sich bringt. Zudem, es ist eben auch ein großes Land, da kommen dann wieder 40 Millionen Menschen, also je nach Migrationslage, die dann auch wirklich diese Freizügigkeit genießen. Das kommt ja alles so in die Waagschale. Und es ist ja dann auch 80-90% der eigentlichen Bedeutung von EU-Mitgliedschaft. Das ist ja ein bisschen wie die Schotten, die jetzt sagen, wir wünschen uns jetzt wirklich den Abgang aus dem Vereinigten Königreich, aber die Queen als Staatsoberhaupt kann ruhig bleiben. Das ist ja so die Botschaft, wo man sich denkt, ach so, genau, stimmt, ihr wollt ja nur alles andere. Mit der Queen, das ist ja dann nur noch so kür. Und so ist das ja hier auch. Ob man es dann EU-Mitgliedschaft nennt oder nicht, wenn der Binnenmarkt offen ist, dann bedeutet das für alle was. Naja, mal sehen, wie die politische Diskussion da läuft.
Die bekommen aber dann hoffentlich auch sofort eine Schuldenbremse.
Ja, also die hatten ja jetzt schon zu wenig Geld.
Also das ist ja auch, wir unterstützen, wenn wir von Unterstützung in deutschen Talkshows reden, dann meinen wir Waffen. Die Zelensky-Regierung hat ja immer wieder Zahlungsprobleme, weil die natürlich einen Krieg an der Backe haben, der extrem teuer ist. Was auch sonst. Und natürlich kommt sehr viel weniger rein. Und es war ja so, dass man da dringend Hilfe von der EU brauchte und man dann von der EU gesagt hat, ja August ist jetzt gerade schlecht, wir sind gerade im Urlaub. Wir kümmern uns dann danach darum. Also ich will das nur mal deutlich machen, wir reden die ganze Zeit über Unterstützung der Ukraine. An dem Finanziellen wird das am Ende ganz stark festzumachen sein. Also wir werden diese Debatten, wir werden die wahrscheinlich hier noch führen, wenn die keiner mehr führt. Das wird dann nämlich sein, ja, EU hat sich also nochmal durchringen können, nochmal so 5 Millionen für Bildung in der Ukraine auszugeben, aber mehr war da nicht und so. Und dafür hat man eine halbe Schule gebaut. Also das wird genau in diese Richtung laufen. Und da ist aber dann nicht mehr jeden Abend Talkshows zu.
Wir brauchen jetzt einfach eine Ernte von denen. Also BIN-Markt heißt einem auch wirklich kurzer Weg, kurze Erträge, nicht so viel Bürokratie. Denn am Ende übernimmt einfach wie jedes andere EU-Land natürlich die Gesetzgebung, wie sie ist. Es gehen dann alle Schlichtungs- und Juristereien ausgehend von Brüssel und so. Und dann schauen wir mal. Aber es ist halt schon so eine materielle Aneignung, muss man auch irgendwie sagen. Weil in dem Moment, wo man die Ukraine in den europäischen BIN-Markt aufnimmt, zieht man sie natürlich auch aus den anderen Wirtschaftszusammenhängen raus. Gerade was Versorgung Afrikas und so weiter angeht. Rosa von der Leyen macht hier mal einen ganz kurzen Sprung vom Gasmarkt. Funktioniert nicht mehr zur Klimakrise. Das finde ich ja gut, das mal zu verkoppeln. Denn wir blenden ja gerade Klimakrise so ein bisschen aus. Also dass wir jetzt wieder 17 Prozent mehr Kohle verfeuern als letztes Jahr, wird ja gar nicht so groß thematisiert. Weil muss ja alles sein, auch das mit den Atomkraftwerken. Da sind bei ihr die Wege zwischen den Problemen so ein bisschen kürzer.
Zwei Figuren, die interessant sind. Letztes Jahr hat der russische Gas 40 Prozent unserer importierten Gas gegründet.
So, über die Klimakrise kann sie natürlich hier dann einfach ein bisschen ausholen, weil erneuerbaren Energien, das ist ja dann zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe, also Resilienz und Klimaschutz, aber am Ende dieses kleinen Klimaschutzsegmentes, von dem wir uns einfach vorstellen können, wie er so abläuft, kommt sie dann wieder zurück aufs Gas.
Auf der anderen Seite müssen wir die globale Kompetenz sicherstellen. Die Sicherheit des Gas, weil das Gas noch auf die Europäische Union kommt, die Energie aller Alltäten. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn es zu teuer ist, schämen wir unsere globale Kompetenz.
Also erneuerbare Energien, schön und gut, vielleicht ab 2025 oder so, aber bis dahin sollen dann die LNG-Bude doch nochmal zu uns fahren, aber wir werden auch nochmal in der Liste aufführen, wir wissen jetzt gerade, das kommt aus Katar und wir sind uns da auch bewusst, dass es da nicht gut läuft, aber es soll mal trotzdem zu uns fahren. Man führt so eine Klassifizierung ein für ja, wir wissen schon, es ist irgendwie blöd, aber es soll mal trotzdem herfahren. Also das ist so, naja, diese typische Verlogenheit. Am Ende muss man die Wirtschaftskonkurrenzfähigkeit dann aufrechterhalten Europas und kann nicht durch zwei Jahre Düsternis gehen, um zu glauben, danach könnte man mit anuerbaren Energien das alles wieder aufbauen.
Wir sprechen ja noch über Aserbaidschan heute.
Zum Beispiel, da kommt ja dann alles zusammen. Sie erinnert an die Ölkrise von vor 50 Jahren und möchte einen Fehler vermeiden.
Das ist der Weg, den die CDU nicht gegangen ist. Sie spricht ja hier aus ihrer eigenen Partei heraus.
Genau, in den 70ern. Also der Club of Rome kommt und spricht von den Grenzen des Wachstums und die stellen fest, hm, ganz schön teuer dieses Öl. Na ja, dann subventionieren wir es mal und gehen den Weg weiter. Sie beschreibt ja eigentlich die große Dummheit, das sie damals gemacht haben, verspricht. Und sagt, ja, jetzt machen wir es gerade anders, während sie gleichzeitig vor 5 Minuten sagte, ja, aber die Boote brauchen wir doch nochmal, die das Gas liefern jetzt.
Wie gesagt, ich hab noch nicht diese große Investitionsoffensive gesehen. Also wir sehen mal die eine oder andere kleinere Summe und damit kann man auch das eine oder andere Windrad bauen. Aber heute, als ich hier losfuhr, schon wieder war ich auf 180, als ich sah, die Bahn wird teurer, 4, 9% glaube ich, wegen Inflation. Und dann denke ich mir, das ist die große Verkehrswende. Also ich sehe das nicht. Also ich kann ja verstehen, dass man nicht sagt, ab sofort, dass das vielleicht 3 Jahre etwas dauert. Aber das... Also wie gesagt, da bin ich ja vollkommen pessimistisch.
Also Bahnpreise müssen natürlich rapide sinken. Denn das muss dann vom... Also Bahnpreise müssen einfach sinken, um schon den Verkehr einfach von der Straße wegzuleiten. Dass es dann in die Bahn geht, das sollten wir als Angebot nehmen, dass wir zumindest eine Möglichkeit haben, von langen Autofahrten abzusehen. Gerade Intercity-Verbindungen sind ja mit dem Zug auch viel schneller zu machen. Sie sind halt nur teuer. Das allerdings würde ja bedeuten, irgendwer anders muss den Ticketpreis bezahlen. Könnte ja eine staatliche Aufgabe sein. Genau. Jetzt wissen wir, wer da im Wege steht, nämlich zum Beispiel Andreas Jung mit seinem Gestammel zur Schuldenbremse usw. Haben wir ja vorhin gehört. Bei Ursula von der Leyen klingt das alles ganz anders. Ist wirklich erstaunlich. Vielleicht sollten wir Deutsche, weil sie eine Deutsche ist und aus dieser CDU kommt, uns das wirklich nochmal besonders anhören, was sie jetzt hier sagt. Sie möchte nämlich eine neue EU-Finanzpolitik. Oder sie möchte überhaupt mal eine EU-Finanzpolitik und nicht einfach nur irgendwo in den Verträgen steht irgendwas drin. Da hat sich ja Ole auch völlig zu Recht nochmal angemerkt. Er hat die Maastricht-Kriterien 60% aus dem Hut gezauert. An den Haaren herbei. Also da gibt es keine irgendeine Kalkulation, die das irgendwie absichert, akademisch oder rational. Sondern man hat einfach so gewürfelt und kam auf 60% Schuldenquote, sei irgendwie so ein gesunder Wert. Sie möchte das alles mal zur Diskussion stellen. Diese Sprünge im Video sind übrigens original im Material der Europäischen Union. Das ist irgendwo ein klemmendes Name. So, strategic investment meint, so wie auch von den Grünen vorgeschlagen, wenn man nicht verkonsumiert, sondern wirklich in was Neues investiert, darf man die Schuldenbremse einfach ignorieren. Das hat sie hier nochmal betont, diese grüne Idee aufgegriffen und dann gesagt, ja, Financial Sustainability, das ist halt das, was die CDU dann so will, dieses Zugeständnis sollen wir ja machen, aber eine sehr viel offene, formulierte Schuldenbremsregelung.
Rules that are fit for the challenges of this decade. And therefore in October we will come forward with new ideas for our economic governance. Let me share a few basic principles with you.
So, im Oktober wird sie eine finanzpolitische Rahmengesetzgebung so andeuten. Wir können jetzt alle schon mal, für uns ist das dann die nächste Ausgabe, wir können ja alle mal drauf achten, was wir jetzt im deutschen Standardismus davon geliefert bekommen, wenn diese Vorschläge kommen. Die EU versteht es natürlich auch gut, dann keine Pressekonferenz zu machen, sondern nur so einen PDF hochzuladen, was dann wieder keiner sieht und so. Aber mal gucken, ob wir da jetzt im Oktober eine Diskussion bekommen.
Müssen sich jetzt die deutschen Steuerzahler sorben machen? Werden sie noch mehr zur Kasse gebeten, für das Bluapazie-Monster?
Aber sie hat ja angekündigt, hier kurz mal ein paar Punkte aufzuzählen. Macht sie hier.
Stabilität und Wachstum kann nur Hand in Hand gehen.
Man hat offenbar jetzt gemerkt, dass die Schuldenbremse eine Wachstumsbremse wird.
Es ist eine Wachstumsbremse. Das ist ein sehr guter Vorschlag, ist genau so zu nennen. Die Schuldenbremse ist eine Wachstumsbremse. Und wir sind in Europa, wenn man jetzt die kollektive Verschuldung aller Länder nimmt, bis hin auf die kommunalen Ebene, haben wir so einen Schuldenstand von irgendwie 68 Prozent im Vergleich zur Wirtschaftskraft. Wir wissen aus Amerika 120 oder so, Japan 250. Also da ist noch Spiel nach oben. Da sind noch Billionen, die man noch bewegen kann. Ohne, das hat sich ja betont, dass irgendein Investor dann glauben müsste, oh, das funktioniert aber dann künftig nicht mehr. Nein, man muss es einfach nur mit neuen Formulierungen in Gesetzen absichern. Und dann ist auch klar, da droht nichts. Auch Italien muss man jetzt nicht wieder 4 Prozent abverlangen. Die fallen genauso wenig aus bei 4 Prozent wie bei 1 Prozent. Und dann nimmt man einfach 1 Prozent. Das muss dann auch reichen für so ein Investor. In der Ansicht, ja, ich sehe auch eine Aufgabenstellung für die Europäische Zentralbank, dass man jetzt dann wirklich diese Fettwege geht und auch ein politisches Mandat hinterher schiebt und nicht nur Inflationserwartungen und so. Naja, nächster Punkt, den sie anmerkt, sie möchte die Grundlagen der europäischen Volkswirtschaft jetzt endlich mal, naja, so ein bisschen auf die zukünftigen, wichtigen Fundamente stellen.
Weil die Stärke unserer sozialen Markt-Ekonomie die Drehung und die digitale Transition durchführen wird. Und unser Akillus-Heal für die Small- und Medium-Entrepreisungs- sind basically drei Dinge. Es geht darum, ob wir ein business-Environment erneuern.
Wir mit unserem ICE über die Grenze, also brauchen wir da ein anderes Bremssystem und andere Feuerlöscher, die dann eingebaut werden müssen. Die Bahn kann das dann irgendwie leisten, aber für andere Unternehmen ist das halt immer total bescheuert, immer noch sowas. Und naja, da wird die große, große Vereinheitlichung angefangen. Und ich bin mal gespannt, ob das hier so eine Begründung europäischer Haushalterei ist, also dass man dann auch wirklich sagt, wir homogenisieren das Steuersystem und setzen uns gleich mal mit als Empfänger. Ins Netz, denn jetzt haben wir uns schon verschuldet. Wieso sollten wir nicht auch Steuern einnehmen? So Befit. Während wir in Deutschland diskutieren, dass das dritte Entlastungspaket zwar jetzt die Rentner und Studenten in den Blick nimmt, diskutieren wir schon wieder, die kleinen Unternehmen wollten alle übersehen. Jetzt kommt sie mit Befit und sagt, uns geht es erstmal nur um die kleinen Unternehmen, also nur um die KMUs und so, finde ich gar nicht so ungünstig strategisch platziert, weil die kommen ja mit einem echten Interesse und sehen dann solche Reden, egal was Journalisten nicht darüber berichten und denken sich so, ja, das ist vielleicht gar kein schlechter Weg zu gehen. So und dann ist da auch so ein Einfallstor offen, um da so Interesse zu wecken, was die EU denn zu bieten hat für diese Unternehmen. Sie ist sehr auf der Höhe der Zeit, also hier wird man so...
Vielleicht noch eine Sache mit diesen kleinen mittleren Unternehmen. Die sind ja nicht alle EU-freundlich, sondern wenn man sich da so umhört und wenn man auch so Verlautbarung dann mal vernimmt, dann ist es ja so, dass gerade Unternehmen eine gewisse EU-Feindschaft noch haben. Insofern, wenn man auf Dauer die EU stabilisieren will, dann geht das nur, indem man diesen Unternehmen auch mal zeigt, guckt mal, das lohnt sich wirklich hier für euch.
Genau, wir wollen dir nicht nur die Gurke verbieten, weil sie nicht krumm genug ist oder so, sondern wir finanzieren dich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen. Hier im Folgenden ist sie wirklich auf der Höhe der Zeit, was so die alten republikanischen Herausforderungen ganz Europas angeht.
Die Zahl der Arbeitslosen ist so niedrig wie nie 6, 0 Prozent. 6 Prozent Arbeitslosigkeit, das ist gut. Aber gleichzeitig liegt die Zahl der offenen Stellen auf Rekordniveau. Lastwagenfahrer, Kellnern, Flughafenpersonal, Krankenpfleger, Ingenieurinnen, IT-Technikerinnen. Von Ungelernt bis Universitätsabschluss Europa braucht sie alle. Wir müssen daher viel stärker in Aus- und Weiterbildung investieren. Dazu wollen wir eng mit den Unternehmen zusammenarbeiten, denn sie wissen am besten, welche Fachkräfte sie heute brauchen, aber auch welche Fachkräfte sie morgen brauchen. Und wir müssen diesen Bedarf viel besser in Einklang bringen mit den Zielen und den Wünschen der Arbeitssuchenden selbst für ihren Berufsweg. Wir haben dieses wunderbare große Instrument ESF. Wir brauchen auf der anderen Seite auch eine Struktur, dass diese Gelder wirklich effektiv eingesetzt werden können. Und ein zweites ist auch wichtig. Wir müssen gezielter Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland anwerben, die hier Unternehmen und Europas Wachstum stärken. Und deshalb ist ein wichtiger Schritt, ihre Qualifikationen, die können, was diese Menschen, ihre Qualifikationen in Europa besser und schneller anzuerkennen. Das ist die Möglichkeit, Europa attraktiver zu machen. Für alle, die etwas können und die sich einbringen wollen. Und deshalb schlage ich vor, es ist ein Riesenthema. Das kann man nicht hier abhandeln. Ich schlage vor, dass wir das Jahr 2023 zum Europäischen Jahr der Aus- und Weiterbildung machen. Lasst uns einen Schwerpunkt darauf setzen.
Aus- und Weiterbildung ist ja eigentlich Olaf Scholz Lieblingsthema gewesen. Das ist ja im Koalitionsquartier groß. Das kommt da jetzt gerade nicht dazu. Er will ja die Berufsausbildung auf das akademische Niveau mit Stipendien und Auslandssemestern und dem ganzen Kram heben. Sie macht das jetzt einfach zu ihrem Thema. Warum nicht? Sie räuber da einfach mal thematisch. Mal gucken, wie weit sie es treiben kann. Am Ende ist es eine Finanzierungsfrage. Aber wenn sie noch mal so ein 750 Milliarden-Programm draus strickt, wer weiß, wir kriegen das in Deutschland nicht so mit. Aber die Italiener hängen ja komplett daran, dass da 200 Milliarden jetzt fließen. Alles Mögliche. Bis hin zu das Kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt wird und so. Das sind alles EU-Quellen. Und naja, da sind schon so einige Möglichkeiten da.
Weiß das Gabriele Meloni auch?
Sie weiß es.
Denn sie versucht ja momentan, Stunken Europa zu verbreiten. Also du hast vielleicht das gehört, was sie über Macron gesagt hat. Dass er zynisch sei, dass er wiederwärtig geradezu sei, dass er derjenige ist, der alles den Investoren gibt und wieder die kleinen Leute usw. Sie hat ja deine Rede gegen Macron gehört, wo ich dachte, gut werden die sich jemals noch mal treffen können.
Also Meloni ist gewählt worden. Wir kommen auf das Wahlergebnis gleich mal im Detail da nachher zu sprechen. Und kurze Stunden später hat die EU die nächste Tranche, wie man so schön sagt, bewilligt. Um damit ihr das Zeichen zu setzen, von den 200 Milliarden bleiben wir treu, das Geld fließt, aber an diese Bedingungen geknüpft, unter denen ja Orban leitet, der gerade kein Geld überwiesen kriegt, dass dafür Gegenleistungen erbracht werden müssen. Und jetzt muss Meloni überlegen, wie sie es regelt. Wohl wissend, dass sie von Salvini und Berlusconi, der eine hat 9 und der andere 8% bekommen, und das sind zwei sehr gekränkte Männer gerade, was das angeht.
Berlusconi, ich hab mir die Bilder, hier hab ich auch noch mal großgemacht, mir auf dem Bildschirm. Es ist ja, also ich hab so was auf Atzenhaftes wirklich noch nie gesehen.
Es ist gruselig, genau.
Das ist die Adams Family jetzt.
Es ist wirklich ein bisschen merkwürdig, was da gerade passiert. Genau. Und ja, Ursula von der Leyen hat nicht nur die Arbeitnehmerschaft im Blick, sondern, und das ist ja auch ein großes Thema, diesen Zugang zu Rohstoffen.
Der Zugang zu Rohstoffen ist entscheidend für den Erfolg unserer Transformer zu digitalen Wirtschaft. Lithium und seltene Erden werden bald wichtiger sein als Öl und Gas.
Das ist ein starker Satz, weil wir es uns immer nicht so ganz vorstellen können, weil das hieße ja auch eine Nichtverfügbarkeit von diesen Rohstoffen würde uns noch mehr unter Druck setzen als jetzt dieser Mangel an Gas. Und der bringt schon ganz schön Turbulenzen mit sich, würde ich mal so sagen.
Ja, und da ist China dann der nächste Partner für die Abhängigkeit.
Genau.
Und dann können die sich jetzt angucken, was passiert hier mit Ukraine. Und dann können die das auf Taiwan übertragen und sagen, da ist ja die Abhängigkeit noch größer. Wie wird das dann da ausgehen? Wird man sich da anders aufstellen? Also, ich meine, wir haben ja Zahlen in diesem Monat bekommen vom ersten Halbjahr. Es gibt einen neuen Rekord zu verzeichnen. Noch nie hat die deutsche Industrie, haben also deutsche Firmen so viel Direktinvestitionen in China getätigt. Wir haben zugleich diesen Diskurs, den Habeck ganz stark gemacht. Wir müssen auch sehen, dass wir diversifizieren. Wir müssen von China unabhängiger werden und wir verkünden jetzt hier einen Rekord. Noch nie gab es so viele Direktinvestitionen und die könnten jetzt noch sogar steigen oder beziehungsweise die Abwanderung nach China, das Outsourcen nach China könnte steigen, weil einige Unternehmen, übrigens auch aus dem Mittelstand, sich sagen, jetzt sind die Energiepreise hier so hoch.
Ja, stimmt.
Das lohnt sich für uns nicht. Beziehungsweise jetzt lohnt es sich wirklich für uns, es endlich in China zu machen. Das heißt, wir lösen uns von Russland, aber zu dem Preis, dass wir möglicherweise die Abhängigkeit zu China verstärken, die dann wirtschaftlicher Natur ist und die ist dann so stark durch die Unternehmen. Und das sind ja immer auch Menschen, Arbeitsplätze und all das, dass man dann sagen kann, da kommen wir gar nicht jetzt so los.
Also wenn uns Fachkräfte und Energie fehlt, dann haben wir genau diesen Trend, weshalb sie das auch zu ihrer Großbaustelle erklärt.
China controls the global processing industry. Almost 90%, 90% of rare earth and 60% of lithium are processed in China. So we will identify strategic projects all along the supply chain from extracting to refining, from processing to recycling and we will build up strategic reserves where supply is at risk.
Ja, also es ist nicht nur ein obligatorischer China-Block da drin, sondern sie hat es nochmal auf die vorher gefassten Probleme, Zugang zu Rohstoffen und Arbeitskraft hier nochmal betont.
Und das ist auch wichtig, das europäisch zu sehen. Also hier ist dann auch unsere lieben Verbündeten in Amerika noch da eine neue Meldung. Das ist jetzt hier aus der Wirtschaftswoche. Biden schottet US-Markt ab, da geht es um die E-Autos. US-Präsident Joe Biden erhofft sich von seinem milliardenschweren Gesetzespaket gegen die Inflationenauftrieb für die Midterm-Wahlen. Im November haben wir schon drüber gesprochen. Er diskriminiert damit aber offen Hersteller von E-Autos aus Drittländern. Steuervergünstigungen von bis zu 7500 Dollar erhalten Käufer von E-Autos nur noch, wenn die Wagen in den USA, Mexiko oder Kanada produziert wurden. Wir merken, Europa ist nicht dabei. Ab dem kommenden Jahr muss auch mindestens die Hälfte der Batterie-Komponenten in Nordamerika hergestellt worden sein. Und das hat dann wiederum zur Folge, dass Elon Musk mit Tesla jetzt doch plant, weniger Batterien in Deutschland zu produzieren, weil er die ja dann gar nicht in Amerika absetzen kann. Deswegen eine wirkliche Unabhängigkeit, die von der Leyen hier schildert, ist dann auch wirklich eine, die auf europäischem Boden stattfindet.
Ich finde ja solche Tendenzen auch gut. Insgesamt muss man diese Autos immer über die ganze Welt fahren, nur um hier so einen kleinen Gewinn noch mal abzuschöpfen.
Da muss man aber selbst darauf auch vorbereitet sein. Also das geht jetzt nicht, dass wir dahingucken und einfach nur sagen, America is back, wie von der Leyen das immer war. Ja klar, die sind zurück, aber die meinen es auch nicht nur gut mit uns.
Genau, ist eine Aufgabenstellung für uns. Sie kommt auf die Queen zu sprechen. Ist das Erbe der Queen nicht schlecht.
Und wenn ich an die Situation in der ich heute bin, herrliche Worte, die sich noch am Heitere der Pandemie noch mit mir aufregen, sie hat gesagt, wir werden es schaffen. Sie hat uns immer erinnert, dass unser Zukunft neue Ideen und alte Werte gegründet ist. Seit dem Ende der Weltkrieg II haben wir die Versprechen der Demokratie und der Wahl der法 zu versuchen. Heute ist das der Ziel der russischen Missile.
So, zurück zu aber diese Idee von ja, wir wohnen alle in so einem Haus, von dem wir dann irgendwann mal sagen können, wir können es auch mal zurückbauen, solange wir das Fundament stehen lassen. Und dann bauen wir darauf wieder was Neues. Das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, weil das ist die Herausforderung. Die Zäsuren sind ja alle da, die Wirklichkeit von Russland, was Energie angeht, demografische Wende und so. Jetzt könnte man sich ja wirklich auf die Fundamente, die einem wirklich wichtig sind, mal fokussieren, die auch thematisieren und alles andere, was nur so nicht tragende Deko-Wände und Fassade und so weiter alles mal zur Disposition stellen.
Von der Leyen war ja nicht Merkels Wahl. Das haben wir heute vergessen. Sondern Macrons Wahl. Und deswegen ist es auch kein Zufall, dass sie sagt, wir brauchen einen Souveränitätsfonds. Souveränität ist das Lieblingswort von Präsident Macron. Souveränität ist das, was er für Europa einfordert. Deswegen eigentlich auch eine Europaarmee und, und, und. Würde ja, wie wir wissen, viel Kosten sparen, wenn nicht jeder da sein eigenes Preußen aufbaut. Aber hier können wir noch mal deutlich sehen, denn erst mal mag es ja verwundern, wieso will denn jetzt Macron eine Deutsche? Da gibt es schon eine große Nähe. Also Macron und von der Leyen sind sich da sehr nah. Und deswegen auch diese Begrifflichkeit der Souveränität. Und wenn man mal ein bisschen darauf achtet, das ist ein Wort Souveränität, das auch sie relativ häufig im Munde führt. Und da ist diese Nähe da. Wie lange ist sie denn eigentlich jetzt noch Präsidentin?
Das geht bis 1921, 1921, 1923. Also stimmt, gute Frage. Eineinhalb Jahre oder so. Es ist gar nicht mehr so lang, wie gedacht.
Lustig wäre doch, wenn die CDU sie dann als Kanzlerkandidatin aufstellt. Klappt das noch gerade so? Ja, könnte klappen. Und dann könnte sie mit Macron sein.
Ja, mal gucken, was die Zeit so noch. Sie ist ja noch jung.
Denkbar wäre so was ja. Denkbar wäre so was natürlich.
Es wäre denkbar. Apropos jung.
Aber wir sind ja auch jetzt weil mit, also ich finde ja an sich jetzt so wie Scholz, wir sind uns da ja sehr einig, alles in ruhigen Gewässern lassen.
Genau, keine Aufregung, keine Turbulenzen im Nachverkehr bitte. Apropos jung. Es ist gerade das Jahr der Jugend. Sie hat das letztes Jahr ausgerufen, sie geht dem so ein bisschen nach. Sie freut sich junge Menschen getroffen zu haben.
Ich hatte eine unglaubliche Möglichkeit, 1500 junge Menschen von überall in Europa und überall im Welt zu beteiligen, die in Tissey getroffen sind.
Und überall im Weltall die, die in Tissey getroffen sind. Und diese Generation ist eine phänomenale Generation. Um ihre Reise auf die Welt erlauben.
Und wir sind ein Generation, die sich um ihre Reise und um ihre Reise auf die Welt erlauben. Und wir sind ein Generation, die sich um ihre Reise und um ihre Reise auf die Welt erlauben.
Und wir sind ein Generation, die sich um ihre Reise und um ihre Reise auf die Welt erlauben. Und wir sprechen jetzt hier tatsächlich über ein Vorhaben. Wir sprechen jetzt hier nicht, nur über, das wäre mal eine schöne Idee. Das ist die EU-Kommissionspräsidentin in ihrer State of the Union in ihrem Finale ihre Rede, was sie sich jetzt wünscht. Und wo sie sich an die Seite des EU-Parlaments stellt, die das schon seit einer Weile fordern. So. Und das ist, weiß nicht, eigentlich müssten sich jetzt die EU-Mitgliedsstaaten über die Ministerräte und dann die Staats- und Regierungschef dazu verhalten. Weil das Initiativrecht für alles liegt bei der EU-Kommission und sie hat hier die Initiative ergriffen. In einem sehr relevanten Punkt. Und das ist wirklich verrückt, dass wir so eine Rede bekommen und dann nicht eine Eilmeldung Ursula von der Leyen möchte EU-Verträge neu schreiben. Weil das ist ja das, wovor wir so große Angst haben. Weil dann, aber jetzt haben wir gerade so viele Populismus und so weiter, wie wirkt das dann da rein? Eigentlich haben wir bisher immer so, wir lassen es lieber, wie sie sind, weil wir wissen nicht genau, wohin das führt und so.
Das wird nochmal eine Debatte aufflammt.
Genau, und sie sagt jetzt einfach, wir machen jetzt EU-Konvent, hören uns die Jungen mit an und dann schreiben wir EU-Generation Verträge als die neuen Verträge. Also ich finde das wirklich Wahnsinn, dass das so auf der Bühne stattfindet und wir das überhaupt nirgendwo aufgegriffen sehen. Weil wo sonst sollte das jetzt formuliert werden? Aber es ist, wie es ist. Solche Reden finden irgendwie nirgendwo statt. Die mächtigste Frau Europas sagt die wichtigsten Sachen und niemand interessiert sich dafür. Kommen wir zu Olaf Scholz. Der, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das... Also das ist ja richtig Ursula von der Leyen, ist eine formale Rolle in einem formalen Termin, nämlich State of the Union und so weiter. Sie redet im Parlament von den Parlamentariern. Ein deutscher Bundeskanzler vor den Vereinten Nationen ist so, hm, ja, keine Ahnung, wie ist das zu verstehen?
Ich habe einige Artikel über die Vereinten Nationen gelesen, was da so los war. Aber da war vielleicht zwei Zeilen Olaf Scholz dabei. Aber mir schien auch, es war nicht so besonders relevant.
Würde ich auch sagen. Aber man wünscht sich doch eigentlich anderes. Man wünscht sich doch eigentlich, dass wir nach 16 Jahren Merkel, wo die UN komplett marginalisiert wurde, dass das eigentlich noch ernst genommen wird. Da wird der Hunger thematisiert, Krieg und Frieden usw. Aber fand alles nicht statt. Und Olaf Scholz Rede fand ich unsäglich und auch nicht gut. Er wollte sie verstecken, was für uns heißt. Jetzt schauen wir besonders hin. Es ist erst mal dieser große Appell, wir müssen jetzt mal die Regeln einhalten.
Globale Großkrisen türmen sich vor uns auf, verbinden und verstärken sich. Manche sehen darin die Vorboten einer Welt ohne Regeln. Zutreffend ist, die Risiken für unsere globale Ordnung sind real. Und dennoch kann ich wenig anfangen mit dem Bild von der regelosen Welt aus zwei Gründen. Erstens, unsere Welt hat klare Regeln, die wir als vereinte Nation gemeinsam geschaffen haben. Diese Charta verspricht uns allen ein friedliches Miteinander. Diese Charta ist unsere kollektive Absage an eine regelose Welt. Unser Problem sind nicht fehlende Regeln, unser Problem ist der mangelnde Wille, sie einzuhalten und durchzusetzen.
Ja, Regeln, Regeln, Regeln, Regeln, Regeln. Aber was meint er denn jetzt? Also dass die Logik der Bundesregierung für uns müssen 50 Sklaven irgendwo auf der Welt arbeiten, weil wir sind ja der reiche Westen weiterhin gelten soll und wir gerade ein bisschen verstört sind davon, dass das so aufgestört wurde, dieses Gefüge, oder?
Und der Hunger ist uns eigentlich auch egal.
Genau, was ist mit dem Hunger?
Schon bevor der Krieg begann, war uns der Hunger eigentlich egal.
Festung Europas, Migration und so.
Er verteidigt jetzt immer so diese Idee der globalen Ordnung und auch der Globalisierung. Er war ja auch bei der Industrie in diesem Monat unterwegs, bei verschiedenen Sachen, und hat dann immer gesagt, nein, es gibt natürlich keine Deglobalisierung, die soll es auch nicht geben, und die Globalisierung ist der Motor unseres Wachstums und Wohlstands. Und das ist in der Weise richtig, als man festhalten muss, das beruht auf diesen Ausbeutungsverhältnissen natürlich ganz stark. Ich halte auch viel für die Globalisierung im Sinne von einer Vernetzung, die dann durch diese gegenseitigen Abhängigkeiten auch Konflikte verhindert oder zumindest Kriege verhindern kann. Also für mich ist auch nicht das Ding Wandel durch Handel völlig ausgestorben jetzt nur, weil Putin durchgedreht ist. Aber ich würde deutlich machen, dass diese Regeln, die da so hochgehalten werden von denen, die sie am Ende setzen können und sich leisten können, sie zu brechen, doch sehr lax gehandhabt werden.
Das würde ich mal auch sagen. Und gerade dieses, wir hatten doch Regeln und so weiter. Ja, wenn die Regel irgendwie lautete, Hauptsache Globalisierung, der Rest ergibt sich von alleine, dann hast du uns ja gerade die Zahlen vorgetragen. Ja, die Globalisierung, der geht es gut. Es ist jetzt Chinas Globalisierung. Das gefällt uns nicht so richtig, aber die Regel, also Globalisierung, machen wir mal. Also an der rüttelt gerade keiner. Sondern Apple geht halt nach Indien, um da jetzt das neueste iPhone Modell herzustellen. Das ist immer noch nicht in Amerika. Und naja, Olaf Scholz, erster Aufschlag. Zweitens ein kleiner Satz zu Hunger und Krieg.
Nicht ein Sack Getreide wurde aufgrund dieser Sanktionen zurückgehalten. Russland allein hat die ukrainischen Getreideschiffe am Auslaufen gehindert, Häfen zerbombt und landwirtschaftliche Betriebe zerstört. Wer den Krieg ächten will, muss auch den Hunger ächten. Mein Amtsvorgänger, Friedensnobelpreisträger Willi Brandt hat diesen Satz gesagt, als er als erster Bundeskanzler im Jahr 1973 hier vor dieser Versammlung sprach. Heute erleben wir, dieser Satz gilt auch umgekehrt. Wer den Hunger ächten will, der muss Russlands Krieg ächten. Diesen Krieg, der auch in Ländern weit weg von Russland für steigende Preise, Energieknappheit und Hungersnot sorgt.
Was wir ja alles ausblenden. Wir kümmern uns ja wirklich nur um Europa gerade.
Und was heißt den Hunger ächten? Dann muss man ihn bekämpfen. Echten, das ist ja so wie zu sagen schön, dass ihr immer da kämpft. Also das ist ja überhaupt nichts gesagt. Und wie gesagt, wir haben es aufgedröselt, war es im April oder Mai mit dem Welthunger. Und ich hatte ja da die Ausschnitte vom November 2021, wo alles schon katastrophal aussah. Und da hat Putin noch nichts gemacht.
Vor allem, er ist ja in der UN und es wurde doch immer gesagt, gerade die UN-Flüchtlingshilfswerke stellen fest, sie brauchen jetzt doppelt so viel Geld, um die gleiche Menge an Nahrungsmitteln zur Verfügung zu stellen. Aber diese doppelte Menge Geld stellt ja niemand zur Verfügung. Also hier muss ja nichts gerechtet, sondern finanziert werden. Aber das wird so alles so ein bisschen weg versteckt. Plus, und das finde ich halt wirklich eine Katastrophe, dass man dann in diesem Zuge, wie eben bei Ursula von der Leyen gehört, natürlich dann auch abgestimmt mit dem Kanzleramt irgendwie, ja, wir wollen die Ukraine im europäischen Binnenmarkt. Weil dann haben wir wenigstens die schwarze Erde, die so fruchtbar ist und das ganze Getreide und so weiter perspektivisch so ein bisschen näher an uns dran. Also das ist doch alles hier sehr verlogen. Und besonders verlogen ist diese Anmerkung zum Klima.
Deshalb haben wir beim G7-Gipfel im Juni in Deutschland noch einmal bekräftigt, beim Klimaschutz voranzugehen, um das 1, 5-Grad-Ziel zu erreichen. Nicht trotz des Krieges und der Energiekrise, sondern gerade weil Klimaneutralität auch größere Energiesicherheit bedeutet. Wir stehen zu unseren Zusagen, Schwellen- und Entwicklungsländern bei der Emissionsminderung und ihrer Anpassung an den Klimawandel zu unterstützen. Zum Beispiel durch neue Partnerschaften für eine gerechte Energiewende. Und wir werden auch die Länder nicht allein lassen, die am stärksten mit Verlusten und Schäden durch den Klimawandel zu kämpfen haben. Bis zur Klimakonferenz in Ägypten wollen wir deshalb einen globalen Schutzschirm gegen Klimarisiken entwickeln.
Ja, der globale Schutzschirm. Also, Olaf Scholz kriegt es nicht mal hin, seiner FDP ein Tempolimit abzuverlangen im Sektor Verkehr, wo wir nun wirklich gar keine Ersparnisse vorzumeisen haben, was CO2 angeht und so. Und nicht mal das klappt, während wir gleichzeitig eher total einknicken. Also, die FDP sagt, wir sollten jede Energiequelle nutzen, auch Atomkraftwerke, machen wir. Da ist die Not groß. Aber bei der CO2-Ersparnis, und wir haben gar keine im Verkehrssektor, zumindest zu sagen, dann lass uns wenigstens langsam Auto fahren, okay, nee, ist nicht. Und dann da zu stehen und den anderen das abzuverlangen und dass man ihr aber auch gerne hilft in so einem Klimaklub und so weiter. Man steht gerne dabei und hält das Händchen. Das finde ich echt so.
Und dann ist doch logisch, dass diese ganzen, auf bevölkerungsreichen Länder, auf Wachstumsländer, Schwellenländer, sich sagen, ich lass mir doch nicht diese Moralpredigten hier halten. Da sind mir die Chinesen angenehmer. Die wollen halt ein Business machen mit uns. Und da können wir uns irgendwie auf Augenhöhe begegnen. Aber nicht noch, dass man sich moralisch hier zurechtweisen lassen muss. Von jenen, die sehr unmoralisch ihren Wohlstand erworben haben.
Genau, in der Hinsicht, das ist einfach, ich weiß auch nicht. Es ging dann beim Thema Menschenrechte, ja gut.
Hinsehen und handeln müssen wir aber auch dort, wo hunderttausend in Straflagern oder Gefängnissen Leid, Willkür und Folter erdulden müssen. Nordkorea, Syrien, dem Iran oder Belarus. Hinsehen und handeln müssen wir, wenn die Taliban Frauen und Mädchen in Afghanistan ihre grundlegendsten Rechte berauben. Und hinsehen und handeln müssen wir, wenn Russland in Mariupol, Butcher oder Irpin Kriegsverbrechen beginnt.
Ja, hinsehen und handeln bei Afghanistan ist natürlich dramatisch. Er hat jetzt hier von hunderttausenden Inhaftierten gesprochen. China dann nochmal ausgespart, da hab ich mir gedacht, der wird wahrscheinlich einen eigenen Blog machen.
Die frühere Hochkommissarin für Menschenrechte hat uns vor einigen Wochen über die Lage der Uiguren in Xinjiang berichtet. China sollte die Empfehlung der Hochkommissarin umsetzen. Das wäre ein Zeichen von Souveränität und Stärke. Und ein Garant für die Veränderung zum Besseren.
Ja, also dieses Drama um diese Hochkommissarin, die sozusagen fünf Minuten vor dem Ende ihrer Amtszeit noch diese E-Mail verschickte mit. Das ist übrigens mein Bericht, aber ab jetzt bin ich nicht mehr dafür zuständig.
Das war ja wirklich unklar, ob der überhaupt noch kommt, aber sie hat es dann auf diese Weise gemacht.
Sie hat es dann kurz vor Ladenschluss noch gemacht, was wirklich hieß, er ist jetzt in der Welt, aber es ist niemand ansprechbar dafür. Und dass er das nochmal so aufgreift als, ja, haben wir ja behandelt. So ist ja thematisiert worden. Die Umstände völlig ausgeblendet und dann nur so. Das wäre auch ein schönes Zeichen, wenn China das jetzt mal macht. Das ist wirklich die allerschwächste Form, die man da hätte wählen können. Das ist wirklich kurz vor verschweigen. Also das ist einfach nicht gut. Und naja, dieses Finale ist echt nicht gut.
Als diesjähriger Präsident der G7 ist es mir daher ein zentrales Anliegen, für eine neue Art der Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern des globalen Südens einzutreten. Eine Zusammenarbeit, die Augenhöhe nicht nur behauptet, sondern herstellt. Zwar diese Augenhöhe de facto ja längst besteht, wenn man das wachsende politische, ökonomische und demografische Gewicht Asiens, Afrikas und des südlichen Amerikas beachtet. Von Beginn an haben wir unsere Ziele auf das Engste mit Indonesien als G20-Präsidentschaft abgestimmt. Die Vorsitzländer der Afrikanischen Union und der Gemeinschaft lateinamerikanischer und karibischer Staaten haben wir unseren Beratungen als G7 beteiligt, ebenso wie Indien und Südafrika.
Der globale Süden ist uns gerade sowas voll egal. Und hier anzumerken, dass man ja an die Philippinen eine gute Amtsübergabe der G20-Präsidentschaft gemacht hat und bei den anderen beratend dabei saß, als sie tagten, ist nun wirklich, das ist so Mindestmaß von irgendwas.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie im Verein, wo man nochmal so sagt, ja, es sind die Trikots alle gewaschen worden und wieder gebügelt worden und die sind jetzt wieder verfügbar. Und außerdem haben wir auch die Abrechnung vom letzten Sommerfest fast fertig.
Ja, und kann nochmal jemand sich zum Beisitzer wählen lassen. Keine Sorge, kommt auch keine Arbeit drauf zu. Wir brauchen nur, es steht in dem Gesetz, wir brauchen einen Beisitzer. Also das ist wirklich schlimm, was wir hier geliefert bekommen oder die Welt von uns Deutschen geliefert bekommt. Hier nochmal dieses kleine Finale. Das ist auch echt fast Wortwitz, den er jetzt bringt, den man auf so einer Comedybühne bringen kann.
Durch einen neu entstehenden Klimaclub gehen wir mit Freunden und Partnern weltweit voran, um das Pariser Klimaabkommen noch schneller und besser umzusetzen. Solche Ansätze sind Pfeiler, die unsere internationale Ordnung stützen. Weil sie Ergebnisse liefern, die den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in all unseren Ländern zugutekommen und die sie von den Vereinten Nationen erwarten. We the peoples, wir die Völker, lautet nicht umsonst die ersten drei Worte unserer Charta.
Paris, noch schneller und besser umsetzen. Ja, das war's. Das ist die Porte, glaube ich, die er bringen wollte da von den Vereinten Nationen. Es ist We the peoples.
Wir sind gespannt. Nein, wir sind nicht gespannt.
Es ist ein großes Drama.
Wir schauen uns das an und schütteln den Kopf und springen zu Aserbaidschan und machen eigentlich ein bisschen weiter in diesem Modus in Aserbaidschan. In der Nacht zum 13. September haben aserbaidschanische Truppen Armenien angegriffen. Es gab 2020 schon den Angriff Aserbaidschans auf Bergkarabach. Und nun aber geht es um Armenien selbst. 200 Menschen etwa wurden jetzt bislang getötet. Knapp 8000 Menschen sollen sich auf der Flucht befinden. Wir hören jetzt erstmal einen Part aus der Bundespressekonferenz. Thilo fragt mal da bei der Bundesregierung nach. Das riecht ja irgendwie fast so nach einem Angriffskrieg, möchte man meinen. Was sagen die denn dazu? Denn das ist ja, wie wir auch wissen, energetisch unser neuer wichtiger Partner. Es gab ja da schöne Bilder mit Ursula von der Leyen und dem Chef des ganzen ADEF.
Ja, nochmal zurück zu Armenien, Herr Wagner. Weil ich es nicht ganz verstanden habe, kann die Bundesregierung einen Aggressor zwischen Aserbaidschan und Armenien erkennen?
Also die Angaben von beiden Seiten lassen sich halt mangelnd unabhängige Objekte vor Ort nicht unabhängig bestätigen und überprüfen. Insofern kann ich dazu auch nicht Weiterstellung nehmen.
Unabhängig, die Berichterstattung sagt ja, dass die aserbaidschanische Seite angegriffen hat am Dienstag. Als die Russen in die Ukraine angegriffen haben, haben sie nicht beide Seiten aufgefordert, die Waffen ruhen zu lassen. Warum tun sie das jetzt hier?
Also ich kann nur nochmal auf das verweisen, was ich eben gesagt habe, mangelnd unabhängiger Berichterstattung, als ein Beobachter vor Ort, kann man das nicht unabhängig überprüfen. Und ich glaube, es steht uns auch nicht gut, diesen Konflikt zu vergleichen mit dem, was da in der Ukraine passiert ist.
Aber genau das wollen wir natürlich in gewisser Weise jetzt tun. Wir werden jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit vergleichen, aber wir wollen mal schauen, was ist da los. Und hören zum Beispiel in der Deutschen Welle Sylvia Stöver, die das auch gefragt wird, die aber Journalistin ist und jetzt folgendermaßen antwortet.
Ich verstehe sie richtig, dass in diesem Fall die Angriffe belastbar einzuschätzen von Aserbaidschan ausgingen sind?
Wenn man sich das Ergebnis anschaut, auch in diesem Fall bei dieser Eskalation in der Nacht, dann sieht man ja, dass Ortschaften innerhalb von Armenien getroffen wurden. Von dort gibt es Bilder, wo Splitter runtergegangen sind, wo Gebäude zerstört worden sind. Aserbaidschan selbst hat gesagt, dass militärische Infrastruktur Armeniens zerstört worden sei, dass man strategisch wichtige Höhen eingenommen habe. Das weist eben deutlich darauf hin, dass es Ausgriffe, Angriffe von Seiten Aserbaidschans auf Armenien gegeben hat.
Genau, man hört dann immer die Journalisten, die natürlich ein bisschen freier als eine Regierungsriege, also die Sprecherschaft, da antworten kann. Aber sie hat ja doch ein paar Punkte aufgezählt, was man so sieht. Und dass das Mantra der Bundesregierung da ist, nichts wissen, nichts wissen. Ich kann mich immer noch erinnern an diese Szene mit Steffen Seiver, der dann einfach vorne sitzt. Seine Kollegen aus den anderen Stellen kriegen Fragen und er flüstert rüber ins Mikrofon.
Nichts wissen, nichts wissen.
Und so ist das dann hier auch wieder gewesen. Also wir wissen gar nichts. Keine Ahnung. Wir haben auch kein Radio, um hier mal die deutschen Journalisten zu hören.
Ja, sofort noch gar nicht in die Zeitung geguckt. Nun hören wir ganz kurz die stellvertretenden Außenminister Gevorgian und Mamadov von Armenien.
Azerbaijan hat nicht nur die Sitzfeuer über die Bordkarte, sondern auch die armenischen Positionen und auch die zivilen Infrastruktur in Armenien zerstört.
Wer ist aber überhaupt diese Regierung da in Aserbaidschan? Wir hören da einen Beitrag aus Deutschland von Kultur Weltzeit. Birgit Wetzel klärt uns auf.
Wir gehen jetzt mal gedanklich weiter zum Präsidentenpalast. Da wohnt oder sitzt drin Ilham Aliyev. Der ist seit 2003 im Amt und wofür steht er?
Ja, Aliyev ist die zentrale Figur in Aserbaidschan. Muss man wirklich sagen, er hat einen Personenkult um sich und seine Familie aufgebaut. Und er ist der Sohn von Haider Aliyev. Haider Aliyev ist derjenige, der diesen Jahrhundertvertrag geschlossen hat. Und man ist ihm bis heute ohne Ende dankbar dafür, dass dieser Vertrag zustande gekommen ist. Denn durch diesen Vertrag, durch die Petrodollars, die dann ins Land gekommen sind, konnte sich das ganze Land entwickeln. Und nicht nur Baku, sondern auch darüber hinaus sind Straßen gebaut worden, sind Autobahnen gebaut worden. Es sind viele neue Schulen entstanden. Durch diese Petrodollars hat sich das Land ganz gewaltig verändert.
Die Petrodollars haben das Land reich gemacht. Und vor allem die Familie Aliyev und die dazugehörigen Clans haben sich daran sehr bereichert.
Ich will noch mal zu sprechen kommen auf den Vater. Und zwar Haider Aliyev. Der war vor ihm Präsident, bis er gestorben ist. Und der war auch vorher im höchsten Gremium der Sowjetunion, dem Politbüro der kommunistischen Partei. Ist das jetzt eine Familien-Dynastie, die wir dort eben haben, seit der Unabhängigkeit von Aserbaidschan Anfang der 90er Jahre? Wie ist seine Rolle einzuschätzen?
Natürlich, diese Familie dominiert das politische Geschehen in der Region. Es ist aber auch überhaupt so, dass die Herrschaftsverhältnisse sehr andere sind als in Europa. Es gibt eben doch sehr starke Clan-Strukturen. Und es gibt auch Ordigarchen, die halt sehr viel das politische Geschehen bestimmen. Für schon einiges Stirnrunzeln hat insbesondere gesorgt, dass Ilham Aliyev auch seine Frau als Vizepräsidentin ernannt hat und auch für seinen Sohn schon Ambitionen hat, dass der die Amtsgeschäfte weiterführen wird.
Ja, das ist also so eine klassische Racket-Struktur, wie wir die aus vielen Ländern kennen. Die Ehefrau als Vizepräsidentin. Das geht dann noch mal weiter als in anderen Staaten. Da sind es dann immer noch so die Schwiegersöhne oder so. Die man noch installiert. Aber hier macht man es ganz eng. Und ja, das ist ein Land, das natürlich mit einer Demokratie nichts zu tun hat. Während Armenien eine Demokratie ist. Auch das muss hier deutlich gemacht werden. Und nun ist es so, dass der Westen eine Verbindung zu Aserbaidschan hat, was sich zum einen durch diese CDU-Connection zeigt. Ich habe da jetzt nichts zu mitgebracht, aber da haben ja viele investigative, gute journalistische Teams gearbeitet zu. Und das ist sehr erhellend, was da herausgefunden wurde. Und es ist natürlich so, dass diese Ölfirmen, die Westlichen, auch eine große Verbindung zu dieser Familie und diesem Land aufrechterhalten.
Es ist klar, dass eine gute Verbindung nach Großbritannien besteht. Die BP ist entscheidend die Firma, die am meisten Anteile hat an den Firmen, die jetzt engagiert sind in Aserbaidschan mit dabei. Ist auch die norwegische Statoil, da ist auch die italienische Eni mit dabei. Es ist auch eine russische Firma mit dabei. Aber die BP ist die entscheidende Firma, eigentlich was die Westkontakte angeht.
Die Pressemitteilung der Europäischen Kommission zu diesem Gasdeal, den man mit Aserbaidschan hatte, die lautet ja, die Vereinbarung enthält die Verpflichtung, die Kapazität des südlichen Gaskorridors zu verdoppeln, um der EU bis 2027 jährlich mindestens 20 Milliarden Kubikmeter zu liefern. Das wird zu den Diversifizierungszielen des Re-Power EU-Plans beitragen. Und Europa dabei helfen, die Abhängigkeit vom russischen Gas zu beenden. Und diese angedachten 20 Milliarden Kubikmeter, die würden dann nur 12 Prozent allerdings des gesamteuropäischen Gas-Imports 21 decken. Also in diesem Verhältnis sind wir da. Aber immerhin 12 Prozent ist dann schon mal was, wenn man sagt jetzt war 40 Prozent, glaube ich, von Russland. Und man hat das stark drosseln können insgesamt.
Ja, mittlerweile glaubt man ja, jeder einzelne Prozentpunkt senkt so ein bisschen das Stresslevel. Man sollte froh sein. Und wenn man dann zweistellige Prozentwerke hört, die schon mal gesichert sind, ist großes Aufatmen angesagt bei vielen, die das da regeln müssen.
Und entsprechend versucht man, sich da bedeckt zu halten, zum Beispiel von der Bundesregierung aus und will jetzt da nicht über diesen Angriffskrieg sprechen. Caroline Morn hat da so eine schöne Formulierung auch in dem Weltzeitpodcast zu den neun Autokraten, mit denen wir jetzt paktieren.
Spielen denn sowas wie Menschenrecht und Demokratie dabei jetzt eine Rolle, wenn man auf Länder zugeht?
Keine große im Moment. Also wir hatten ja zum Beispiel auch den US-Präsidenten Biden in Saudi-Arabien. Ich habe Habeck in Katar schon erwähnt. Also es gibt zwar die Kritik, dass man jetzt einfach einen autokratischen Herrscher durch einen anderen ersetzt. Man will jetzt aber darauf achten, dass man nicht zu stark auf nur ein autokratisches System vertraut.
Das ist so verrückt. Wir gehen ja nur auf die Länder zu, weil das für uns an und für alle eine große Rolle spielt. Und dann spielt es aber keine große Rolle. Eigentlich kriegt man es nicht so richtig erklärt.
Wir hören jetzt in der deutschen Welle Joshua Kucera, der über diese Eskalation Folgendes sagt, also über die, die jetzt da stattfindet zwischen Aserbaidschan und Armenien.
Die Werte dieser Runde sind, dass die Aserbaidschaner dieses Mal in Armenien sind. Vorhin wurde die Kampfzeit meist in und um Nagorno-Karabakh konzentriert, die international als Aserbaidschaner verwendet wurde.
Diese Versuchungen sind in den armenischen Gemeinden, an der Bordereinheit in Armenien, die eine bedeutende Ausgleichung in Aserbaidschaner ziel.
Die sind jetzt da auf armenischem Boden, das heißt, wir können jetzt nicht mehr sagen, da ist mal irgendwas rübergeflogen oder bei Bergkarabach, das war auch schon ein zu verurteilender Angriff, aber da kann man sagen, ja, das rechnen die sich ja noch zu, aber hier ist es ganz klar eine Grenzverletzung, also auch ganz klar das, was jetzt Olaf Scholz immer sagt, das geht nicht, also das ist meine rote Linie, aber diese rote Linie existiert da nicht. Es gab auch einen interessanten Artikel von Anna Aritzanian, die für T-Online schrieb, doch nicht nur die Regierungskoalition aus SPD, Grün und FDP ist hier zu kritisieren, aserbaidschanische Lobbyisten haben über Jahre hinweg Einfluss auf die Bundesfraktion der Union genommen, die sogenannte Aserbaidschan-Connection war die Grundlage für regimefreundliche Aussagen von Unionspolitikern und Lobbyarbeit für den Autokraten Aliyev, also der ist uns jetzt lieb und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie muss Russland oder wie will Russland darauf reagieren? Es ist ganz interessant, Armenien ist ja eigentlich mit Russland da in so einer Verbindung, dass Russland sich in der Regel für die armenische Seite stark macht, aber immer deeskalierend in diese Konflikte eingreift, aber jetzt ja selbst einen Konflikt angezettelt hat und damit ja auch Allahand zu tun hat, wie wir wissen. Und jetzt sind die da sehr zurückhaltend. Das kann man zum Beispiel daran erleben, dass Armeniens Präsident sich bei Putin natürlich sofort nach dem Angriff meldet. Also es ist dann quasi die erste Adresse, die man anruft. Aber direkt danach telefonierte er schon mit Macron und ich glaube auch mit Michel von der EU. Ne, mit Blinken hat er dann telefoniert. Also Armenien merkt jetzt, Russland hat gar keine Zeit, keine Lust, sich noch vielleicht einen weiteren Konflikt drauf zu schaffen. Zumal ja Aserbaidschan und Türkei und wiederum Türkei und Putin dann nochmal, also es ist sehr, sehr vertrackt. Dadurch, dass, und jetzt hat also Armenien, Macron und Blinken auch mal noch kontaktiert. Interessanterweise dann nicht Scholz, zumindest habe ich das dann nicht erfahren. Und hier ist also ein Land, das eigentlich Hilfe schreit, von dem, die eigentlich da sind, da ein bisschen Regeln einzugreifen, nichts erwartet, sich jetzt eigentlich nach Westen wendet. Und man den jetzt aber zu verstehen gibt, wisst ihr, wir bekommen ja diese 12% bald so an Gas.
Ja, es ist wirklich dieses Paradox, dass wir, weil wir diese ganzen Menschenrechtssachen so wichtig nehmen. Vielleicht ist es wirklich, aber auch da, es ist ein Krieg, weshalb wir uns von Russland abwenden. Und gleichzeitig diese Hinwendung, ob es am Ende wirklich nur die Aufmerksamkeit ist, medial.
Genau, wo liegt eigentlich Aserbaidschan, könnte man fragen. Also genau, das sind diese Fragen, die sich dann da stellen. Also wir haben auch einen Dominoeffekt. Also du hast es ja ebenso schön beschrieben. Putin hätte das wohl nicht gemacht, wenn Merkel jetzt noch an der Regierung wäre. Also er hat gewartet, bis Trump weg ist, bis Merkel weg ist. Jetzt hat er dann in seinen Augen Schwächere mit Scholz und Biden. Und was macht jetzt Aliyev? Naja, der hat auch abgewartet, bis Russland sich jetzt um diesen Konflikt, weil die waren damals bei Bergkarabacht dann doch schnell dabei und haben gesagt, also hallo, hier müssen wir mal einschreiten. Und die haben natürlich jetzt auch auf das Momentum gewartet. So schätzt es zumindest Gesine Dornblüt ein in dem besagten Weltzeitpodcast.
Also dass das Mutterland getroffen wurde, also armenisches Land innerhalb seiner international anerkannten Grenzen, das ist ganz ganz wesentlich, ein wesentlicher Punkt. Und zwar deshalb, weil Armenien Mitglied ist in einem östlichen Militärbündnis, das heißt OVKS oder auch ODKB abgekürzt, russisch. Das ist die Organisation des Vertrags über kollektive Sicherheit. Da sind sechs Staaten drin. Das Ganze wird von Russland dominiert und es gibt dort eine Beistandsklausel. Deswegen hat sich Armenien bereits an diese OVKS gewandt, nicht zum ersten Mal. Aber die Organisation, die hat jetzt zwar getagt, hat aber keine Eingreiftruppe entsandt, sondern erst mal eine Mission, die sich ein Bild machen soll von der Lage und die feststellen soll, ob da überhaupt armenisches Gebiet angegriffen wurde. Man beruft sich darauf, dass die Grenze nicht markiert sei. Und das Ganze lässt schon darauf schließen, dass die Organisation eben nicht gerade sehr scharf darauf ist, da wirklich aktiv zu werden. Und das liegt unter anderem daran, dass die anderen Mitgliedsstaaten, so wie zum Beispiel Kasachstan, engere Verbindungen unterhalten zu Aserbaidschan als zu Armenien. Und deswegen kann es sein, Aserbaidschan möchte testen, wie weit Russland geht, aber wie weit auch die anderen OVKS-Mitgliedsstaaten gehen.
Hm, das ist ja interessant, dass es da so Bündnisse noch gibt. Weil du hast ja eben kurz angemerkt, Putin hat gewartet, bis Trump weg ist. Da könnte man ja auch, es gibt ja auch diesen Gegenentwurf, dass Trump eigentlich bleiben sollte für Putin, um dann in der zweiten Amtszeit Amerika aus der NATO zu nehmen. Und dann reift da in der Ukraine lauter solche Sachen. Dass hier noch so ein zweites Bündnis eine Rolle spielt, für das Putin jetzt gerade keine Zeit hat, ist natürlich interessant. Also dass da über Historie so eine formale Verpflichtung eigentlich gäbe.
Ja, und ich meine, für die Familie Aliyev ist das eine enorme Bereicherung. Jetzt auch im ganz persönlichen Sinn. Und das ist nicht nur, wir haben unsere Wirtschaft gestärkt, sondern wir haben uns reich gemacht. Die war natürlich auch gut dabei bei den Panama Papers. Die haben drei Kinder und diese sind als Shareholder in 44 Firmen registriert auf den British Virgin Islands. Und es gibt ja auch so einen Korruptionsindex und da steht Aserbaidschan auf Platz 128. Da ist man also dann so in einer Nähe mit Myanmar. Das ist ganz beachtlich. Wir hören jetzt Jason Palmer vom The Economist Podcast zu Aserbaidschan und dem Friedensabkommen.
So you have to bear in mind that what ended the war in 2020 was not a peace agreement, but a ceasefire imposed by Russia. And talks about a possible peace settlement between Azerbaijan and Armenia have been ongoing. I think the latest round took place in Brussels. These talks are being mediated by the EU in late August. And in fact in early September, the Azerbaijani President Ilham Aliyev mentioned that the two sides were probably months away from a peace agreement. But, and this is a very big but, Azerbaijan wants Armenia under such a peace agreement to acknowledge its unconditional sovereignty over Nagorno-Karabakh. Armenia is not so keen for that to happen. And Armenia also demands guarantees for the region's ethnic Armenians.
Also dieser Berg-Karabakh-Konflikt liegt da auch immer noch drunter natürlich. Das ist ja nicht gelöst, sondern das ist nun mal so eingestellt. Und das ist eigentlich so ein Befriedungsvertrag, nicht ein wirklicher Friedensvertrag, der da stattgefunden hat. Maria Tizian in der Deutschen Welle sagt jetzt, warum dieser Konflikt so brisant ist.
Is this a conflict that we need to pay more attention to?
Absolutely, because this is not only between Armenia and Azerbaijan.
So, ein neuer Konflikt zeichnet sich da möglicherweise ab vor den Türen Europas, weshalb das sehr ernst zu nehmen ist. Wir hören jetzt noch mal eine Einschätzung von Samuel Doveri-Vesterbay bei Al-Jazeera.
Und wenn man nach Süden der Aserbaidschan und der Armenier schaut, findet man Iran, ein Land, das auch Verschränkungen hat. Die Aserbaidschan und die Armenier, ein Widerstand werden. Und natürlich auch die Inzidenzen für die Aserbaidschan und die Armenier, um sich für einander zu beherrschen.
Intrikate Verhältnisse und noch eine weitere Einschätzung vom Direktor des armenischen Nationalen Komitees in Amerika. Noch mal ganz deutlich macht, um was es hier jetzt eigentlich geht für die Armenier.
Das ist grundsätzlich die Waffe für die Überlebung der armenischen Menschen. Das ist eine existentielle Waffe für die armenischen Menschen. Für eine Nation, für Menschen, die Genesid erlebt haben, die noch immer von der Legasie des Genesids verhaut sind, heute in der Aggression, die sie an die Hände der Aserbaidschanen und von der Türkei erlebt haben, ist das die Waffe für die Leben der armenischen Nation. Wenn die internationale Community einen autoritarischen Diktator in Ilham Aliyev mit Impunität ein demokratisches Land wie Armenien stehen und erlauben würde, würde die Welt die Reverbierungen der Nation über den Weltall beachten. Und jetzt muss die internationale Community verstehen, dass es keinen Weg gibt, einen autoritarischen, expansionistischen Regime wie Russland zu entgegen, indem man einen anderen, autoritarischen, expansionistischen Regime wie Aserbaidschan ermöglichen kann.
Wir stehen hier vor der Konstellation, die beiden ja in seinen Reden ständig wiederholt, Autokratie gegen Demokratie. Die Demokratie wird vertreten durch Armenien. Die kämpfen hier für die Demokratie. Man könnte jetzt auch wieder sagen, die kämpfen dort auch für uns. Die kämpfen für ihre Unabhängigkeit. Und wir ziehen uns daraus, sagen wir haben noch nichts genaues gesehen. Wir wissen nichts. Die EU äußerst vorsichtig. Und einen Tag später hält dann Ursula von der Leyen eine Rede im EU-Parlament. Und ich habe jetzt mal drei Clips mitgebracht, die nichts mit Armenien, Aserbaidschan zu tun haben. Denn es geht natürlich um den anderen Krieg und wir sollten das aber jetzt einfach mal übertragen.
Das ist natürlich dieses, ja, Aserbaidschan sind ja nur zwei Millionen Leute, was kann schon passieren, es sind ja nur wenige. Da ist ja keine Schlagkraft dahinter wie bei Russland. Also nimmt man es einfach so hin.
Genau, Aserbaidschan ist natürlich jetzt nicht in einem großen Bündnis drin, das uns gefährlich werden kann, beziehungsweise die sind da so lose verbunden, aber wir können die jetzt an uns ja binden und das ist dann das Entscheidende. Wir haben es nicht mit einer Bedrohung zu tun für die NATO. Ganz im Gegenteil, man kann sich da Aserbaidschan gefügig machen mit entsprechenden Zahlungen und diese Familie Aliyev weiter unterstützen.
Ich will es sehr klar machen. Das muss sehr klar werden.
Wenn man das aber so rigoros ausdrückt gegenüber Russland, dann bedeutet das natürlich und da wir aber weiter Energie brauchen und da wir weiter wirtschaften werden, können wir nicht einfach das jetzt irgendwie mit Frankreich lösen, sondern wir brauchen ja dann andere dafür. Und damit begeben wir uns natürlich je härter man das vorträgt, desto mehr geht man auch in die Hände dann der Familie Aliyev und Konsorten. Und dies noch zum Schluss.
Wir sollten die Stimmen in unserer Union hören, in Polen, in den Baltiken und überall im Zentrum und im Osten Europas.
So, und jetzt müssen wir bitte das so beherzigen und sagen, lass uns doch dann nicht noch wieder einmal mehr den Fehler machen, sonst können wir in drei, vier, fünf Jahren da sitzen und auch Namen aus Armenien aufzählen, auf die wir hätten hören sollen.
Ich korrigiere nochmal, Aserbaidschan hat 10 Millionen Einwohner, zwei Millionen leben in Baku und das kennen wir ja, Europäischen Song Contest und so.
Genau, da war schon die Baku Connection da.
Wir können ja eigentlich sagen, das ist ein uns nicht ganz unbekanntes Land.
Ja, und wir haben natürlich die Autokraten nicht nur dort in noch relativ weiter Ferne, sondern wir haben sie jetzt auch sehr nah an uns herangerückt mit Italien.
Italien und Schweden, diese schwedische Wahl war natürlich... Georg Dietz hat einen Text geschrieben über den Boomer-Faschismus. In Italien und Schweden zeigt sich das destruktive Verhältnis von Kapitalismus und Demokratie seit der Finanzkrise. Wichtiger Punkt, es gewinnt, wer von ökonomischer Ungleichheit ablenkt. Das gilt insbesondere für Italien, wo Jugendarbeitslosigkeit immer noch bei 30 Prozent liegt und krasse Verarmung mittlerweile Raum greift. Das ist allerdings Überschrift und Vorspann, was ich gerade vorgelesen habe, ein Text, der exklusiv nur für Abonnenten ist. Und wie gesagt, ich bin zwar Abonnent, aber kein Digitaler. Genau, was er jetzt hier schrieb, aber bei den Schweden, das ist ganz interessant, weil wir jetzt immer so der Rechtsruck und so. Bei Schweden kann man nochmal kurz in die Zahlen gehen. Diese Schwedendemokraten gibt es seit 1988. Und seit 2010 sitzen sie im Reichstag. Und ihr Standardprogramm ist dieses rechte Migrations- und familienpolitische, was man so kennt. Allerdings haben sie sich auf den Klimaschutz verpflichtet. Also Paris, halten sie hoch, irgendwie so eine neue Wendung. Wahrscheinlich braucht man nur eine Bevölkerung, die es einfordert. Und dann ist man da auch selbst da populistisch mit am Werke. Als sie 2014 zur Europawahl antreten, forderten sie auch einen Austritt aus der Europäischen Union. Und nun haben sie, wie wir hörten, so ein bisschen mitgewonnen. Aber sie fuhren jetzt mit 20, 5% im Ergebnis ein. Das bedeutet nur plus 3%. Also sie haben so ein Niveau, so ein bisschen ausgebaut, das sie schon hatten. Und sind jetzt mit 73 von 349 sitzen die zweitstärkste Fraktion insgesamt. Muss man aber zu dieser Wahl sagen. Die Regierung, also der Regierungsblock, 48, 87% hat 0, 41% verloren. Die Opposition hat auf 49, 59, genau diese 0, 41% gewonnen. Und damit hat die Regierung gewechselt. Magdalena Andersen trat also zurück, weil sie die Mehrheit verlor, obwohl ihre Sozialdemokraten als Wahlgewinner 2, 07% noch mal zulegen konnten auf über 30%. Also es ist nicht dieser mega harte Rechtsdruck, sondern die Schweden haben genau gesehen, es war halt vorher schon auf der Kippe mit 49, 51. Und jetzt ist es halt wieder auf der Kippe, aber es hat sich einmal gewendet. Und da finde ich doch, ist es von den Zahlen her eine erhebliche Stabilität, weil durch was sind die durchgegangen im Vergleich zur letzten Wahl? Die hatten diesen Corona-Sonderweg und den Russlandüberfall auf die Ukraine, also NATO-Beitritt und so. Also die konnten sich mal richtig über sich verständigen und sind dann auch sehenden Auges in das eine oder andere Katastrophental da gemeinsam durchgelaufen und irgendwie relativ stabil. Und das ist eben ganz anders in Italien. In Italien gibt es sechs Parteien über fünf Prozent, obwohl dort ist es eine Vier-Prozent-Klausel, aber für uns das deutsche Gefühl, ja, sechs Parteien. Und es ist ein Hin und Her, es ist unglaublich. Diese Fratelli d'Italia, also die Brüder Italiens, gewannen nun mit 26 Prozent plus 21, 6 im Vergleich zur letzten Wahl. Das ist also für so eine wirklich rechtsaußen Partei ein erheblicher und auch für die Italiener ein ganz neues Ding. Also da wachen auch viele auf, gerade so, da müssen wir erst mal gucken, was jetzt ist. Die haben sich auch selber so ein bisschen verunsichert damit.
Sie, Meloni, in der faschistischen Jugend tätig, also da ist jetzt nicht mehr, dass man sagen kann, wie das jetzt so mitunter zu lesen war bis hin zur FAZ, das ist so bürgerlich dann am Ende doch oder was? Oder sie will ja das Land verbinden. Natürlich sagen die immer, dass sie das Land verbinden wollen und dass sie das einen wollen, aber das ist jetzt hier nicht mehr zu sagen.
Genau, sie versucht selber gerade den Schreck einzufangen, indem sie sich ein bisschen moderat äußert. Und wir wissen aber, da steckt mehr dahinter. Ihr an die Seite. Jetzt Salvini mit der Lega, 9 Prozent, Berlusconi, Forza Italia, 8 Prozent. Das Bündnis kommt also auf 44 Prozent, hat eigentlich keine Mehrheit. Aber ob siegte doch, weil es dieses interessante Grabenwahlrecht gibt. Ein Drittel der Parlamentssitze ergeben sich aus relativen Mehrheitsverhältnissen, zwei Drittel über die Wahlkreise. Und da weiß man dann Winner takes all. Daher kommt es dann darauf an, das Bündnis so zu schmieden, dass man in der Fläche dann einfach da siegt. Ein Sieger pro Wahlkreis, deswegen diese hohe Relevanz dieser Bündnisse und deswegen auch die Möglichkeit, über einen geringeren Popular Vote dann trotzdem diese Regierungsparlamentsmehrheit zu erringen. Und genau, Meloni ist kein unbeschriebenes Blatt, sondern sie trat ja 2012 schon mal im Streit aus der Regierung aus. Gründete daraufhin, also mit Berlusconi, gründete daraufhin diese Fratelli d'Italia, die wieder in Erbe und Tradition von diesen rechten Parteien gestellt wurde, ging 2013 schon wieder ein Bündnis mit Berlusconi ein und hat halt heute diese eigenartige Partei, deren Parteilogo eine Flamme über einen schwarzen Strich zeigt. Und dieser schwarze Strich ist Mussolini Sarg. Also das ist auch auf so vielen Ebenen so bescheuert. Auf der anderen Seite hört man jetzt immer wieder, die Italiener haben das Erbe so ein bisschen anders verarbeitet. Ja, also hier muss man nur Hitler sagen und alle so. Und das ist dort anders. Also mit Mussolini kann man noch so ein bisschen punken. Und auf der anderen Seite, ja, die haben jetzt diese krasse europäische Abhängigkeit. Die müssen jetzt also wirklich gucken, wie sie sich nicht komplett verspielen mit Europa, weil das ihre Einkommensquelle ist. Ja, es wird jetzt gerade auch, wenn man jetzt immer so hört, die Italiener, die wählen nicht wie wir Deutsche einfach für vier Jahre eine Regierung und liefern sich ja aus, sondern die vergeben halt so ein bisschen Amtsmacht und sagen sich dann, na gut, gucken wir mal, wie es läuft, wenn nicht verjagen wir sie vom Hof. Entsprechend auch diese elf Monate Durchschnittsregierungszeit über alle Regierungen seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, also seit der Nachtkriegszeit. Also mal schauen, wie weit Meloni es da treiben kann, dass sie eine Frau ist. Hat ja noch mal eine Rolle gespielt, nachdem Hillary Clinton sich äußerte mit, ich kenne sie nicht, aber das ist eine Frau, das zeigt, das ist ein Schritt nach vorn. Während Florian Schröder noch mal anmerkte, ja, das ist die Vollendung der Emanzipation. Wenn wir in allen auch Bösewichtrollen, jetzt Frauen als Normalfall und akzeptabel, da plötzlich aufspielen sehen.
Die aber nicht in feministische Ordnung einführen wird. Das ist ja immer die Sache.
Also die Partei hat Brüder, Italien ist.
Genau, das Patriarchat bleibt erhalten, wird nur von einer Frau geleitet.
Ja, genau, kennen wir ja so ein bisschen Thatcher und so. Die haben sich da auch nichts geschenkt. Oder Merkel hat den Frauen auch nicht viel geschenkt. Na ja, ist jedenfalls eine interessante Koalitionskonstellation, bei der es jetzt sehr drauf ankommt, wie die Italiener das selber erst mal finden.
Sollen wir uns mal eine Rede anhören? Ich habe einen Clip mitgebracht und zwar habe ich das als Video mitgebracht für uns, damit wir, wir hören nämlich jetzt einfach nur, sie Italienisch sprechen. Das ist ja ein bisschen das Problem, dass wir nicht alle Sprachen können und deswegen uns auch immer stark aufs Englische und natürlich aufs Deutsche konzentrieren. Wir lesen also jetzt den Untertitel mit und übersetzen den dann so ein bisschen für alle. Also zwei Minuten 14 dauert dieser Clip.
Okay, let's go.
Was sie hier fragt ist, warum wird die Familie als Feind angesehen? Warum fürchten sich alle vor der Familie? Also das ist jetzt ihre Behauptung. Da gibt es auf solche Fragen nur eine einzige Antwort. Denn, also wir müssen übersetzen, das ist jetzt immer noch was im Englischen, deswegen wer weiß was am Ende rauskommt, was sie eigentlich gesagt hat, aber weil die Familie uns definiert, uns in unserer Identität. Denn das wird als Gefahr angesehen, dass jeder, der noch eine Identität hat, als gefährlich angesehen wird, wenn das sind Leute, die wollen, dass wir nicht länger eine Identität haben, die wollen uns unsere Identität rauben.
Also wir haben in Italien das Problem, Jugendarbeitslosigkeit 30 Prozent und das Auszugsalter aus dem Elternhaus liegt bei irgendwo 30 Jahren. Also katastrophale Werte, allerdings ökonomisch erzwungen und nicht aufgrund irgendwie, wir lieben die Familie so sehr und jetzt findet so ein Krieg gegen die Familie statt, also eben nicht auf der Ebene. Es ist ein bisschen wie Georg Dietz andeutete in seinem Text, den wir jetzt nicht kennen, dass die in großem Bogen um die ökonomischen Argumente machen und stattdessen glauben, die Familie sei hier irgendwie unter so einem Wogness-Beschuss, obwohl man eigentlich mal die finanzielle Diskussion führen müsste.
Und man will Menschen ohne Identität und will eigentlich die perfekten Konsumsklaven haben. Jetzt geht das weiter von der Familie, da holt sie also alle mal ab, der hat irgendwie eine Familie. Jetzt geht es um die nationale Identität, die attackiert wird, die religiöse Identität, die Gender Identität. Und jetzt sagt sie, dass sie ihr nicht mehr erlaubt, es sich länger als Italienerin, Christin, Frau und Mutter zu definieren. Gemacht, man sei dann Bürger X mit dem Gender X und ist Eltern 1 und Eltern 2. Denn wenn man keine Identität mehr hat, dann ist man nur noch eine Nummer und ist der perfekte Sklave dann für die Finanzspekulant. Also man sieht ja auch die Hochfinanz, die Hochfinanz, da wird so eine, genau, Hochfinanziere ich die Übersetzung, also man hat ja dann von deren Gnade man abhänge, so eine strukturelle antisemitische Verschwörung noch.
Das ist die Frage. Und das ist Frage.
Und deswegen würde das jetzt auch alle erst mal so in Furcht versetzen, also was jetzt von ihnen da ausgeht. Sie wollen nicht länger Nummern sein, sie werden sich verteidigen, ihre Werte als Menschen. Dass sie dann also, because each of us has a unique genetic code that is unrepeatable, also diese zunächst in die DNA eingeschrieben, die Originalität.
Ja, dieser Verweis auf Genetik war ja was Tilo Sarrazin damals, es war ja irre, er hat ja dieses Deutschland schafft sich ab Buch hingeschrieben und da gab es auch was zur Genetik, dass irgendwas so vorbestimmt ist und so weiter und so fort. Und das fand sehr viel Resonanz, weil das natürlich ein dagegen kann man nicht anargumentieren Punkt ist, weil es steht in der DNA, es ist sozusagen Gott oder Natur gegeben, wie auch immer. Und dann hat er als nächstes Jahr ein Buch geschrieben über diesen genetischen Punkt, weil er merkte, da resonieren die Leute. Und Kaube meinte damals nur, ja, eigentlich über den schwächsten, innerlich schwächsten Punkt das ganze Buch aufgezogen. Und so ist es hier auch wieder. Sie kommt einfach mit diesem Unique Genetic Code einfach nur, um das so als Signalding zu setzen und muss verschleiern, dass sie keine Ahnung davon hat, was sie da sagt und was sie überhaupt meinen kann damit. Sondern es ist wirklich nur so ein Signaling.
Dann natürlich wird das nochmal umgekehrt, dass sie die Freiheit verteidigen werden, niemals Sklaven werden wollen oder einfache Konsumenten.
Wie ist die Hochfinanz möchte?
Und jetzt ist es interessant, sie zitiert Gilbert Keith Chesterton, einen sehr katholischen Autor, der konservativer war, aber sehr kontraintuitiv ist. Man kennt Chesterton auch natürlich als Autor der Father Brown Krimier-Romane, der sehr viele Essays geschrieben hat. Und jetzt hier nochmal an so einen Katholizismus zurückgeht. Im Übrigen wurde das auch angedeutet, schon bei der bei den Rechten in Wilbecks Unterwerfung. Da wird auch schon auf Chesterton Bezug genommen. Sie sucht das Zitat. Ja, also es ist jetzt quasi der Mut, muss da sein, dass man wieder benennt, dass 2 und 2 4 ist und manchmal ist das der. Also gibt es Zeiten, wo das den größten Mut verlangt.
Die Blätter sind grün, 2 plus 2 ist 4.
Ja, also wo man die einfachen Wahrheiten wieder aussprechen muss und das wird am ärgsten bekämpft. Und diese Zeit, sagt sie dann, nachdem sie ihn zitiert hat, diese Zeit sei nun gekommen, wir sind bereit. Da bekommt man es mit der Angst zu tun. Und zugleich haben wir dann auch in Deutschland interessante Entwicklungen, wie zum Beispiel ein Friedrich Merz, der bei der Bildzeitung ist und folgendes sagt.
Wir erleben mittlerweile einen Sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland, zurück in die Ukraine, nach Deutschland, zurück in die Ukraine. Näher als 1, 1 Millionen Flüchtlinge insgesamt bisher. Von denen mittlerweile eine größere Zahl sich dieses System zur Nutze machen. Da haben wir ein Problem, das wird größer. Wir haben im Frühjahr darauf hingewiesen, dass dieses Problem entstehen konnte. Die Bundesregierung hat sich taub gestellt.
So was ist das jetzt bei Friedrich Merz gewesen? Er hat sich dann danach entschuldigt, wenn sich jemand davon beleidigt haben und sollte. Also es war natürlich eine Nicht-Entschuldigung, die er geliefert hat. Und er argumentiert ja hier. Es ist ja nicht so, dass er sich verhaspelt und irgendeinen Begriff verwendet. Er will eigentlich Flüchtling sagen und sagt Asylant oder so etwas, wo man sagt, na da hat er sich wohl versprochen oder das hat er nicht so gemeint. Sonst ist ein ganz klarer Argumentationsaufbau. Und es ist ja wohl überlegt, dass er das da vorträgt. Das passiert einem ja nicht. Das unterläuft einem nicht. Meine These ist, Friedrich Merz hat jetzt mal getestet, wie ist die Stimmung, ab wann kann man dazu übergehen? Es gab ja dann auch doch so den einen oder anderen wirklich aus der allerletzten Reihe der CDU, der auch sagte, ja ja, die bilden sich ja weiß Gott was ein, die aus der Ukraine kommen. Also man versucht jetzt schon mal so langsam deutlich zu machen, ja die sollen da mal die NATO unterstützen, sage ich mal, aber die sollen nicht hier erwarten, dass wir es allzu glimpflich mit ihnen angehen. Und dann ist auch bald, wir machen das alles nur für die Menschen, wieder vorbei und sicherlich war jetzt März noch zu früh, da hat ihn jetzt das Gespür auch ein bisschen verlassen. Das müsste man dann schon machen, wenn der Winter sehr kalt wird, dann glaube ich, kann das schon besser zünden wieder, aber er hat es schon mal probiert, kriegt dann noch aus der eigenen Partei so ein bisschen was mit. Aber es haben auch schon, ich habe dann mal so drauf geachtet, ganz viele CDU-Leute schon mal seine Entschuldigung retweetet direkt, um zu sagen, ja, wir wollen es ja, aber wir müssen auch mal schon vorsichtig sein, dass da nicht allzu viel Schindluder getrieben wird.
Also ich fand Robin Alexanders Erklärung dazu ganz gut, der fühlt ja doch noch mal rein in die Partei, wie wird es da so aufgegriffen? Er meinte, die Testballon-These ist schwierig, denn Friedrich Merz hatte in diesem Moment eigentlich einen Elfmeter vor sich liegen, weil das war ja zeitgleich mit auch Christian Lindner, sagt dann irgendwann, die Gasumlage muss eigentlich weg. So. Und in diesem Moment hätte man ja wirklich die, also jede Partei für sich, aber auch die Bundesregierung an sich so ein bisschen drauf einschlagen könnte, dass sie das nicht geregelt kriegen, dass sie keinen Ersatz haben für die Gasumlage. Ich würde ja weiterhin sagen, die These vom letzten Monat, Habeck hat sie boykottiert im Sinne von, ja wenn ihr das wollt, liebe FDP, machen wir das. Am Ende werdet ihr es kassieren müssen.
Aber ich mach die so schlecht, damit ihr sie dann...
Genau, ich mach die so schlecht und alternativlos, dass am Ende ihr dran kleben bleibt und Lindner ist genau in die Falle gelaufen. Und Robin Alexander meint dann so, ja, das ist so, als hätte man diesen Elfmeter genommen, ein Handspiel daraus gemacht, ihn rüber ins andere Tor, ins eigene und dann nochmal über die Linie geschoben. Also bescheuert geht's eigentlich gar nicht. Und die Erklärung dafür war dann, ja, Friedrich Merz war halt auch einfach 20 Jahre nicht ein politischen System. Der weiß nämlich nicht, dass 2013 oder so Sozialtourismus zum Unwort des Jahres erklärt wurde.
Kannst du das mal wissen.
Und ich dachte mir auch, wir sind ja, wir haben doch alle noch vor Augen, wie Markus Söder da so saß und vom Asiltourismus und so weiter. Und dann alle Diskussionen danach, wie er dann feststellte, ach so, ich muss hier gegen die Grünen arbeiten. Okay, mache ich mal eine grüne Wende. Und dann hat man jahrelang sich darüber amüsiert, wie er eigentlich von diesem Sozialtourismus, Asiltourismus-Ding hin zum, ach nee, ich muss jetzt für die, rettet die Bienen und so weiter, dieses ganze grüne Ding. Und es war komplett ausgeblendet bei Friedrich Merz. Also man hat es überhaupt nicht gespürt, dass er da so ein historisches Bewusstsein, ein Debattengedächtnis irgendwie hat. Und saß einfach völlig banane und hatte diesen Sozialtourismus in einer Situation, wo man ja echt sagt, nee, wir sind gerade ganz solidarisch mit den Ukrainern. Und zwar flächendeckend. Und wir räumen auch gerade keine Toren heilen für die Freie. Wir haben auch keine sachlichen Gründe, uns dagegen zu wenden, weil das Problem gerade nirgendwo anlandet und aufläuft. Und in deren Sicht würde ich sagen, wir haben es hier mit klassischer Dummheit einfach zu tun gehabt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Das ist eine totale Unterschätzung, Überschätzung der Situation.
Für wahrscheinlich, dass er schaut, dass man doch wieder... Also ich glaube, die CDU, man hat es ja auch bei diesem Parteitag gemerkt, möchte über Identitätspolitik, also so wie Meloni uns das jetzt gerade vorgemacht hat, Wähler bekommen. Und das wird man am Ende auch schaffen, indem man quasi eine Gemeinschaft als Wir-sind-das-Volk sieht. Und dann gehören Ukrainer am Ende auch nicht dazu. Die müssen sich dann auch dem fügen und sollen sich mal gar nicht zu viel herausnehmen. Also ich glaube, dass man schon dieser Logik ist, inwieweit das jetzt Testballon war oder nicht. Ich glaube aber, dass es aus tiefstem Herzen kam. Nun ist es ja so, dass wir es mit einer nach wie vor steigenden Inflation zu tun haben, dass wir es mit enormen Belastungen zu tun haben, die auch durch die Entlastungspakete nicht ausgeglichen werden. Wir hatten ihn schon einmal und ich bringe das jetzt wieder. Helmut Schläweis hat sich zu Wort gemeldet. Er ist der Präsident des Deutschen Sparkassen und Juroverbandes. Am 13.9. hat er eine Rede gehalten, die man überhaupt nicht findet im Internet. Man findet nur so ein dürres PDF. Und dieser Rede heißt es, ein enorm wichtiger Faktor für den deutschen Mittelstand und insbesondere für konsumnahe Branchen wird in den nächsten Monaten die Einkommenssituation und die Konsumneigung der privaten Haushalte sein. Die erheblichen Preissteigerungen der letzten Monate sind ein massiver Dämpfer. Bei den aktuellen Preissprüngen benötigen nach unseren Berechnungen 60 Prozent der Haushalte ihre gesamten monatlichen Einkünfte und mehr, um die laufenden Ausgaben zu decken. Haushalte mit monatlichem Nettoeinkommen unter 3600 Euro werden am Monatsende kein Geld mehr übrig haben und Lücken teilweise durch eigene Ersparnisse ausgleichen müssen. Für Gastgewerbe, Tourismus, Einzelhandel und andere persönliche Dienstleite bedeutet das, dass sie sich auf massive Änderungen im Kundenverhalten einstellen müssen. Also mit anderen Worten, die kommen nicht mehr. Ich halte es deshalb für richtig, dass die Bundesregierung und die Koalitionsfraktionen mit einem dritten Entlastungspaket reagieren. Wichtig scheint mir allerdings, und wir reden jetzt hier vom Präsidenten des Sparkassenverbandes, wichtig scheint mir allerdings, die Entlastung auf Haushalte mit einem Nettoeinkommen bis 3.600 Euro zu konzentrieren. Denn höhere Einkommen können, so zeigen Berechnungen, Netto immer noch zusätzlich Rücklagen bilden. Die niedrigsten Einkommen stehen dabei zu Recht im Fokus der politischen Aufmerksamkeit. Ich empfehle allerdings auch, die Einkommen von rund 2.000 bis 3.600 Euro monatlich nicht zu vergessen. Die Betroffenen werden dies in der jetzigen Phase nicht in Angriff nehmen. Wenn es hierfür nicht spürbare staatliche Anreize gibt. Das ist jetzt der Sparkassenverband. Es ist erstaunlich, wie wenig das in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der jetzigen Phase in der politik also in der Ampelkoalition verstanden wird. Sie haben Angst davor. Sie haben Angst davor, das zu verstehen, oder?
Nee, das wissen sie, wo es klemmt, aber sie haben Angst davor, den Prozess dann herzustellen. Es überhaupt so zu thematisieren, dass Ansprüche überhaupt entstehen, dass sich so Schicksalsgemeinschaften bilden. Man sieht ja jetzt schon, wie sie vorbeugen, indem sie das Wohngeld wirklich, also die Zugänge zum Wohngeld wirklich krass verbreitern. Ich war ganz überrascht, die Zahlen zu hören, dass sie da so ein bisschen vorbeugen und erst mal politische Realität schaffen und dann sagen, wir haben es schon so ein bisschen geregelt. Also holt euch mal Wohngeld oder so, damit man den Leuten nicht sofort eine Adresse gibt, wenn es dann so thematisiert wird. Aber ja, es wird natürlich heikel, gerade für uns Deutsche, wo wir immer dachten, wir können so mit Nothilfepaketen und hier nochmal Rettungsaktionen da irgendwie durch. Nee, wir müssen jetzt wirklich ein bisschen strukturell umbauen.
Naja, und man kann ja sehen, was so passiert. Also ich bekam eine Nachricht von einem Hörer, der in der Oberstufe noch ist. Und der hat gesagt, er würde mir jetzt mal ein Video schicken, das seine Klassenkameraden ganz toll finden. Und er sei da sehr erschrocken darüber. Und das war ein TikTok-Video mit Alice Weidel. Aber nicht von Alice Weidel hochgeladen, sondern von irgendeinem Account. Dieser Account hat ein paar andere Politikvideos hochgeladen, hat damit 10.000-20.000 Aufrufe. Nicht der Rede wert. Also dieses Alice Weidel-Video, das wir uns jetzt gleich anhören, das hat 4 Millionen Aufrufe und 500.000 Likes. Und die Kommentare, 13.000. Ich habe nicht alle gelesen, aber einige. Da stand, ja, ich finde die AfD ja scheiße, aber hier hat sie wirklich recht. Oder eigentlich dachte ich immer, die AfD ist nicht meine Partei, aber vielleicht jetzt doch. Solche Kommentare waren da. Oder Weidel ist einfach die richtige Politikerin, sie spricht es aus. Das waren die Reaktionen. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal an. Das ist also ein Video, in dem Alice Weidel nicht, wie viele andere Politiker rumtanzt oder sonst was, weil man glaubt, das muss man auf TikTok tun, sondern sie sagt folgendes.
Die Leute werden auf die Straße gehen. Den ganzen Winter lang. Und was fällt solchen Politikern eigentlich ein, die sich hier irgendwie durch die Gegend fahren lassen? Irgendwie den Leuten vorzuschreiben, wie viel sie verbrauchen, mit dem Waschlappen zu duschen, kalt zu duschen, sonst irgendwas, frieren und hier und da. Das ist so unfassbar, unseriös und unglaublich verblödet, dass es nur so kracht. Und natürlich werden die Leute dagegen auf die Straße gehen, weil sie nachher nichts mehr haben. Was glauben sie denn, wie das hier weitergeht? Die Menschen werden reinweise ihre Jobs verlieren. Wer soll das denn alles noch bezahlen? Was glauben sie, was hier in Deutschland los ist? Wir haben nicht mal im geringsten einen strategischen Lösungsansatz, um dem überhaupt zu begegnen. Das ist unverantwortlich. Darum habe ich auch gestern in meiner Rede gesagt, die Menschen haben alles Recht, auf die Straße zu gehen. Gegen diese Politik, gegen diese Regierung, die sie eiskalt auflaufen lassen. Die haben doch gar nichts mehr. Wir haben eine sterbende Währung. Die Leute, die Menschen können auch gar nicht mehr sparen. Es geht doch alles für die Lebenshaltungskosten drauf.
Ja, wir sind mit diesem Soundtrack unter. Das ist ein Video, das vier Millionen Aufrufe hat. Und wir haben jetzt sehr viele über Facebook geredet und von der Boomer-Generation, die da auf Fake-News reinfällt und sich am Ende nicht impfen lässt. Und das geht natürlich bei jungen Leuten viral, die plötzlich sagen, die spricht ja eigentlich die Wahrheit aus. Also ich würde sagen, da braut sich auf TikTok einiges gerade zusammen. Die AfD ist da sehr stark vertreten aus diesen ganzen Videos, aus den ganzen Auftritten im Bundestag werden solche Clips geschnitten. Da gibt es dann diese Musik darunter. Und die Tatsache ist ja, dass wir von der Ampel, du hast jetzt da Beispiel genannt, aber wir bekommen da eigentlich viel zu wenig, wenn man bedenkt, wie hart der Winter werden wird. Und ich finde auch, dass die Berichterstattung da zum Teil vollkommen schief läuft. Also man gar nicht das Leid der Menschen in den Mittelpunkt rückt und dann sagt, was politisch zu tun wäre. Auch bei diesem Funk-Format wird ja nicht mal wirklich dann über Schuldenbremse oder so gesprochen, oder wenn es um wirkliche Zahlungen geht. Oder man hat dann hier so ein Format wie ZDF Insights, so ein YouTube-Format, wo dann Andrea Maurer sagt, ja rechts und links, die wollen ja beide demonstrieren. Ach, die sind ja irgendwie dann auch ähnlich. Also wieder so eine Hufeisen-Theorie schmiede. Der Beitrag endet dann mit solchen Worten.
Was meint ihr? Wird sich das bei Protesten auseinanderhalten lassen, wer links und wer rechts ist? Wird dieser Herbst heiß oder bleibt das ein politischer Traum von Linken und Rechten? Und was müsste die Regierung eurer Meinung nach tun, damit es nicht zu Massenprotesten oder Unruhen kommt?
Es ist ja nicht einfach nur ein Traum. Es wird jetzt so getan, als wäre die Linken träumen einfach nur von irgendeinem Aufstand. Es gibt ja einfach probate Gründe, warum man da auf die Straße gehen würde. Und ich fand es auch so toll, dass wir sofort dieses allgemeine Framing haben. Ja, was ist, wenn da Leute demonstrieren und da aber noch irgendwo sich Rechte dazu gesellen? Ich fand sehr schön da ein Tweet, weil ich ja in gewisser Weise auch Fan des What Aboutism bin von Ole, meinem lieben Podcast-Kollegin. Und zwar hatte Tilo da angekündigt, Kanzler Scholz reist Ende der Woche unter anderem nach Saudi Arabien, um zum Beispiel mit dem Kronprinzen sich zu treffen. Und dann hat Ole drüber geschrieben, aber gut aufpassen, also jetzt quasi an unsere Demonstranten, aber gut aufpassen, wer neben euch bei der heißen Herbst-Demonstration steht. Also da sagt man sofort, ja, wenn da irgendjemand ist, der nicht links ist, dann ist das falsch. Und ich sehe das auch als was Falsches an. Aber wir müssen auch zugleich erkennen, dass die Bundesregierung die ganze Zeit neben irgendwelchen Leuten stehen kann, die nicht auf dem demokratischen, liberalen Boden stehen. Und ich warne wirklich sehr davor, das einfach nur als so eine Geschichte da zu verkaufen. Sondern es ist einfach reales Leid. Das ist, wenn die Familie kein Geld mehr hat für die Kinder, wenn nicht mehr entsprechend geheizt werden kann, dann ist das ein reales Leid, was da entstanden ist. Und die gucken nicht vorher nochmal einen YouTube-Clip und lassen sich über irgendwelche Konstellationen und Querfronten aufklären, sondern die haben dann einfach kein Geld.
Ja vor allem, wenn jetzt Menschen auf die Straße gehen, dann wissen wir doch wirklich, warum. Dann müssen wir die Frage, ist das jetzt rechts oder links oder beides, gar nicht klären, weil ist ja egal. Also das ist ja nur der Anlass. Der Grund ist ja dann trotzdem ein anderer. Wir werden im Salon, ich hatte es schon letzten Monat, es ist so eine interessante Textgrundlage. Es gibt einen Autor, Markus oder Martin Rückert. Der schreibt so für die Frankfurter Rundschau. Der hat immer so zusammengestellt, was es eigentlich bedeutete, die Kinder in Corona so ein bisschen sich selbst zu überlassen. Also 54 Prozent plus diagnostizierte Essstörungen bei Mädchen 15 bis 17 Jahre, Adipositas plus im zweistelligen Prozentbereich und so weiter. Und wir kommen jetzt in so eine Lage, wo wir bei den Familien sehen, okay, die sparen jetzt. Die werden aber nicht Hunger leiden, sondern die werden sich nur ungesund ernähren. Und das führt ja dann auch wieder zu folgen psychischer und körperlicher Natur. Also wir haben es ja mit so einem wirklichen konstitutionellen Abwärtstrend sozusagen zu tun, durch diesen Preisdruck, der jetzt entsteht. Und ich finde, wir sollten da viel mehr auf diese psychischen und physischen Konstellationen und Konstitutionen schauen, als diese, was man halt typischerweise bei Funk dann noch mal ist, ist das jetzt die Veränderung des Hufeisens und so weiter, so ein Halligalli aus solchen Argumentationen zu drehen, sondern sich wirklich mal jetzt diese materielle Grundlage anzuschauen, was passiert da eigentlich. Und in deren Sicht, ja, die schauen jetzt diesen TikTok, dieses TikTok-Minütchen, sag ich mal so. Wir wissen bei, aus dieser Facebook-Diskussion, gerade 2016 Wahl in Amerika, man kann mit ganz schön wenig Einfluss für ganz schön viele Wellen sorgen, gerade weil das Publikum ja zehn Stunden am Tag irgendwie online ist. In deren Sicht, ja, so ein Video, vier Millionen Views, aber diese vier Millionen runtergebrochen auf eine Minute im Verhältnis zu wie viel TikTok-Zeit die so durchrauscht. Also ich sehe da noch Potenzial, zum einen zu sagen, ja, die sehen das und verhalten sich dazu, aber es könnte auch Anlass für ein Gespräch sein. Also zum Beispiel wache Lehrerschaft, weil eine Minute ist nicht allzu viel Indoktrination, dafür, dass da noch relativ mehr wird.
Man kommt natürlich schnell weiter. Ich habe es mir dann zwei bei einem angesehen bekommen, natürlich entsprechend, dass dann sofort präferiert, was in der endlichen Richtung geht. Das dauert nicht lang. Ich würde noch mal einen kleinen Sprung machen zu einem Moderator, der im Tomorrow Podcast zu Gast war, und zwar nicht der amerikanische Tomorrow Podcast, sondern der deutsche Marketing Podcast von Tom Jung, das Dorf. Und zwar kennst du Ricardo Basile? Nein. Ich auch kannte ihn natürlich auch nicht. Das ist ein Sky-Moderator, der ganz populär wohl bei den Fußballern ist. Also bei den Fußballern, ich weiß, mir sagte man, bei den Fußball-Fans sei der nicht populär. Das haben mir dann Freunde, die Fußball gucken, sofort gesagt. Das glaube ich sofort.
Das war immer dieses Belarreti moderiert wieder. Oh, scheiße. Aber dabei fanden alle Belarreti supergeil, wenn der die Spiele moderiert hat. Aber hier glaube ich jetzt nicht so.
Also hier ist es, so sagte man mir das. Mir ist es auch egal, denn ich werde ja niemals Fußball gucken. Nur greife ich das raus, weil ich es so kurios fand, dass ich es mitbringen wollte. Denn wir haben jetzt schon über Identität gesprochen. Und irgendwie ist das ja so etwas, was alle umtreibt. Und statt über Ökonomisches zu sprechen, möchte man dann lieber sagen, ja, lass uns nochmal über App-Konzerne sprechen. Ja, über App-Konzerne sprechen. Die schönen englischen Äpfel, wie Alistras sagt, oder hier Meloni, noch mal von der Kirche und der Familie. Und ich zitiere euch Chesetton. Zugleich haben wir es aber ja immer mit Figuren auch zu tun. Alice Weidel wäre ja auch so ein Beispiel dafür, die ein modernes Leben führen. Das ist eigentlich mit dieser Identität, die sie darauf beschwören, gar nicht viel zu tun hat. Und dennoch gibt es aber diese Suche und die Sehnsucht danach. Jeder Disney-Film befriedigt sie inzwischen. Das heißt, ich würde generell so ein aufkommendes Tribalismus wahrnehmen wollen. Und zwar global. Und dann findet man es manchmal so in der Schwunnstufe. Und da wird es dann so besonders kurios, aber vielleicht auch fassbar. Und deswegen aus diesem Tomorrow-Podcast hören wir jetzt Ricardo Basile, der da von seiner Karriere erzählt. Und der jetzt aber erst einmal erläutert, dass er ein Jahr im Hotel gewohnt hat.
Es gibt eigentlich nichts, was ich jetzt irgendwie in der Hotelzeit vermisst habe. Weil da ich eh viel unterwegs bin, habe ich da dann auch mal ein, zwei Leute getroffen. Es war eine schöne Zeit. Es gibt nichts, was ich tatsächlich, als ich im Hotel gelebt habe, an einer normalen Wohnung vermisst habe. Jetzt bin ich erst in der Wohnung, seit wir uns getroffen haben, war die erste Nacht. Dann war ich wieder zwischenzeitlich drei Nächte wieder weg, habe jetzt insgesamt vier Nächte da geschlafen. Es ist schön, ich könnte jederzeit wieder ins Hotel ziehen.
Ein Leben im Hotel, ein ganzes Jahr. Wir kennen das sonst nur von Udo Lindenberg, der das einfach jetzt zu seiner Heimat gemacht hat, an einem Ort, der eigentlich für den Durchgangsverkehr ist, dann zu bleiben. Aber er kommt damit zurecht, der hat auch keine Bindung eigentlich an Möbel oder so. Und deswegen war das kein Problem für ihn. Noch was betont er hier.
Ich liebe Flughäfen. Ich liebe Flughäfen so unglaublich. Ich liebe Hotels, deswegen habe ich da gewohnt. Ich liebe auch dieses Schnelllebige. Wenn ich auch dann am Flughafen bin und die Leute beobachte und sehe, die kommen von dort oder von dort. Wenn ich den Flughafen betrete und diese großen Anzeigetafeln sehe, das gibt mir schon ein Gefühl der Freiheit.
Ich weiß, was er meint, aber ich dachte, das nutzt sich relativ zügig ab.
Offenbar nicht. Man würde jetzt sagen, so ein Mensch, der ein Jahr im Hotel leben kann, der eigentlich nur an Flughäfen unterwegs ist, der braucht jetzt ja nicht noch irgendeine Identität. Aber vielleicht gerade das produziert dann noch mal besonders stark diese Sehnsucht nach irgendeiner merkwürdigen Identität, auch nach einer Pseudotheorie. Denn bevor wir zum Thema Identität kommen, gehen wir jetzt erstmal zur Bändchentheorie über. Hast du schon mal von der Bändchentheorie gehört, Stefan? Nein. Naja, jetzt macht dich auch mal was gefasstes. Also jetzt wird es richtig kompliziert, mein Lieber.
Du hast ja Kommunikationswissenschaften, Politikwissenschaften und Romanistik studiert. Da ist ja alles cool, aber da ist ja kein Fashionbezug.
Das stimmt. Ich verrate dir, warum ich das studiert habe, weil Marcel Reif, mein Ziefater, mir gesagt hat, ich solle das studieren. Er hat das ähnlich studiert, nur nicht Romanistik, sondern Amerikanistik stattdessen noch zur Politik. Ich habe ein Praktikum bei Sky gemacht und dann wollte ich gerne länger bei Sky bleiben und dann hatte Marcel Reif mir aber gesagt, Junge, pass auf, es gibt die Bändchentheorie. Von der Bändchentheorie bin ich nach wie vor überzeugt.
Ich bin gespannt.
Und die Bändchentheorie besagt, man soll so viele Bändchen sammeln, wie eben möglich. Abitur ist ein Bändchen. Das berechtigt dich, die nächste Tür zu öffnen und sie auch zu durchschreiten. Das war dann mein Studium, was ich eigentlich nicht machen wollte, weil ich gedacht habe, ich bleibe direkt bei Sky. Nein, mach erst das Studium, da sammelst du das nächste Bändchen. Und so geht es im Leben darum, immer weitere Bändchen zu sammeln, dass man immer die Möglichkeit hat, wenn irgendwann mal ein Türsteher vor der Tür steht und sagt, du kommst ja nicht rein, deine Hand zu heben und zu sagen, ich habe aber das Bändchen, ich bin berechtigt, hier reinzugehen.
Genial, oder? Ja, in der Regel helfen schon mal höhere Schulabschlüsse. In der Regel ist es gut, wenn man mehrere Sachen kann. Viele Sprachen ist auch oft hilfreich.
Es ist sehr merkwürdig, weil auf der einen Seite ist ja dieses, ich bin Kosmopolit oder wie wir sagen würden, Lost. Ja, wenn dir egal ist, in welchem Hotel du wohnst, weil ich würde ja mal sagen, es ist egal, in welcher Wohnung man wohnt, solange die Nachbarschaft hinhaut und man weiß, wer steht dir wann zur Verfügung und für was. Also diese Sozialdimension einfach zu klären. Wenn man einfach ins Hotel geht oder sich im Flughafen wohlführt, da weiß man, da kann man dann irgendwo hin. Aber der Ort selber ist sozusagen Transit. Dass man dann anfängt mit so einer Bändchentheorie, also sich zu verorten, indem man seine Persönlichkeit auch ganz an die Erwartung der Umwelt bindet und sagt, wir müssen ja gar kein Wort wechseln, ich zeig dir einfach meinen Abschluss. Das ist natürlich total Banane, denn ich habe auch so eine Art Bändchentheorie, die jetzt gerade in meinem Leben so ein bisschen greift, dass ich mir denke, warum engagiere ich mich nicht mehr? Dann ist so der Förderverein, der Schule und der Schwimmverein und plötzlich ist man halt nicht nur Mitglied, sondern so zweiter Vorsitzender und sowas. Und das ist aber ganz anders gemeint als bei ihm. Denn ich gehe ja nicht da hin und sage, guck mal wer ich bin, der zweite Vorsitzende, der so und so, sondern nein, ich bin natürlich der zweite Vorsitzende und damit will alle, die schon da sind und mich kennen, der Ansprechpartner für die alltäglichen Probleme. Also ich bin gerade da für diese Gespräche, die er vermeiden möchte. Also eine genau umgedrehte Bändchentheorie, nämlich eine, die sozusagen mit sozialem Gehalt gefüllt ist und nicht mit als Shortcut gemeint ist. Und das finde ich natürlich unter dieser, da es bei mir jetzt auch relativ neu ist, wirklich so ein paar Monate, die Erfahrung, die so langsam aufbaut, einfach auch mal da so ein bisschen eine Rolle zu spielen und so, ist das natürlich ganz schade zu hören, dass er das als diese Art Abkürzung benutzt und nicht als Enablung. Weil das ist das Türsteher-Ding. Das heißt ja, da geht es mir nur um mich und den Abend und am nächsten Tag bin ich schon wieder im Flughafen und dann schon wieder in irgendeinem Hotel. Ja, und tauche dann eben nicht wieder auf, wo mich der Türsteher schon mal kennenlernen kann, sondern nicht auf mein Bändchen.
Man kommt rein und absurd ist es ja auch, dass man das noch mit dem Begriff Theorie belegt. Das zeigt ja, es gibt so eine große Orientierungslosigkeit. Also ich würde sagen, diese Orientierungslosigkeit ist immens, wenn du dir Instagram-Kacheln ansiehst. Und das hier ist ja einfach die gesprochene Instagram-Kachel, die ich euch jetzt hier vorführe.
Aber das ist ja eh.
Oder es kommt noch mehr.
Wenn man einmal hier Luhmannsoziologie studiert und dann kommt irgendwer mit irgendeiner Theorie, sagt man, nein, das ist eine Idee, über die können wir jetzt eine halbe Stunde reden. Aber das war es.
Es ist keine Theorie. Und nun er sammelt auch Uhren. Wer hätte das gedacht? Das ist ja auch so etwas ganz...
Es ist ein Bändchen.
Es ist auch ein Bändchen. Und das hat er ja auch gemein mit all den wunderbaren Fußballern vom FC Bayern. Denn was gibt es Schöneres als Uhren irgendwo hinzulegen? Und er hatte eine Odemar Piquet und beschreibt jetzt mal da seine fast identitäre Verbindung zu.
Ich mag an der Royal Oak, ich liebe blau. Die ist ja blau und Zifferblatt. Dann diese Uhr, die hat was. Ehrlicherweise finde ich zumindest hat sie was mystisches. Ich bin früher sehr oft mit meinen Eltern am Meer gewesen. Und oft waren wir segeln, weil mein Vater unter anderem Kapitän war. Und immer wenn ich in diese Uhr blicke, ehrlicherweise kommt es mir so vor, als ob ich auf das Meer blicke. Und deswegen habe ich die Uhr wirklich sehr, sehr oft mittlerweile an. Die beruhigt mich unheimlich, dieser Blautruhn des Ziffernblattes.
Der braucht ganz dringend einen Therapeuten. Denn diese Uhr zeichnet sich nur dadurch aus, dass sie relativ viel Wert auf ganz wenig Volumen und Gewicht vereinigt. Das heißt, es klappt zu seinem mobilen Lebensstil. Die kann er immer bei sich tragen, ohne dass er als Gepäck noch mitverrechnet werden muss. Und diese Art von materieller Abhängigkeit ist möglich.
So wird eine materielle Abhängigkeit hergestellt, dass man das jetzt auflädt mit eigener Geschichte oder die Unternehmen dann mit ihrer Geschichte. Esquer und Boltanski sprechen ja von der Bereicherungsökonomie.
Absolut, das ist Werbungsoppfer.
Ich bereichere das Produkt auch noch mal selbst. Ich nehme nicht nur die Geschichte des Uhrenherstellers, der sagt schon vor 200 Jahren haben wir, sondern ich sage auch noch mal selbst, das erinnert mich an das Meer, wo ich dann denken würde, ja dann verkaufe doch die Uhr und fahre für das Geld ans Meer.
Dass er sich hier allen Ernstes als Vorbild sieht und deswegen auch so redet, statt als Opfer, finde ich grotesk, denn es ist ganz schlimm zu hören.
An dem Punkt sind wir ja angekommen. An dem Punkt sind wir ja leider angekommen. Menschen werden zu Instagram kacheln und verkaufen das dann als Vorbild. Und er hat natürlich auch, wie sich das gehört, ein Mode-Label und dieses Mode-Label heißt Bolzer. Woran erinnert dich das? Selbstverständlich an den Bolzplatz. Und auch hier haben wir eine schöne Geschichte.
Bolzplatz meets Street-Style. Warum hast du dich dafür entschieden und nicht gesagt, ich mache Prada, Gucci, 3.0?
Ich liebe ja den Fußball und alle anderen Sportarten auch. Und da war die Idee damals dahinter, die ist dann in Bamberg, da habe ich studiert, entstanden ist auch eine ganz kleine, süße Stadt, Kopfsteinpflaster sehr oft. Und da kam dann aufgrund dieses Kopfsteinpflasters und meiner Affinität auch zum Fußball die Idee, wir machen Street-Style. Street-Style, die ein bisschen cool aussieht, ein bisschen Oversize, die T-Shirts, dann Hoodies, die viele Leute tragen, viele meiner Freunde lieben Hoodies oder ich glaube fast alle.
Das ist natürlich eine ganz groteske Herausforderung, der sich stellt, nämlich zum einen, ich bin der Mann ohne Persönlichkeit, der Mann ohne Eigenschaften, mir ist alles recht, ich brauche nur meine kleine Uhr, die fällt nicht weiter auf und dann die Orte sollen möglichst neutral trocken, da soll immer ein Sicherheitspersonal sein und ich brauche immer was zu kaufen.
Er ist investiert in eine Sicherheitsfirma übrigens.
Und gleichzeitig dieses Bemühen, diese nicht mehr vorhandenen Reste von Persönlichkeiten nochmal zu exportieren in irgendeinem Produkt, damit andere das attraktiv finden ist, also es ist wirklich grotesk.
Das ist genial, jetzt geht es noch weiter.
Und was ich total mag ist so dieser Claim, den du dahinter hast, Beutzer zeigt der Welt, wo du herkommst. Ich finde das ist irgendwie, das hat so eine Romantik.
Ja, das liegt ehrlicherweise daran, dass, auch wenn du mal den Bolzplatz jetzt nimmst, da ist es total egal, welche Religion du hast, welche Hautfarbe, da sind wir alle gleich. Es geht ums Gewinnen und dann bist du mit deinem Teamkameraden eins.
Das widerspricht allem, was wir auf anderen Instagram-Kacheln sehen, nämlich es ist egal, wo du herkommst, wichtig ist, wo du hin willst.
Ja, und jetzt dreht das aber auch wieder rum. Wir hören uns wirklich den letzten Clip an. Ich entschuldige mich fast dafür, dass ich das ausgesucht habe, aber ich finde, es ist so symptomatisch für unsere Zeit, denn Patriotismus geht natürlich auch noch dazu.
Aber ich finde, man sollte dennoch nie vergessen, wo man herkommt. Ich finde das ganz wichtig. Ich finde, in Deutschland haben wir historisch bedingt ein Problem mit Patrioten.
Das finde ich komisch. Das ist irgendwie, dass wir das noch nicht ablegen konnten.
Das hätte eine Störung in der Geschichte gewesen, dass wir jetzt ein Problem mit Patrioten haben.
Das ist wirklich schade, weil ich finde, man sollte schon stolz sein, oder man kann stolz sein, wo man herkommt.
Also man ist dann stolz auf den Ortsbonus. Da kann ich sagen, ich hatte richtig Glück, ich bin richtig viel besser ausgestattet als irgendjemand aus einem nordafrikanischen Land.
Das ist auch das, was wir bei der Queen so vermisst haben, dass sie noch mal stolz ist, dass sie zur royalen Familie und so weiter. Das ist genau das, was gefehlt hat.
Berlinerin, mein Papa ist deutsch, ich bin in Deutschland geboren, ich bin da total stolz drauf, ich bin superglücklich, in Deutschland zu leben. Das Land bietet einem unglaublich viele Möglichkeiten. Man hat hier viele, viele Sicherheiten, die man auf der Welt sonst wirklich vermisst. Und deswegen, egal wo man herkommt, sollte man glaube ich nie vergessen. Und wenn man es nicht vergisst, sollte man es auch allen Menschen zeigen. Das finde ich ganz, ganz wichtig, dass man nicht vergisst, wo man herkommt und auch dazu steht und den Leuten dann zeigt, was ist denn vielleicht aus deinem Land das Besondere?
Ja, das wäre doch das Allerblümste, blödeste, wenn wir irgendwann eine Welt haben, in der wir nicht mehr fragen, und wo kommst du eigentlich wirklich her?
Genau, wir müssen unbedingt die ganze Zeit den Identitätsdiskurs. Und wenn da jemand perfekt Deutsch kann, der Taxifahrer da von Elke Heidenreich, aber der nicht weiß ist, dann müssen wir unbedingt nochmal nachfragen, was er hier denn eigentlich zu suchen hat.
Ja, das ist ja für mich so dieser Arbeitsauftrag. Ich habe mir in Bielefeld meinen ostdeutschen Tonfall abgelegt und versuche auch hier einfach, einen modernen Lebensstil für die Kinder und so weiter zu leben. Nein, ich muss jeden Morgen aufstehen und mich dran erinnern, dass ich aus Thüringen komme. Und ich muss ganz stolz auf diese Bratwurst-Herkunft sein. Wenn ich das jemals vergesse, dann verliere ich ja komplett mein, dann fühle ich mich ja auch auf Flughäfen nicht mehr wohl. Weil, oh geil, Flughäfen sind so geil, weil sie nicht Thüring sind. Aber nie vergessen, dass du aus Thüringen kommst jeden Morgen.
Mein Erfolgsrezept ist ja auch seit vielen Jahren, den fröhlichen Rheinländer zu spielen. Es ist entsetzlich, aber ich glaube, hier sind wir mal an den Kern der Ideologie vorgedrungen, der Identitätsideologie, aus der man wunderbar Produkte generieren kann. Luxusuhren, die einen an Sommerurlaube mit der Familie erinnern. Oder dann auch irgendwelche Mode-Labels, die irgendwo produziert werden, die aber dann ein Identitätsgefühl herstellen sollen. Und der Bolzplatz ist zum einen dann der Ort, an dem alles egal ist, wo du herkommst. Aber zugleich ist Patriotismus auch toll, dass man zeigt, woher man kommt. Also man packt alles zusammen. Und das ist ja das interessante eigentlich, wenn man es mit diesen neun vorwiegend rechten Identitätsströmungen zu tun hat, dann ist ja immer so, dass da man auf tausend Widersprüche stößt. Und hier, das ist ja ein hochwidersprüchliches System, das ist ja voller Eklektizismus und dennoch funktioniert es. Und das zeigt, wie chaotisch unsere Tage sind, wie unübersichtlich die Gegenwart ist und wie dann versucht wird, mit der Bändchen-Theorie noch wenig Ordnung ins Ganze zu bringen.
Ich habe jetzt rausgehört, das war dein letztes Thema.
Ja, gut.
Dann schließe ich mit einem zweiminütigen kleinen Listicle. Du weißt, was ein Listicle ist. Für Leute, die keine Lust haben zu lesen, die kriegen einfach eine Liste. Punkt eins bis zehn.
Ach so.
Wiedert sich in dem Fall an, denn wir haben ja gerade gehört, man soll nie vergessen, wo man herkommt und stolz drauf sein. Wir interessieren uns also für das 2022 Ranking The Best Countries. Erhoben von usnews.com nach einer Methodologie, die ja in einem ganz großen Text ganz raffiniert aufgeschlüsselt ist. Quality of Life, Entrepreneurship, Agility, Social Purpose, Movers, Cultural Influence, Open for Business, Adventure, Power, Heritage. Das spielt eine Rolle in verschiedenen Gewichtungen von 14, 52% für Quality of Life bis 3, 09% für Heritage. Und jetzt kleine Rätselfrage, welches Land ist auf Platz 1 das beste Land der Welt?
Ist es am Ende Japan oder so?
Nein, es ist die Schweiz.
Ah ja, natürlich.
Es ist die Schweiz, wer hätte es gedacht. Aber Platz 2, Deutschland. Also wenn ihr euch fragt, warum soll ich noch mal stolz sein? Ja, ihr seid auf Platz 2. Dann kommt Kanada, dann kommt Amerika, dann Schweden, Japan, Australien, UK, Frankreich, Dänemark. Ich finde die Liste abenteuerlich, denn egal, welche Kriterien man nimmt, Japan ist gerade kein lebenswertes Land. Also das macht keinen Spaß, da zu leben. Also alle Texte, die man bekommt, sind...
Ist aber ganz begehrt, wenn es um Staatsbürgerschaften geht. Deswegen habe ich es gleich genannt.
Ja, es ist von außen betrachtet ein reiches Land. Letztens flog auch wieder so ein Thread durch Twitter mit Kanada, wie es in Kanada wirklich ist. Kein frisches Gemüse im Supermarkt, alle Autos auf Lautstärke getrimmt, niemand kümmert sich um irgendwen. Und alles, was man so hört, ist Legende. Gerade, was Nachbarschaftshilfe und so angeht, sondern nö, es ist einfach genauso der gleiche westliche Scheiße überall sonst. Plus keine eigene Kultur, wie wir auch. Alles muss importiert werden, aus Amerika und sonst woher. Also da ist man unter Ferne liefen. UK auf Platz 8 hat man sich mal umgeguckt in UK und mal von den Londoner Tourismus-Hotspots abgesehen. Also das ist wirklich kein Land, wo man gerade gerne ist. In der Ansicht, es wird hier wieder ein Müll im Internet zusammengetragen. Es ist wirklich grotesk, die ganzen skandinavischen Länder spielen ja keine Rolle. Dänemark auf Platz 10, da würde ich sagen, nee. Also Dänemark muss da höher gerankt werden. In der Ansicht, es geht drunter und drüber. Und wer auf seine Herkunft stolz ist, ich weiß auch nicht, wie sowas ermessen und bemessen und nach welchem Maß steht und überhaupt. Und wer sich auf seine Uhr zurückziehen kann und daraus Lebensqualität schöpft, also wohl dem, würde ich sagen.
Ja, und wir empfehlen eher so etwas wie Geselligkeit und das machen wir ja auch. Wir gehen ja auch in diesem Monat nochmal wieder in die Oper und auch hier mein Aufruf, nicht nur in die Oper zu gehen, sondern auch generell gesellig zu sein, Dinge wahrzunehmen, ins Kino zu gehen, verschiedene Veranstaltungen zu besuchen. Und dann blicken wir mit Freude auf den nächsten Salon. Wir werden also sprechen über das Buch von Harald Wälzer und Richard David Precht. Hast du schon was vorbereitet? Ich kann bislang nur eins ankündigen, weil ich noch nicht weiß, wie umfangreich dann diese Arbeit daran wird, nämlich Nick Land. Das ist ja ein Ackzellrationist, der sich dann ganz nach rechts bewegt hat. Da ist jetzt bei Matthias von Salz ein Buch erschienen mit Texten von ihm, okkultes Denken und einer Korrespondenz, die interessanterweise Dietmar Daert mit diesem Nick Land geführt hat. Und dieses Buch will ich mir mal genauer ansehen.
Dietmar Daert, ich bin super Fan. Ich werde, wie schon angekündigt, zur demografischen Lage Russlands. Das ist wirklich super interessant. Das ist da ein Grund und Boden. Klar, ich sage jetzt, das ist eh die wichtigste Dimension, aber wie sehr es ausgeblendet wird, ist doch erstaunlich. Stephen King wird 75, er hat 75 Bücher geschrieben. Und weil auf Twitter ein Geburtstagsartikel empfohlen wurde von Matthias Kalle in der Zeit, werde ich suchen, ob ich ihn vielleicht auf Papier irgendwo finde, in den Tiefen des Stapels, der sich mittlerweile ansammelt. Ansonsten lesen wir die Online-Version, die steht nämlich frei zur Verfügung. Demin Hörst hat Kunst verbrannt. Es scheint da wohl irgendwie keine Ahnung, ob sich der Text dazu lohnt. Ich glaube, ich werde noch mal einen Blick nach Afrika werfen, weil diese ganze Dessert-Tech, wir brauchen Energie von denen, zwar nicht, weil wir Ölöcher bohren, sondern dann wirklich mal kooperativ statt kolonialistisch mit ihnen so Energiepartnerschaften schließen. Da gibt es auch interessante Texte, also so Brand 1 und so. Da verspricht man sich aber einiges. Der Ansicht wird es ein interessantes Alarm, aber ich freue mich natürlich auf das Buch.
Wunderbar.
Das wird ein Spektakel.
Dann einen schönen Monat und bis zum Salon.